Uh-huh.
Heat. Heat.
It's
hey.
Heat. Heat.
Heat. Hey. Hey. Hey.
Don't make up.
I know you.
feel.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Heat. Heat. N.
Heat.
Heat. Heat.
Hey, Heat.
Heat.
Hey,
hey, hey.
Down.
Hey. Hey.
Heat. Heat.
Black
down
back down back down back down back down
back down back down.
Take down
back.
Hey,
rock.
hey, hey.
Heat.
Are you
ready?
Hey, hey, hey.
Summer is in full swing in North America
and there's no better place to be than
the Sunshine Coast. This is Vancouver,
Canada.
Fresh off the heels of the regional
qualifier in Sydney, Australia, Ireelia
finally takes down a win at a major
tournament. But of course, around the
corner, we've got some very hungry,
dazzling Aurora players ready to take
home a win.
With 40 legends now in the game since
the release of Unleashed, anyone has a
chance and opportunity to climb to the
top of the tournament to take home that
grand prize. Now, of course, we don't
know who it's going to be. Could it be a
new legend, something like Rengar, who
gets to play units with ambush
abilities, or will we see a rise of the
sand soldiers themselves with Azir and
maybe take home another win like we saw
in Leo?
Now, Unleashed is only just now heating
up with our second stop here in
Vancouver for regional qualifiers. Don't
go anywhere. The action starts right
now.
Good morning, Riftbounders across the
globe. I'm Bear Bryant and I will be
your host and interviewer for this
weekend. And I'm joined by one of our
wonderful casters, the Eggman. I've got
the pleasure standing next to. How are
you feeling on this Vancouver sunny
morning? Yeah, I am super excited. This
is, you know, a huge event this weekend.
We've got not only a huge Rift event,
but we've got the new Unleashed meta
here for North America and excited where
it's going to take it.
>> Yeah, I Exactly. And that's just the
fact that we have because we have eight
exciting rounds for our players today in
the main event. Of course, we have a ton
of things that we're going to go over
before we sort of enlighten all of the
viewers at home. Round one is coming up,
but of course, we've got our schedule
that we want to break down for. had
eight rounds today and Saturday.
Starting right now as our players are
getting sat at this moment behind us.
And then of course, as we'll get to it
tomorrow as well, Sunday, five more
rounds of Swiss. You qualify for that by
going X and two essentially um by having
six wins and then a top eight single
elimination right afterwards.
>> Yeah. So 16 rounds across two days. A
lot of riffbound and we're really
excited for it.
>> Absolutely. But don't go anywhere
because these players are going to be
prized focused as they are going for
these wonderful prizes that we have. Of
course, the champion prize being that
Poppy Defender of the Meek alternate art
with a cool little porro in it is a big
fan of mine. Top eight spreads off for a
different one of course. And we have
even added extra prizing here that first
started in Sydney but is now carrying
over of course to these regional
qualifiers. That VEX play mat is a hot
commodity I've got to say.
>> Yeah, it looks fantastic and I love all
the prizing that has been added. It's
been really nice.
>> Yeah, exactly. They're going to get some
prize wall tickets as well for our
competitors that they can go of course
and redeem some of those plated legends.
But we don't want to forget some of the
other stuff that they're playing for.
The best of. These players are going to
be here and showing off and trying to
win the single best of for each of the
legends in our format. 40 legends across
the entire tournament. And I guarantee
you that every single one of them is
probably represented today.
>> Yeah. And you know, I've been on the
floor. I've been listening to
discussions what people are trying to do
with it. Uh people are hungry for these
100%.
>> Yeah. There I think there's even
specific teams out there that are like
hunting for these.
always
trying to rack up as many trophies.
You can earn more of these at across all
the events that we've not only had
earlier this year, but ones that we have
coming up afterwards. So, we're going to
go into our road map, which explains all
the events that we've seen already so
far. Of course, Houston, Spirit Forge,
we've passed these ones quite a while
now. Bolognia, Las Vegas. We're going to
go to our next one which is the
unleashed format which is where we are
currently at essentially. We just had
Sydney that we've already come and
passed through and here we are right now
with Vancouver but we don't want to
forget in a couple weeks time we've got
Utrect and Hartford coming up
afterwards.
>> Yeah. So we're pretty much kind of in
the middle half of this format but then
we've got a new set Vendetta coming out
July 31st. some events from their
radiance on October which uh maybe we'll
get some hints of what behind that as
well but uh finally ending in Los
Angeles which I'm from so definitely
going to be that that one. Absolutely. I
mean you're right. I I have heard we
might get a little bit of inklings of
some information on maybe some set five
and also maybe some set four stuff. So
make sure you tune into that tomorrow
before we go into our top cuts. But
that's for tomorrow. We want to talk
about some predictions here for our
lovely casters this weekend. And I
didn't make one any of myself, but uh
I'll be honest, you guys got a little
I'm not going to use the word lazy, but
you all are thinking on the same horse
here.
>> Yeah, I mean I publicly said Diana on
the way over here, right? And uh seemed
to be a pretty popular pick, but Ursy's,
you know, the believer in Leblanc, which
also a very popular legend right now. A
lot of people trying to make it work and
definitely could be in the top eight.
>> I mean, we saw both of these legends
across the ones that y'all have picked
be in the top eight for Sydney and
Zidan. I know he was back and I believe
he's running it back on that sort of
baited hook Leblanc deck. So very good
pick here I think across all of you. Of
course I think Allen EQ and some other
known players I think looking to still
play that Diana for this format. But
>> Eggman we've got a lot of Riftbound to
get through not just today but tomorrow.
And I think we want to hear from our
casters for our first round. So don't go
anywhere. We're going to go ahead and
send it to them to say hello in our
morning here in Vancouver.
Hey everyone and welcome to Vancouver.
I'm Alex
>> and I'm Silverfuse
>> and we are beyond excited to be bringing
you the Riftbound action here in Canada.
I cannot explain to you how excited I am
for this event because we have so many
incredible players who have established
themselves in the scene looking to make
a splash here in Canada. Yeah, it's been
really great to start seeing these
stories come to life and we're seeing
players who are making these top cuts
over and over again and we're really
excited to see who's going to take it
down this weekend.
>> Now, as you saw in our predictions, you
and I agreed that Diana just might have
an edge here from a competitive
standpoint. What are your thoughts on
Diana and whether or not it can take
home the uh the championship?
>> Well, first off, I am a big Diana
believer because I love her. I love how
high agency she is. And in these big
tournaments where you're playing so many
rounds of Swiss, having high agency and
not leaving things down to variance as
much is so important. So I think that's
why so many players favor her because
she has a high amount of agency, high
amount of draw, and a high amount of
movement.
>> Now, one thing I will say is that
talking about those predictions, had I
known we were all going to generally
pick Diana, I might have tried something
a little different. I'm going to say
that I think that Azir is probably going
to have a really good showing as well.
We saw a really good result in Asia, but
ultimately I think that at the end of
the day with Riftbound, anything can
happen. We saw last uh last regional in
Sydney, we had an amazing Teemo run. So
realistically, like this is going to be
an amazing event to watch.
>> Oh yeah, there's a lot of things to
watch out for. For example, we saw
Rengar get number 11, which wasn't
really on anyone's radar. So seeing that
and of course the big bad Aurora is
around and who knows what that will do
as we did see it get second in Sydney.
So on Aurora, obviously that's a topic
of conversation. A lot of people are
sideboarding a ton of stuff to
counteract Aurora. So if you want to
make it into the top cut, how much tech
are you going to have to fight through
as an Aurora player?
>> Well, we've actually seen people start
to mainboard here. Hey, instead of just
putting it on the sideboard, but almost
every player sideboard is just loaded
with things that say, Aurora, I don't
want to have to deal with you. I want to
delete you. I want to remove you from
your hand. I want to take you away out
of the game as much as possible. because
Aurora does rely so much on getting
Aurora down and without it most of the
decks flop. So having that gear hate and
even putting it into the main board as
well has been something that a lot of
players have seen is worth doing.
>> So at the end of the day what's
fascinating about Aurora is that you
have so many different legends that can
play Aurora. Pretty much almost all of
the body legends have been at least
experimenting with it. Which are the
ones that you think stand above the rest
that could potentially make it to top
cut? Well, of course, we have Civer as
we did see it perform very well. Um, my
personal favorite though, I love
Misfortune. I think the ganking ability
from her ability just allows you to do
so much more with the deck and you're
able to maintain battlefields a bit more
and also having access to bullet time to
have another way beside just flurry the
blades.
>> And so, with regards to legends, are
there any dark horses you want to talk
about? Ones that you think that people
aren't necessarily discussing, but just
might surprise to the upside. Well, we
have to talk about Pike for sure because
Pike is something that a lot of players
have realized. You know what? This
purple red, it's actually better than we
thought. And Pike has a lot of
opportunity to uh it has the red removal
and also is part of Chaos, of course.
So, you can't really go wrong with it.
So, I like seeing a lot of players
experiment with Pike. And the other one
is putting Aurora in Yi. As a lot of
players had really gone to that
mid-range Y again, we are now looking at
seeing Aurora in Yi. And I'm really
interested to see if that performs since
we saw it a lot in set one and it kind
of fell off in set two, but we're seeing
it again in set three and I think it's
going to keep having an uptick.
>> Yeah. And so you bring up Pike.
Obviously Pike's game plan is to be very
aggressive, perhaps even disruptive
depending on the deck build, but
something that Fury's been struggling
with is Vex apathetic. Now Chaos has
been tremendous in the meta. How do you
think Vex has had a uh impact on the top
cuts and how competitive these types of
uh accelerated and aggressive decks can
be?
>> Yeah, we talked about how meta warping
that Aurora has been, but Vex is right
up there on that list as well. So, Vex
being able to say I pay four to get a
four P or four cost and then also four
might and no power required for it is
huge. And also, it has deflect and went
on a battlefield stopping all the
acceleration. It's been a big reason why
we've seen Fury not as common now
because you can't just play that Darius
or that Kai'Sa and accelerate it. And
it's I mean it shuts it down all of a
sudden. It shuts down a lot of different
decks.
>> Now this weekend is one of the last
opportunities to get the best of cards
for the Origins Heroes, right? Cuz we do
have that expiration so to speak. If you
were playing in this event and you were
targeting one of the best of,s who would
you be targeting?
>> Mine is Jinx. I think there's a
different way to build her and I'm kind
of keeping that secret for hopefully
Hartford, but I'm looking to I think
Jinx has some opportunity to play. Of
course, she does have access to Chaos,
so you can't really go wrong, but she
has been one of the weaker decks and she
is also a classic because everyone loves
Arcane, of course.
>> Yeah, of course. Arcane was one of my
absolute favorite shows I've watched in
a long time. And uh like for me, being
introduced to the lore of League of
Legends via Riftbound has been a
tremendous boon for uh my enjoyment of
all the media that they have and it's
been remarkable. So, with regards to the
tourn, we have eight rounds of Swiss uh
and uh who do you expect to be perhaps a
legend that has been underperforming in
recent qualifiers, but perhaps might
impress to the upside this week?
>> H, that's hard to say. I mean, I would
still, funny enough, say that Diana is
still a little bit underperformed,
although she's very common. I was
expecting her to win by this point
already. That's one of the big ones for
me. Uh, yeah, that's I I really see
Diana doing well. So to me, her not
winning already is her underperforming
in my eyes.
>> So of the new unleashed legends, right,
for me, I want to say Ivvern, I would
love to see Ivvern do well. And um but
like the thing is is like these hold
decks, right? These decks that are
trying to hold even Vex as a legend,
they're holding these battlefields and
now we have these new tools like
Ruination that can just completely wipe
out an unchecked power is making a
comeback. Do you feel like a lot of
people are starting to tech towards
these hold mechanics which are starting
to I don't want to say gain popularity
but in unleash they've gained a new
life.
>> Yeah, a big thing is it's a been a very
might dependent meta of just being able
to get a little bit above the your
opponent. So that's why we see decks
that can break those holds even such as
like Annie coming out of the woodworks
and having the access to cleave for
instance of just being like you know
what you have eight I get nine I win the
game cuz I broke your hold which is
really important.
>> Yeah. One of the things about Riftbound
Unleashed in particular is Baron Nasher.
Baron Nasher has been included in many
of the decks, including we saw in the
top six Teemo. How is Baron changing the
landscape of well, I'm using the word
landscape. Obviously, he's adding the
Baron pit, the new battlefield. How do
you find that Baron's impacting the
meta?
>> Baron has been great for decks such as
Pike. It is one of the main win
conditions of the deck and then also
putting it into the sideboard as well.
Uh big thing is Diana. If you're Diana
vers Diana putting into the sidebar, it
also breaks things for Vex as well. It
just makes your opponent have to play
differently because you're having access
to three battlefields rather than two
and it makes the win condition harder
and it also makes it where holding
becomes a lot more sustainable.
>> Yeah, for me one of the things that I've
been thinking about a lot is Rengar.
Rengar obviously in Fury as well. Trophy
Hunter is one of the best new cards in
the set in my opinion and I feel like
it's being played in a lot of different
uh different decks. Now, the ambush
mechanic obviously uh works not not
great against something like a Vex
apathetic. It tends to shut down those
aggressive style plays. Do you think
that Vex and the ambush mechanic are
kind of at odds with each other? And if
those like fury style aggressive plays
uh can ultimately overcome the
popularity of Chaos to make top cut.
>> Yeah, it's definitely been at odds with
each other. However, we have seen Annie
be successful who does run a lot of
ambush mechanics. And if there is a way
to remove the deck, she is still only at
four might at the end of the day. And if
you are able to play things to get get
over her, then you can be just fine.
However, these whole decks that have
access to Vex right away, such as Vex
herself, it's always on curve. And we do
see decks that don't run uh ve running
Vex as the champion, such as Aurelia,
being able to play Vex early can just
win us that as well. and Vex, not even
just, you know, Pike and the Fury. It
does great against Aurelia as well.
>> Now, with Aurelia, obviously a
tremendous result in Sydney, one might
say the best result that you can
possibly get. What do you think makes
that deck and that archetype so
incredibly powerful and resilient
against the likes of Aurora?
>> Well, the big thing is is that the deck
doesn't have that many weaknesses and it
has access to defy and um you know,
being able to stop catalyst and that
ramp for instance, and you are pretty
quick. You also have a lot of card draw
with Stellorn Herder as well. So being
able to filter through your deck very
quickly, find your answers is really big
for the deck.
>> For me, one of my absolute favorite
legends from Unleashed has been Lilia.
Now, of course, we've I feel like I'm
I'm a broken record here. We've talked
about Vex Apathetic a number of times,
but do you think despite that and
despite how damaging Vex Apathetic can
be to those aggressive style archetypes,
do you think Lilia can make a splash
this weekend? I think she definitely
can, especially because there are so
many players in this, you might just be
paired up against non-vex decks. It is
possible. There's a lot of best of
hunters out there and being able to get
the right matchups. Lilia can definitely
take advantage of that.
>> I love that you bring that up cuz one of
my favorite things about the Riftbound
competitive scene is the best of. The
reason for this is because we often see
a very wide spread across the meta,
right? You see representation from every
single legend because the prizing is so
fantastic. How do you think that uh you
know kind of impacts a player's
decision-m when they're choosing what
they're going to be bringing to a
regional?
>> Oh, I think it has a large impact
because really you're looking for that
top 64 or you're looking to hunt for
that middle legend and because they do I
mean they are very collectible and
players love them. So, you can't go
wrong going for it especially when you
feel like you have a tech that other
people aren't seeing and if you feel
like your matchups are good enough, you
can do very well with it.
>> Okay guys, we got great news. is you're
going to be able to vote for who our
show match is going to be. So, in the
Twitch chat area here, you'll be able to
actually vote whether or not you would
like to see the following. On the screen
here, we do have uh we have Vi, the
Pilttover Enforcer versus Lilia. And
then, of course, we have Lilia versus
Azir. Oh my gosh, these are fantastic
matchups. And you guys are the ones that
get to vote.
>> And also, I want to point out here that
we have TSS the secret sauce. Gail wins
here who has won the best of Yaso in the
past. So, I really want to see what he
cooks up. I'm a little bit biased, but
I'm good with any of these.
>> I absolutely love this. We were just
talking about Lilia and how excited we
are. And we do have a guaranteed Lilia
match here now by the Pilttover
Enforcer. She has struggled a little bit
in the meta. What do you think that she
has to do to overcome something like
Ailia?
>> Oo, that's tough. Uh, a big thing is she
does not have access to Vex, who we
talked about shuts down that Lilia at
times. So, this is a pretty good matchup
for Vi. A big thing is just having that
additional might to overtake the
battlefields. And I mean, this seems
like a pretty good matchup for Vi is my
big thing on it. And match B is Lilia
versus Azir. Okay, these are literally
two of my favorite legends in the game.
Azir I played extensively during uh
Spirit Forge. What would you think about
the match up between Lilia and Azir?
>> I mean, a lot of it's going to be Azir
going wide and getting that early
equipment. Of course, Arise being a key
card in that as well. So, I would say
that maybe a little bit Azir favorite.
However, with all the temporary units
that Lilia is able to go for, I could
see Lilia getting on the board pretty
quickly too and taking over Azir, it
feels like it's overall a pretty close
matchup for that reason. Well, the
people have spoken and the winning match
is going to be Vi, the Piltover Enforcer
versus Lilia. And uh I I got to tell
you, I'm so excited. Uh you know, as
much as I love Lilia, I think am I
rooting for Vi here? I think I might
have to because I mean, I think Lilia is
starting to establish itself as a
premier aggressive deck. But like, but
how can you not love Vi?
>> I mean, we have to love Vi, especially
with Fury being such an underdog of this
meta. It's one of the least
underrepresented decks. So being able to
see Fury do well would be a lot of fun
as well.
>> Yeah, it's kind of funny talking about
uh Fury being an under represented I
mean we're literally just removed from
Draven absolutely dominating Spirit
Forge and then of course we had Kaisa in
Origins doing amazing work and now but
it's in unleash it has been relatively
quiet
>> and um okay and we do have our deck list
with us so we'll go ahead and take a
look at those. Uh first off, we have
Gailwinds on that uh Lilia as we talked
about. It is running a lot of gear hate
as we expected. Uh we'll actually go to
that VI before this. Yeah. So with this
VI here, one of my favorite cards is
going to be Pike. This card is not only
playable from hidden, but it is an
aggressive card, one that you're going
to utilize to good effectiveness. And
one from Origins that I think is low-key
one of the best cards in the game is
Noxis Hopeful. when you are playing many
cards and trying to be aggressive. Knox
coming out is a two four thanks to that
Legion ability is going to be a
difficult thing for your opponent to
overcome.
>> And I want to say that we are running
the new Rengar here which is as we like
to call it the keyword soup Rengar here.
Has Accelerate, assault two, deflect,
ganking. He really has it all at four
for four. Not bad at all. And of course,
you have Falling Star, which remains to
be an absolutely incredible removal tool
for Fury. Being able to target three
different units for three damage is
impeccable. Now, it is an an amazingly
costly spell at two power, but three is
a damage uh level where you're able to
take out a lot of key um kind of uh
units, including like the the Leblanc
Chosen and etc. So, I do think that uh
you know, this is an excellent call in
the current meta.
>> Yes. And I also love to see red Jin here
as well. This was a card that a lot of
players were very hyped about at the
start. And when it moves, it gives you
an energy and a power, which has been
huge. And a lot of players have said
this card is still underplayed right
now. And a big thing is Fury is a bit
underplayed right now. So Jin hasn't
really had its proper time to shine. I'm
really looking forward to see that
today.
>> And we do have two of of the Kai'Sa
survivor, which is in my opinion one of
the best cards in Riftbound as a whole.
Um, now we are going to go over to the
second deck here. This is going to be
the Ailia deck. Uh, this is from uh from
Gailwinds here. Now, this here is uh
it's a deck that's obviously utilizing
the Fon um chosen champion. Now, what do
you see here that stands out to you?
>> Well, something that I really love is
the Heart of Dark Ice. A big thing is
you are throwing a bunch of temporary
units in over and over again. And Heart
of Dark Ice says, I will now give those
value as well. Instead of having a three
might sprite, you now have a six might
sprite. And we talked about how this
meta is all about having enough might to
break through holds. And Heart of Dark
Ice gives you so much value and allows
you to break through holds that you
wouldn't have been able to before.
>> Yeah, especially with those accelerated
sprites. Well, not accelerated. They
come in ready, of course. And uh when
you're talking about the comm archetype,
we have to talk about the tricks. It all
starts with defy. Defy, one of the best
tricks in the game. I mean, when you're
able to counter uh counter spells here
and and definitely gain an advantage in
showdowns, it's something that this
archetype can rely on. Something I
really want to highlight here is
Unchecked Power in the main board. We
talked about how Aurora is the big bad
of the format. And this is a way of
hating on Aurora, but also other decks
that are trying to build those large
holds as well. And because we're running
so many temporary units, we're say, oh,
you know, if ours dies, no big deal. But
Unchecked Power can be a huge nail in
the coffin for a lot of these decks that
we'll see today. And with regards to the
general idea of this deck, I think
Arena's greatest the battlefield there.
It really illustrates how aggressive
Lilia wants to be. Get on the board,
score the points, end the game fast. You
don't want to be sticking around against
an Aurora meta. Let's move to the game.
I don't want to say gain popularity, but
in Unleash, they've gained a new life.
>> Yeah, a big thing is it's been a very
might dependent meta of just a little
bit above the
All right, looks like we're just getting
ready to get started here. And uh I'm
actually so excited for this matchup.
>> Yes. Uh that was one that I wanted to
see personally because I wanted to see
how the best of Yaso player built the
Lilia deck. I know it's been a big
favorite of a lot of players and they've
wanted to make it work. As we said, Vex
has been really tough into it. And we do
have our first battlefields here.
>> It's going to be seat of power for
Gailwinds and Forge of the Fluffed. Uh
what are your thoughts on these
battlefields and the the choices into
game one?
>> Well, first off, I want to say seed of
power has been on a huge uptick as it's
very strong going neutral for sure. And
on top of that being able to draw so
frequently with the Lilia because you
are playing things like sprite burst and
you're are able to take battlefields
pretty easily.
>> So if you're Lilia here, what's your
general game plan? What are you trying
to do to counteract the power that Vi is
able to output?
>> Of course, you want to get on the board
early. You want to be sneaky and you
want to get things points quickly
because the later this game goes, the
more it favors the spy.
>> We can have some grace,
>> of course.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Okay, we're just getting set up here.
Arena's greatest here. Oh, we have
different battlefields
>> and some confirmation on that there as
we get started. No, we don't. The just
the graphics a little different.
>> And looks like both players will be
looking to make their mulligans here.
ready.
>> We do see two Rex eyes in hand for Vi.
>> Okay, here we go. We're getting started
here. And uh we got a Raven Bloom
student coming out to start us off.
>> And it looks like we are
>> Oh, that was very Yeah, we were missing
a room there. And I love that. I love
the sportsmanship we see in the
Riftbound community here. That is
remarkable sportsmanship. They're on
camera. They're nervous.
>> You absolutely love to see that. And I
think that's one of the benefits of uh
of playing in these types of events face
to face with people that uh you know
love a game as much as you do. You do
see those moments and uh that
sportsmanship does not go unnoticed.
Absolutely fantastic here as we go to
four runes.
>> That's okay.
>> Let's see what they play. I can't uh
quite make out their hand here, but we
got an unchecked power. I do see that
that might come in to help later.
>> So both players did find their two
drops, which is very big. Something I
want to highlight too is we do have the
powdery porro who can be very good in
this meta that has a good amount of
removal into it. So that is one of the
cards that Fury does have access to. We
have seen a lot of the other such as
calm and mine get access to new drops
that have been very critical and really
we're staying with the triedand-true
powdy porto here.
>> Yeah, the power portal is absolutely
fantastic. It was a meta staple during
Origins. I'm glad to see that it's doing
well here as well. We do have the Sprite
Fountain come out. This is one of the
new cards from Unleash and Sprite
Fountain is an absolutely remarkable
gear. It is exactly what Lilia wants to
do on these early turns. It creates a
tremendous amount of of pushing power,
scoring potential, and it's something
that Vi is going to have to deal with
near immediately.
>> Yep. And also getting that seed of power
draw this early in the game, just having
access to more utility, and we get the
mask here as well. So, we're going to be
having some strong sprites coming up
here pretty quickly.
>> Yes, that's that's right. And then we're
going on to the next turn here. Pouty
Portoro is available. Now it is it's not
going to be able to really contest much
here. We do have a tapped out uh Lilia
player here. Gilwinds is tapped out. So
perhaps with a trick you could take out
that Raven Bloom student. We'll have to
see what their decision making is here.
>> And if we can just try We do have that
that falling star in hand, but won't
expect it to be used here quite yet. Not
enough value there.
Is that a Rex eye as well? It's
>> having two Rex eyes at hand.
>> Let's go.
>> Five for cycle for Kai'Sa.
>> All right, it's Kai'Sa survivor coming
on out. Accelerated. So, they're going
to be able to contest these
battlefields.
>> Yep, we will be able to take one and
draw for Kai'Sa for sure. And
unfortunately fluffed. Uh something to
note here is it's pretty good for Vi,
but it really doesn't do anything for
the Lilia player here. Of course,
>> it's a really smart neutral battlefield
choice.
>> And that's going to be a point scored
for Vi. They are tapped out. And uh
we're just waiting to see. Oh, that's
right. Draw there.
>> Additional. So,
>> yep. The Kaisa draw very important to
remember. Part of the reason why we've
seen her be so solid in all these red
decks. She is really what is keeping
Fury afloat right now.
>> Of course.
>> And we are going to reinforce the
battlefield there in past turn. Now,
Lilia does have the sprite fountain
there. It will temporarily uh will
temporarily get destroyed. There we do
have the ready sprite being generated.
>> So, they're in a position to score
additional points here, which is exactly
what Lilia wants to do.
>> Yes, does have the opportunity to score
a point here. Would love to find a way
to take this other battlefield to be
able to draw from that seat of power.
However, with only five runes available,
it's pretty unlikely.
>> And looks like we'll have the Lilia come
out.
>> Where' they go?
>> This is Yeah. Yeah. So, they're
generating the sprite with the legend
ability, utilizing the discount being uh
generated by the existing sprite. And it
looks like they're just trying to chip
away at the battlefield a little bit
here to uh generate a more favorable
favorable trade.
>> And I really love how we're taking the
mask of foresight and or and just being
able to throw in one at a time. So, we
get extra value because each time you
attack with just one, you get an extra
might. So, being able to make that trade
with Kai'Sa and then making that
favorable trade as well.
>> Yeah, excellent play there. Well done.
As we move on to the Pilttover Enforcers
Tour here, um it looks like Jin is in
hand as well. Generates a lot of value.
It moves back and forth through the
battlefields. And it is gen.
>> Yeah. And we talked about how much we've
wanted to see this Jin because it does
give you essentially a ramping ability
with that extra energy and that extra
power. And we have seen how gold has
affected the meta in the past. And
essentially, he's kind of generates a
gold that's active right away is a way
to think of him.
>> Yeah, absolutely. And the thing I love
about Jyn as well is that like he does
have ganking and deflect. It's kind of
easy to overlook uh those uh those
keywords there. He has a modest five
might uh four might body, my apologies,
but at the end of the day, you are
looking for that movement to generate
that value.
>> And we do see the champion Lilia out on
the deck now or out on the board now.
>> Okay. And uh yeah, there's going to be a
lot of uh movement being generated there
from that Lilia champ, which is going to
allow more sprites to be generated,
which discounts the legend further. So
it looks like our Lilia player already
at four points is off to a fantastic
start.
>> Yes. And note that the Lilia is not
accelerated there. So won't be leaving
us right behind and unfortunately can't
conquer that other battlefield. Getting
the seed of power here for the extra
draw would be great, but just not quite
enough runes to do it,
>> of course. And uh we also have like
sprite burst uh in the deck. Now I'm not
sure if they've drawn it. I don't think
they have, but sprite burst would allow
them to then discount their legend even
further, generate more sprites, and then
push in. And uh yeah, especially with
that mask, you're able to generate a lot
of value.
>> So something that the VI player here is
really going to have to watch out for is
that one of unchecked power. If they
develop here and start taking too much
of the battlefield, we could have a huge
issue for this VI player. So, I'm
interested to see how they decide to
navigate this.
>> So, they're going to generate the uh the
value, the extra resources from the gin,
score a point.
>> You're at two, correct?
>> And uh do you think they try to contest
that sprite?
>> I would be surprised if they did that.
Mask of foresight is still up there. So,
it is a little bit deceptive there. So,
it is a stronger sprite than what we're
used to.
>> So, we'll do three.
>> Okay, let's see what this next play is.
And it's going to be Rexai
>> for the accelerate
>> and uses the Jin.
uh energy and power to help with that
Rexai accelerate as well.
>> And this is the aggressiveness of Fury
that we were talking about earlier in
the open and we're starting to see it
here.
>> And there's the Falling Star.
>> That's a fantastic play and that's
really going to set the Lilia player
back because you want to generate value
with that chosen champion and falling
star just completely wipes it out. And
as we said before, that three damage.
There's so many vital champions and
units that are simply three might and
that is a fantastic removal and suddenly
Vi is back in the game.
>> So, one thing I'm a little bit surprised
to see is not seeing that Falling Star
come out here first and then going for
that conquer and then trying to get that
draw from the seed of power as well. Of
course, we did use the Jin power. So,
that is likely why we saw that decision.
But it's interesting because there's two
different things of do you care about
recycling the rune more or do you care
about the draw more
>> uncheck and that that's the unchecked
power coming on down and that's exactly
what you were worried about establishing
a board state and then having it
completely wiped.
>> Yes, essentially resetting the board
here and Lilia because it has access to
these sprites that is are ready to go a
lot of the time. Oh, even has the two
drop as well. This two drop is so
critical because you're going to be able
to get those extra points here. Jyn has
to reestablish the or Vi has to
reestablish the board. This is looking
really good for our Lilia player now.
>> Absolutely. And not to mention along
with that mask that Lil Porro is going
to defend a battlefield pretty well.
>> Oh yeah, with it shield and the mask.
It's like I said, deceptive. A lot of
Lilia is deceptively strong with the
ability to just buff up all these. And
we haven't even seen the heart of Dark
Ice yet.
>> No, we haven't.
>> Okay, Kai'Sa survivor coming on in. And
that does make perfect sense. So, you do
want to start getting that uh that uh
that hand going in and Rex eye with the
followup. So, they're trying to
reestablish their board presence here.
>> The big thing is we do know that that
unchecked power is a one of in the deck.
We don't have to worry about the second
one now.
>> So, let's see what uh what Lilia does
here as uh past turn yet. I think that
uh we're still Yeah, there's the activ
uh organized.
>> Really excited to see how this game
continues to develop. Four to three. It
actually looked like Lilia was starting
to run away with the game a little bit
>> and then even with the unchecked power
then suddenly we find ourselves VI is
right back in it
>> and we are ready to go with the porro
going into that forge
>> there's the fifth point and uh if you're
trying to be aggressive you vitally want
to score this sixth point right if you
can and they're going to be able to even
just naturally with the legend ability
which I think has remained untapped but
uh long story short yeah there it is
that's that sixth point so now you're
going to be uh threatening to win the
game on that next turn if you're able
taken.
>> And I just want to point out how much
value this seat of power has generated
for the Lilia player. It we've had
multiple draws from it. And as we know
in card games, we love drawing cards. So
being able to play that on a neutral
battlefield is so good. And on top of
that was able to go first and was able
to just take both those battlefields
pretty early. So still establish
establishing those points. And also
we'll see what Vi does with this. Looks
like a little bit. Yep, there is the
pass. and we'll have Vi maybe will be
able to draw something good with the
Kai'Sa. However though, the double mask
of foresight now makes these units so
hard to break through.
>> Not just that, but you have three open
energy and against a cal player, you
don't want to see three open energy.
>> Exactly. There are so many options with
calm and then also Mind even has some
things as well that can help out.
>> Yeah. Like I expect to see disciplines
which obviously you know they not only
buff the defending unit alongside those
masks which they're just
disproportionately massive. We have the
shield of the porro. You're right it is
going to be a bit of a challenge but
they have to knock off at least one of
these uh these units here.
>> Yes. Has to be able to do something
which we've seen that falling star
already come out here. And looks like we
might be seeing Vi being played here
ready to go as well.
Vi does generate a lot of power and
might. We'll have to see what their
decision-m is on the uh might level of
the might of uh Vi, sorry.
>> Yeah. So, she recycles her cards to
decide how much might she will be
gaining and it's a really hard decision
because just we talked about how
critical having just enough might is and
you want to be able to use her
potentially in the future as well. So,
if you just say, "Oh, I'm going to
recycle all my cards now, make a giant
unit." Well, we still have a lot of
points left to go in this game if Vi
wants to get back into it
>> and and Vi has well in Origins was one
of the
champs to play and for the reason of
like you know in Annie you were able to
generate a ton of value generating a lot
very large trash and then make Vi
massive ride the wind it over
>> in this case here with Vi. So it did add
uh so it's a eight might unit here. It's
going to be able to do uh it's
definitely going to be able to take one
of the battlefields here and it doesn't
have to worry about like gust or
anything along those lines. So we'll
have to see how the Lilia player does
respond.
>> Correct.
>> As of the biggest thing would just being
to find a way to
>> pump up this porro to be able to defend
here. And it's notable as the players
had motioned there that uh the the
legend of Vine doing the excess damage
here is something in mind and uh
>> targeting stro targeting sprite.
>> Okay,
>> let's see what's uh what's done here.
>> Yeah,
>> masks will trigger on.
>> There goes the mask as well.
>> Yep.
>> And we have
>> I will stupify
>> that mirror that came out.
>> So that would make it so it doesn't
trigger. Can we get dice for the star?
>> All right.
>> Uh, that will put her to seven. Yes.
>> It looks like they're sorting out uh the
details here. Stupify being played as
well.
>> Yep. And with the mass trigger here from
the sprite to seven.
>> Oh, yes.
>> So, we have stupify on VI putting her to
seven.
>> Um,
>> and we'll see if we get a response here.
>> Yeah. Okay. Well,
>> so that's going to allow it to transfer
some of that might over to the
>> VI on top of drawing a card
>> for
uh
>> so it looks like Rexi will likely pay.
>> Yes.
>> On to Vi.
>> By Rexi.
>> Yes.
>> So, can I get more?
>> So, our lily player is tapped out here
and it looks like Vi is going to be able
to take this battlefield.
>> She's plus five minus one plus three.
We're not going to see a uh
>> so
>> not going to see a double hold here.
>> Nope. The game will continue. And looks
like this Y will take it.
>> Yep. This is fine.
>> Okay.
>> And there goes the
>> from the
>> sprite. It did a lot of work though. I
mean, this is a temporary unit that just
got multiple cards out of this V.
>> Yeah, there's no question about it. And
uh like both players had to expel a lot
of resources for that particular
showdown. And it actually shows the
value in why when you're trying to
contest or trying to hold these
battlefields, carrying the extra runes
into the next turn there as a lily
player had done was so valuable because
it allowed them to contest and force the
VI player to expend more additional
resources.
>> And a really important thing here is
that VI, if you've assigned three excess
damage, you may exhaust me to ready a
unit. So we are here readying this VI
and going for the next battlefield
again. Yep, that's what I have.
>> And they are going to wipe out both
battlefields here. Score two points. And
that was absolutely vital. Absolutely
vital to not only just stay caught up in
the game from a score perspective, but
to reduce the opportunity for Lilia to
close out the game next turn.
>> So, another interesting thing here is we
had two options. And I actually like the
line that we took here of not using the
Kai'Sa to also hold the battlefield
because V would have been able to draw a
card
because if you had put the Kai'Sa in,
you wouldn't have got the draw cuz
you're no longer conquering cuz you got
it from the VI. Instead says, I want to
keep my Kai'Sa safe for a conquer in the
future. Doesn't want to have to worry
about these readied sprites just taking
the Kai'Sa out for free. So although you
could be like, is this card worth it? I
definitely agree that the answer is no.
And we are going to generate sprites
here. And this is going to be a
challenge for the uh VI player here
because you're going to have two sprites
come out that's going to discount the
legend as well. And each of these
sprites can be sent in individually and
they're going to be absolutely massive
thanks to those masks. And then we have
the sprite fountain as well. There is
just so many options here to just
whittle away at Vi and ultimately
perhaps take this game.
>> Yes, this is looking really good for
Lilia. And there's only two runes up
here for Vi. I don't really see what she
can do here. So, we're ready to see
these sprites crash in and potentially
take this first game. However, I do see
those death grips in there. Is that
enough is the question.
>> Yeah, the death grips are going to allow
them to essentially pump Vi and generate
additional might there. Make it a little
more resilient. We'll have to see. Oh,
it's going to be three sprites in.
They're going to contest the Vi right
now.
>> I love this play because we're playing
around that death grip. That's a very
good play.
>> Excellent game by both players here.
Lilia takes game one
>> and congratulations to Gail wins on that
first game and we'll see what we get for
the next battlefields which we have
sunken temple and Dusk Grows Lab.
>> I love Dusk Grow's Lab. That is an
absolutely fantastic battlefield for the
Lilia player. A little risky into a meta
where LeBlanc is as popular as it is,
but I think that this makes perfect
sense because you're going to want to
utilize uh that ability especially with
your temporary units.
>> Yes. And then also the sunken temple I
think is also a really good choice here
because the big thing with it is if you
don't have five might units then you
don't get the value from it. And if
Lilia doesn't find its buffs then it's
just throwing in a bunch of three might
sprites. So it's potential that both
these players are getting more value
from their battlefields than their
opponent is which is always a great
start.
>> Yeah, both of these are actually perfect
battlefields for their independent
strategies and they're not really going
to benefit from it cuz as you said Lilia
is not going to be able to generally go
above five. Now, we did see those masks,
which did have a surprising impact on
the power of those sprites. Uh, but uh
I'm just really enjoying uh what we're
seeing here thus far.
>> And then also, of course, that Heart of
Dark Ice. We're not saying that it won't
happen, but it's just going to take a
little bit of setup to get there.
>> We do see a salvage in hand. Okay, so
the salvage is uh kind of brought in.
Might have been sideboarded there. Uh we
do have uh it looks like the VIP for is
going to be going first here. Let's see
if they have a porro to get us started.
>> That is also legal.
>> And the pass. That's always a bit tough,
especially when you're going first.
>> Yeah, especially against a deck like
Lilia. It's going to be extremely
aggressive.
>> I have one.
>> Yes. And this is another VC still wants
that good tempo as well. Generally, Fury
does. So, the fact that it's missing out
on that tempo makes it tough. Although,
the game's not lost by any means. It's
just going to be an uphill battle. Now,
>> yeah. And what you can even do here if
you're the Lilia player on the next turn
is you can move um the chosen champion
into a battlefield. It'll generate a
sprite. It won't be readied. It'll be
there but it'll discount the legend
ability which allows you to then play a
ready spite. Take the other battlefield
if necessary.
>> So we see that dangerous falling star in
hand and we saw that it was very helpful
at first and also we do have the Fiora
coming out. However, if the another
three might unit is played here and
there isn't a way to stop it or buff up,
this falling star could be gamechanging,
assuming that we draw the red ring to be
able to play it.
>> Yeah, falling star was an absolutely
massive play for them on the prior game.
It allowed them to basically keep in it
and so you're right, being able to use
that to good effect is going to be
important here. We do have two sprites
coming out. This is going to be
extremely aggressive and allow them to
take both battlefields here. Score quick
two points and get on the board.
>> And Lilia is doing exactly what Lilia
wants to do. Getting on the board and
then saying the pressure is on you. You
have to react to me now.
>> I'm doing it.
>> We have passed turn here.
>> My dextrous ability is
>> this is probably not a moment where you
want to obviously you want to wait for
two valid targets for the falling star.
you could consider. I mean, taking out a
sprite with a pawn star is not
necessarily what you want to do. But the
problem is the chosen champion is going
to generate so much value over time and
it's especially with with Lilia and that
legend ability discounting the legend
ability over and over again. It's just
it's free value.
>> We'll do this.
>> It's important to note here that the
Lilia player is tapped out and we will
see that quick draw sword. I was just
thinking about that because you give
that deflect and the ganking to the
Fiora and then also give yourself the
option for that sunken temple. On top of
that, the buy gets triggered because we
had an additional over three might for
that conquer.
>> Yeah. And then of course the sucking
temple as well.
>> Yes, you can order it. Okay.
>> Lots of value going on here. Really
strong play for taking that long sword.
>> Here, we'll do that.
>> Yeah. And one of the things when you're
battling a Lilia, you want to kind of
stay on the field. You want to be able
to keep getting points. You don't want
to fall too far behind because Lilia can
win a battle of attrition. It's able to
send these sprites at you over and over
and over again. And as long as you're
able to kind of withstand that then and
there we go, there's the second point
being scored there. Uh you're able to
kind of maintain control of the board.
But once you start falling behind the
resources that Lilia is able to just
send at you for almost I don't want to
say no cost, but they just don't pay the
toll that you are paying to keep on the
board.
>> Yeah, we previously saw how much that
unchecked power did just disrupt VI's
plan. Uh we'll have to see that comes
into play again. uh at the time it
wouldn't be that great of a target, but
if we see the uh VI deck really start
piling on those battlefields again, we
might see that. However, this Fiora is
going to be incredibly hard to deal with
for the Lilia deck.
>> Yeah, now they could I didn't quite see
their hand there. Like a sprite burst
here would allow them to be a little
aggressive, but getting over Fior is
going to be hard. Um
>> disciplines and stuff like that. They
don't have the mass. It's not the heart
of the dark ice out there yet. So
getting over that body might prove
difficult. And they are sitting on the
uh Duskro's lab which is exactly where
Lilia wants to be. And so as a result uh
might have a little bit of an advantage
on Vi.
>> Yeah, Spice is looking very good here
despite missing that two drop earlier.
And that's just a note to players. Hey,
maybe it isn't over just because you
missed your two drop. We will see that
Lilia come in for the conquer on the
sunken temple. Won't be able to pay that
two. We'll leave a sprite behind. I'm
scared.
>> And that sprite's being left behind
there. And uh smok and mirrors is great,
by the way. It's a great great spell
with this Lilia cuz you're able to kind
of move it around and generate those
tokens where they have to be generated.
>> And we do see the disarming rake come
out here to destroy that long sword. U
that is a huge part that it can hit any
type of gear and it takes away the
Fiora's ganking ability because she's no
longer at five might. Huge play here. We
have the on guard as well. It's starting
to shift to where all of a sudden the
Lilia is looking really good once again.
>> It's another sword. It's another sword.
Now the question is is some sideboards
will have multiple disarming rakes. I
mean obviously it's a good call into an
Aurora meta here and I just can't
believe he had a second one in hand.
>> Would you like to?
>> Absolutely. Such a great card. The
biggest downside of course is that power
cost to it, but we see that it's
definitely worth it as we make our
opponent spend additional power on this
long sword. Uh the fact that they had
the second long sword though could be
absolutely critical for this game
because Fiora is likely the way just
dancing around these battlefields of the
way that our path to victory.
>> I love watching two aggressive decks go
at it here. That was a remarkable play
and I'm sure Gail Winds is hoping that
they pull something here.
>> And looking at the falling star on hand
is looking pretty juicy here for Vi.
Really looking at what else they want to
do. I mean, you can just go ahead and
gank over as well and take this and save
that falling star for a little bit
juicier targets. Although, in the Lilia
deck, there's only so many options for
it. However, we do have the ability to
ready this Fiora once again, and we can
bring her to safety if we would like.
>> We'll do that and that. So, draw card.
>> You do proc the legend ability from Vi
there and from the sunken temple.
>> Oh, yes.
>> Lots of options here for Vi.
The game is quickly turning into VI's
favor here.
>> You should also have to see um if
they're going to are they going to carry
over with
try to establish the board a little
further.
>> Uh so as well less legal than
>> I did see a Rexai in hand. Yeah, I
don't.
>> Looks like they're thinking it through
>> and they're going to bring back the uh
knowing that they have the advantage
here, especially on the score against an
aggressive deck like Lilia. Uh
protecting that Fiora is going to make a
lot of sense here.
>> Yes. Uh there's really no reason to
leave the Fiora out here. Going for the
whole game plan against this temporary
deck doesn't really make much sense. So
being able to take Fiora to safety and
then look likely to establish more units
here ready in that base and then react
to the Lilia instead of making them
instead of making them react to you.
And we do have okay there's a Noxis
hopeful coming down. Noxis hopeful is
going to alongside that that Rex eye.
That's a big board presence now uh for
Danny. And I'm sure that uh this next
turn is going to be an important one for
Lilia. Now, they're not, of course, as
you mentioned, they're not great at
holding the battlefields, but they'll be
able to score here, but will they fall
too far behind?
>> Yeah, I'm really interested to see what
the play is here. We did see some pretty
big buffs and stuff come out earlier in
that first game, and we're not finding
them the second game. The arming rake
was really great, but we're not finding
those other pieces. It looks like we
could see the ong guard in hand,
>> sprite fountains there as well.
Yeah, it's really just without these
buffs and having to go against this
Fiora equipped with the long sword on
top of other strong might units. It's
just really tough. So, we're just going
to put points on the board and hope that
we can find those pieces later in the
game.
>> Yeah, the sprite burst is going to allow
them to get on the field here, score
these points. Um the question is, do you
think that Danny's thinking about um the
unchecked power? I mean, unchecked power
is obviously utilized in the last game
there. He has a decent board state here.
Unchecked power is going to probably
dissuade him from trying to hold. Yeah,
it is one of those questions of is it
it's a one-off card first off. Is it
something that we have to play around
here to win or is it something that we
do have to take that gamble? Because
sometimes you can't play around
everything.
It's not always an option is the reality
of it. And really, this Lilia deck will
outvalue in the long term. So, being
able to say, I'm going to continue
pushing for these points and uncheck
power if you have it, good for you. If
not, maybe I can take this game. And
Gailwind does come down with another
disarming rake. Two swords, two
disarming rakes. You have been disarmed,
Fiora.
>> So that's the really important part of
seeing these disarming rakes. We talked
about how it's great against Aurora, but
seeing it be very useful in this matchup
as well of taking away those long
swords. It's the fact this is why so
many players are main decking gear
removal now because it isn't only Aurora
that you're worried about. You're also
thinking about these gears on these
might as well because gears that add
might are so good because they can't be
reacted to but they can be destroyed and
that's what we're seeing.
>> And we do have the Kaiser Survivor being
accelerated coming out to generate the
draw. They must be searching for
something in their deck here as an
answer cuz they do have a really strong
board presence here. Now the disarming
rakes are not really good targets for
Falling Star. So, I imagine that they're
going to hold it there, especially since
like realistically the ability to
generate all these sprites is going to
apply so much pressure anyways. So, I'm
not sure the disarming rakes represented
that risk.
>> I would really be considering the
falling stars here on the disarming
rakes just because there aren't that
many great targets in Lilia. That's the
biggest thing is there's not great
targets for it. And on top of that,
since you are stuck with keeping these
units here holding just saying you can't
buff these up with like a heart of dark
ice, for example, that takes this away
and we don't see that falling star come
down. Um must be keeping some other
trick in the hand ready to try to
protect at least some of these units
here.
>> Yeah, the disarming rakes of course
being able to kind of contest cuz you
are right, they those hopeful and kaiser
survivor, they're stuck there. They
can't go anywhere and we do have the
sprite found come out that's going to
generate a sprite. So, we have a pretty
decent board here. A lot of open uh
runes available to Gailwind. We'll have
to see if they're able to try to contest
both both battlefields at once. They're
not going to be able to go to six power,
but they'll be able to uh perhaps
>> threaten lethal soon.
>> And I want to say, of course, I love the
ordering here as we get the sprite bound
out first. Getting the sprite out first
to reduce that cost of our Lilia Legend
power as well.
>> Okay. And there is the on guard coming
down to put them above the Kaiser
Survivor.
>> Yep.
successful.
>> We'll go to our sixth point.
>> Yes. So, we have six to six. A close
game here. And we'll see if we can take
this other battlefield as well.
>> However, holding is going to be tough,
especially when likely this disarming
rake is what gets killed.
>> And this is exactly the moment you were
referring to. You're like, "Hey, maybe
those disarming, you got to get rid of
them because they're able to contribute
to the push to score that now seventh
point." Now, of course, the sprites
aren't going to be able to hold to an
eighth point,
>> but they're going to be able to
accelerate in.
>> Yes. And I love holding back this
disarming rake because it sets up for
for potentially drawing on that fake
eighth conquer point that we don't quite
get. Oh, it looks like we're deciding if
we want to try to hold with it or not.
We do have three runes up. So, we might
have the ability to hold here. Okay, it
looks like that is what we're doing.
>> Temple. Yeah. Okay. Yeah, you do have
the sprite fountain that's going to be
generated. You have the Lilia Legend
ability. So, no matter what, you're
going to be able to contest. So, I'm
ready to see this Falling Star come down
and potentially end in end this game.
We'll see if there is an ability of
course, you know, discipline potentially
could stop that, but Falling Star and we
do have two units ready to attack.
Counting up our runes here real quick.
We have plenty of options to end this
game.
>> And it's notable that Falling Star
cannot be defied as it does cost two
power. So, yeah, at six points here,
Danny is threatening to be able to win
this game. is falling star and is going
to target the sprite. Both sprites it
looks like are going to be gone leaving
the disarming rake.
>> So, uh we'll have to see if there's any
tricks available here.
>> And I really like targeting both these
sprites here because they are the
highest might units. And with only two
might from this disarming rake, it just
gives you a few more options here.
>> And that BF sword, it does come down.
And I think that might be enough. But
there's still three open runes for
Lilia. We'll have to see in the comments
as well. Okay, it looks like we got a
smile on Danny's face as it looks like
they're going to be able to uh threaten
the win.
>> Yes, and I love just getting this uh
this Fiora up because you have the buy
legend available as well. And we have
Jana coming out.
>> Fantastic.
>> What a hold from Gail Winds
>> that is. And you have Rexai still
available, but you're tapped out.
>> I didn't know you had Jan. I didn't know
anybody. And Danny has a smile on their
face. Was not expecting that. That's an
absolutely remarkable play. And the
handshake comes in. Gay wins takes the
win. What an absolutely remarkable game.
>> Absolutely fantastic.
>> Yes. Uh seeing that Jana come out. The
look on the face of I didn't know you
had Jana is what we heard from him. And
yeah, I mean seeing that push it back,
getting that hold and really the read
there was because we saw that disarming
rake be moved up.
>> You are at seven.
>> Wow. And think of that too. Falling star
targets mattered a lot here because if
we had a falling starfer
back no it wouldn't have the Jana anyway
but seeing that Jana come out and just
push back and say yep
>> I was just trying to make sure I had
enough damage.
>> That was a fantastic game and it really
goes to show you as well cuz these are
uh these are deck list there's closed
deck list right now. Day two you get
into a point where you do have the the
open deck list. What I will say is that
I absolutely loved that game because it
really showcased the aggressive style of
play that Riftbound can be known for. We
have different style of decks. Of
course, I'm throughout the day, I'm sure
we're going to see some Aurora as well,
a bit of a different play pattern, but
we saw two very aggressive decks, two
very aggressive players going at each
other here.
>> Yeah, and I just want to say the Jana
tech card in there. We talked about how
this is the best of Yasuo player on the
secret sauce here playing. And those
secret tech cards are what make the big
difference of just surprising your
opponent in these closed deck lists and
saying the field is so wide. So being
able to have that and of course the
reaction I didn't know you had Jana that
is the way that you know that the tech
card worked.
>> And I love honestly I know we talked
about it before but just the overall
like the the sportsmanship we're seeing
between the players. They obviously
respect each other tremendously. they're
playing a a game we all love of course,
but to see that kind of play surprise
them and instead of being like upset
like they're excited like they're
actually like I didn't see that coming
and they have a huge smile on their face
and that's the kind of thing that I
think Riftbound brings out in players
because like it's like I did not see
that coming and perhaps even if had they
you know maybe held an equipment back
for the Rex eye or something there's
there's always a win there in Riftbound
I find.
>> Yeah. Uh definitely one of the ones that
you could look back and see like oh I
should have done that instead or I
should have done this instead. But I
mean, we have to say expertly navigated
by Gailwinds. This was huge for
Gailwinds. Just making it great plays
all around. Really showing us what Lilia
can do, especially when there's not a
Vex on the board.
>> Oh yeah, tell me about it. Vex is one of
those uh I mean Chaos as a whole is uh
is a challenge for us for the the
archetype. But yeah, Vex apathetic is
just it completely shuts down uh Lilia.
And for that reason though, like
sometimes you you have to try to like
find creative ways to deal with that Vex
apathetic because obviously all your
readyied sprites, they're just they're
going to sit there. They're just not
going to do anything, right?
>> Yeah, exactly. And it looks like we have
an interview with the winner. So, we'll
go ahead and take a look at Gail Winds.
>> Thanks so much for a wonderful cast and
a wonderful match played by the
wonderful Gailwinds, now a part of TSS
as we can also mention. So, I kind of
want to do a little bit of talk about
we're building a lot more storylines
about the teams that exist this weekend.
So, you're now a part of the secret
sauce who we just saw sold out actually
take that second place.
>> Yeah, it's Sydney. So, you know, speak
to that. You know, how's the team vibe?
Relatively new. How are you all kind of
feeling coming into this tournament?
>> We say it's relatively new, but it's
only relatively new official. We've been
playing together since the beginning.
I've been playing with these guys since
uh trial meta. Basically, Sold I've
known from the trial meta. In fact, we
were playing like jinxes together and
stuff like that way back when. So, it's
not that the team is new, it's just
officially branding now. Uh, so yeah, we
are the secret sauce. Uh, we're going to
be split between some best of and some
actually trying to win the event as we
go to each event. Uh, for this one, I'm
on a best of, so I'll be trying to get
Lilia a best of. Uh, meanwhile, Togg and
Sold are going to win the event with
Civer Aurora, just like Sold almost did
at Sydney.
>> Perfect. And that sounds like an
excellent plan. I'm It's awesome just to
hear immediately like a breakdown of you
guys have a plan coming into this event
to to take down best of. And speaking of
best of gallons, you already have one on
Yasuo. You're pretty known already in
the community. We've seen you, you know,
do a couple of other pieces across these
other events, but I got to ask you, you
know, this unleashed format is the last
chance to get these best dubs for the
Origins Legends. Y
>> and you're not playing. Can I ask maybe
why the pivot to Lilio? Because we saw
an excellent gameplay from it. Yeah. So,
I loved Yasuo set one. Yasuo set one has
been my favorite deck of the game. It
was beautiful with the way that it
played and its modality into that
specific set format. But as we changed
format, Yaso just felt worse and worse
and he was not what I fell in love with.
So, instead of tarnishing like what I
have my love of Yasuo for, I'm just
going to play the things that I do want
to play. Lily has a whole new color
combination for me. uh being blue green.
It's still green, so I have to keep some
bit of home in there. Uh and it's been
very exciting just to explore those
colors combinations and to figure out
where those are ticking. And Lilia is
giving me similar to the same vibes as
Yasua from the original. I've been able
to grind out games with her. She has
some modality and she's also super fast
deck. So, I've been enjoying her a lot.
>> Yeah, it actually is very interesting to
look at the differences between what I
Lilia now as this sort of like not hold
specialist like what Ari and what people
have attempted to use. Horn is obviously
a whole separate beast, but Lilia does
sort of have that modality like you said
of being able to get onto battlefields a
lot more efficiently by always getting
this, you know, this ready sprite unit,
a bunch of now new sprite and temporary
synergies that exist in the game. So, it
is interesting that it is kind of maybe
a little bit of that similar feel
without now losing chaos and gaining
mind access for sure.
>> So, it it is awesome to hear that. I got
to ask you specifically in that match.
I'll be honest, I was a little afraid
for you when I think of like how Vi
wants to play the game. your little
three might sprites might be a little
bit, but you handled it so well and the
mask of foresight's really coming in
clutch there. I think a lot of people
were even like everyone's talked about
Mask of Foresight being successful in a
lot of these decks that need a little
bit of extra might push and we've been
kind of selling the point about how
numbers really matter in might. One or
two extra might mattering a lot. How
does that really feel when you add those
sort of cards to this deck?
>> It radically changes everything. The
break point between a three and a four
is massive because now we're trading
with all of the common fours in the
format. things like Kai'Sa, things like
Noxus hopefuls, as we saw in the VI
game, those fours matter. When we get
the second Mask on the field, now we're
beating that and it can just become
overwhelming over the course of a game.
In Kai'Sa, a deck like Kai'Sa, she's not
really in the meta right now, but she's
a great example of how Mask of Foresight
can just block a deck entirely. Her only
units that she really plays are like two
drops, four drops, and then like a
ferris forrunner in there every now and
again. There is some Darius, but either
way, most of her game plan revolves
around getting those to get her early
points, and Mask of Foresight just
blocks her off entirely. So, that that
card is a powerhouse all on its own.
People have to side in gear hate just
for that two drop.
>> I definitely would as well, but Gins, I
really appreciate the insight here.
Round one officially now done for you.
You can go take a break cuz you finished
relatively quick. So, nice to go, you
know, wander around, maybe get some
insights. Some people didn't have a buy
of course, but uh I'm glad you had a
great performance here and we hope to
see more of you and your team some of
these future rounds.
>> You'll see us first at this event. One
of us. I believe in them.
>> That's right. So, don't go anywhere.
We're going to pass it back.
>> Now, what's interesting about what we
saw there, and you brought it up cuz you
were looking through the deck list,
you're like, I think that Jana was a one
of.
>> Yes. And the main board is indeed a one
of. So, it's something that I've seen
some Jax decks played before because it
is just sneaky. It is a reaction at the
end of the day that says, you know, heal
your units and then push one of these
back to base. So, it was just such a
great line from Gail Winds to see like
this is the way that I win. We know we
saw that didn't draw all those buff
cards that we were expecting like the
heart of dark eyes. It didn't have that
mask of foresight game too and still
found a way from being very clever just
getting those sneaky points and getting
that sneaky hold.
>> Yeah. And the deck has the one of of
unchecked power which we did see great
board reset there. Uh I should say
battlefield reset. Uh it also has a one
of a thousand tail watcher. Now thousand
tail watcher is synonymous uh with the
blue archetype and so it provides with
that accelerate that that uh that
aggressiveness is able to be used. How
do you feel like Lilia would be
utilizing the thousand tail watcher to
kind of close out games?
>> I mean big thing is that you have all
these sprites that are pretty low cost
and you're able to play them pretty
quickly. So if you do play a thousand
tail watcher, give minus three might to
everything, then you're able to retake
battlefields and get that final conquer,
especially with a thousand tail watcher.
>> Now with regards to VI, uh piltover
enforcer now obviously we've discussed
that Fury has been having a bit of a
challenge now when people are bringing
Vi to a championship like this, are you
assuming that they're going after that
best of or do you think they're going to
be competing for a championship? Of
course, I'm expecting Vi to go for the
best of because she, you know, that fury
domain for one thing, but really Vi is
just so iconic is the biggest thing.
Like, who wouldn't want a Vi best of
card?
>> Of course. Now, if you were to choose
and you wanted to take the championship
with Fury, who'd be the legend you would
choose?
>> I would have to say Pike. Maybe Annie.
Annie or Pike for sure. Those are the
two that I think have been Well, of
course, we've seen Prismat do great on
Annie in the past multiple times.
However though, Pike I think is going to
find a way to get into the top eight at
least.
>> I think Pike is actually one of the
underrated champion or I should say
legends of Riftbound thus far cuz there
are a different different variations of
it. I actually kind of like that
disruption variation where you're just
like blowing up their hand. They're
discarding everything. Uh but also you
have that aggressiveness of like the
acceleration and etc. Um what variation
do you think could perhaps make a top
cut? I'm expecting more of that removal,
a bit more of that tempo variation. Of
course, the hand disruption is great and
maybe we'll see some thrown into there
kind of like what we've seen with Ezreal
in the past, but I'm expecting more of
the Pike tempo play, you know, using
those Falling Star. We've seen Falling
Star be really good into some matchups
and that's what I kind of see Pike doing
as well.
>> And for Lilia, we saw a very successful
pilot of Lilia from Gailwinds here. Do
you think Lilia has what it takes to
make a top cut and then perhaps make a
top eight? Or do you think there's just
too much chaos, pun intended, for it to
break through?
>> If Soul were to do it, it would be Gail
wins and after seeing him expertly
navigate that game, I think there's a
possibility of it.
>> So, the next games we're going to be
taking a look at soon. I hope hopefully
we get to take a look at that. Azir and
Lily game. We got two Lilia games
perhaps on the docket. I think they
might be going into game three. We do
have some upcoming breakdowns as well,
but before we get into that, um, with
Lilia specifically, the sideboard is,
uh, is being played with disarming
Drake, uh, disarming rake, sorry. Do you
think that that is absolutely vital
considering the meta you have right now
with Aurora?
>> Oh, yeah. I mean, as we said during that
game multiple times, disarming rake hits
a lot of things outside of Aurora as
well. And even that postgame interview,
Gail once was talking about how Mask of
Foresight was something that people had
to use their gear gear removal against.
So it hits so many things and with such
a diverse meta right now, there's a lot
of things that you can hit that are
outside of the big bad of the format.
>> Yeah. And I think that like even what we
saw in that prior Lilia game, right, we
didn't see smoke and mirrors very much,
which is actually a core synergistic
component of what Lilia is trying to do.
And uh at the end of the day though,
they were able to uh Gilwind was able to
generate so much value with those spray.
It's that aggressive play and like for
me, I love those aggressive decks. I
absolutely love it. Um and it was just
fantastic to see being able to put like
that immense pressure on to Danny to
ultimately close out the game cuz
especially when Danny was threatening to
win the game going into that eighth
point.
>> Yes. Uh we saw of course, you know, the
Fiora stacked with the idea of like I'm
going to conquer this battlefield and
then I'm going to gank over and I'm
going to finish this game. And that
wasn't quite what happened. And you
know, putting all of those a big thing
was putting all of the equipment onto
the Fiora was a big thing. We saw the
line of why they wanted to do that, but
of course the Janna making all the
difference in the world there.
>> Now, a card that we did not see in that
game, but was in the main deck is
Riptide Rex. It's actually one of my
favorite cards from Origins is basically
Singularity on a body. Um, why do you
think that players are mainboarding that
now? because they want to uh yeah like
what what is your thoughts around
Riptide Rex? We even have another Rex
that's being very popular in Leblanc.
But what about this one here?
>> A big thing is there are a lot of tall
decks right now like the Master Yi
mid-range comes to mind. So being able
to take those out is really important
and we talked about how it is a game of
might at the end of the day. So being
able to have that damage to uh you know
take out the battlefields and then
retake is a huge difference there. And
we are going to be going to game three.
We're going to Silver and I are going to
break down the decks here. And uh
Silver, we got ghosties. It is another
Lilia game. Green game three of Lilia
versus Azir. What do you see?
>> I really love the build of this deck.
It's different. I mean, we get to see
eggplant, our tasty faolk back. Usually
we've seen this in Ye and then haven't
really seen them so much. And of course,
Scuttle Crab, an absolute favorite card.
It really started off being really
underrated at first and a lot of players
have said like, "Oh, revealing my
opponent's hand is pretty good. This can
conquer at zero might. That's also
pretty good. I get to draw a card. Oh,
that's also pretty good." And then a big
thing is three unchecked power here.
This is really saying I want to reset
the board and then I'm going to retake
over and over again. We saw what
unchecked power did for Lilia in the
first game. So, I wonder if that's also
been a key card here in this match as
well. It is against Azir, so having all
those sand soldiers, maybe it goes a
little bit too wide, but it's something
that the Azir player definitely has to
navigate around.
>> Now, we don't see the sideboard, but
there is a chance that there are going
to be disarming rakes there getting
brought into game three. But what I do
notice here is, it's funny, you
mentioned three unchecked power. We
don't often see three,000 tail watchers
either. This is a very different
approach to this type of deck. Yeah, I
do wonder what the thought process is
behind it because with the unchecked
power and the thousand tail watcher both
being three of there's a good shot that
sometimes your hand just bricks. We also
have our fa folk as well. So the fact
that we have so many high cost, high
power, very power hungry overall. It
worries me that sometimes this deck
won't just be able to find the right
part of the deck and it's very likely
that you'll brick some games. However,
if you draw the right part of the deck,
you do have a lot of draw options such
as having that skeletal crab and it is
power hungry. So, we do have the
plundering poor Owens there. There's
definitely times where this deck will
just fire off and there's not too much
you can do about it.
>> And let's take a look at Mr. Beefy's
Azir deck.
We got the Azir Sovereign Champ. And I
mean, I absolutely love that. What can I
say? Four uh four might for four cost.
Perfect card. And I love the fact that
you can reposition all of your sand
soldiers for uh for a closing eighth
point.
>> Yeah. And I'd really like to highlight
uh soul sword here, a new card from
Unleash put this Azir to the next level
because it is so much more consistent
with having the soul sword available to
it. It is a very equipment focused deck
as we can see. A lot of gear very
important. So having the soul sword for
that extra consistency for the Emperor
of the Sands is so critical. You do see
the tricks of three defies. You have
three disciplines as well. Desert's call
as well. But we have the Vi Pilttover
Enforcer, uh, which, uh, for me is going
to be a very unique addition from set
three for Azir. Um, what are your
thoughts on the Vi?
>> I mean, she's just too good not to play.
The fact that you get to stun a unit
when with her as well, she just has such
a great stat line. Of course, she does
cost that power, but with the ability
she gets, it's so critical. We've seen
her played in most yellow decks at this
point because she also has the new
ambush mechanic as well. Being able to
be played as a reaction and on the
attack, stunning an enemy. I mean, it
allows you to go in and retake something
so much easier because of that stun,
sending something to zero might.
>> And we would be remissed if we did not
talk about Arise, Azir's signature
spell. This is one of my favorite
signature spells in the entire game.
Being able to generate a sand soldier
for all of the equipment you have is
absolutely insane. And then just to add
to that, two of them come in ready. And
there just so happens to be two
battlefields which gives you an
opportunity to be as aggressive as
possible.
>> Yeah, we could talk about this deck all
day. I know it's one of your personal
favorites, but we do have that match
ready for you all. So, we'll be getting
into game shortly.
>> Yeah, you got me. Azir is one of my
absolute favorites here and I'll have to
be seeing if Mr. be if he can close out
game number three.
Here we go as they get prepared to play.
It's going to be Hall of Legends and the
seat of power. What are your thoughts on
those two locations?
>> I mean, the Hall of Legends just being
able to reset that for Ozir and it's
really so good against a lot of
different decks that we see. However,
Lilia can use advantage of it as well.
>> Yeah, that's actually an excellent
point. the Hall of Legends Zulia can
utilize and it actually will decrease
the cost of the next proc because you're
generating a sprite and then the Hall of
Legends comes into play and well you got
a sprite out there so now it's even
cheaper with Azir it actually generates
usually a very very tempo oriented turn
too where you're able to put down an
equipment score that point and then of
course put out another uh another uh
sand soldier. Now, of course, we saw the
work that Seed of Power did for the
Lilia deck in our last match, and I bet
there's a good chance we see it do a lot
of work again. Being able to take the
battlefields early and then get that
free draw over and over again from Ceda
Power is why it's been such a great card
in the Olia decks and a lot of other
decks as well.
>> You see the fist bump. We're ready to
get started here. Game three. Let's see
how we do. Mr. Beefy on Azir and Ghosty
on Lilia.
And we do see that soul sword that we
talked about earlier just giving the
deck a little bit of extra consistency
and being able to allow Azir to make
that sand soldier rather than being
stuck. We'll
>> play the Lilia of course here. Okay, so
Lilia does come out from the champion
zone.
>> And this person must be, you know, man
of taste with the overnumbered Azir and
the alt art as well. I'm sure you have
your eyes on those.
>> I I did. Okay, I got to be honest with
you. I did manage to pull the uh
overnumbered Azir from just like a
regular box. I was just opening and I
got so excited. And sometimes for me
it's like what I pull is what I decide
to play. It's why I became a Teemo main
in Origins because I pulled an
overnumbered team. I was like, well, I
guess I'm a Teemo player now. And the
same thing happened with Azir. But I got
to tell you, I fell in love with this
archetype as a whole. But there was a
period of time when Ezreal was super
super popular. Playing Azir was
difficult because pit pocket was
literally everywhere because pit pocket
was being used to counteract the seals
and Azir is just sitting there like I'm
not playing seals. I'm just trying to
play small equipment. Why do you hate
me? Right. So it's the meta has become
significantly more favorable to Azir and
we actually have seen some legitimately
good results.
>> Yes, and we do come into that hollow
legends here and because we didn't play
gear earlier, we didn't use Azir
earlier. So we're not paying for that
rering of the Azir legend. So, we'll
have to see what comes out next. Um,
perhaps, you know, we don't know what's
in hand. If we had a We're hiding a
card.
>> So, that hidden card, I mean, I mean,
got to take a look at the decks, but it
could be anything. Who knows what it
could be? Uh, it's it's more than likely
your hidden blade, right? Cuz with the
hidden blade, especially with the uh the
recruits being generated, even the
tokens, you're able to kind of generate
either draw for yourself or, of course,
you're able to defend that battlefield
if they happen to bring something in.
Now, in this case here with Lilia,
you're not going to want to hit and
blade something like a sprite. So, it's
more than likely going to be used to
draw and establish more of a hand
presence.
>> Yes, another option it could be would be
back off as there are two in the list.
So, potentially hiding a back off and
saying, "Oh, Lilia's coming in."
Actually, no, you're not.
>> Now, back off's a funny card to bring up
because first of all, I love it. I I'll
be honest, I love everything with Vex's
art on it. But back off specifically,
it's unique in the sense that obviously
if you hide it, it generates incredible
value. But at the same time, it's like
for three cost you stun and you get to
draw if you play it from hand. Sometimes
I sit there and be like, do I want to
hide this or do I want to play it?
There's very few instances in Riftbound
where that occurs because often the
cards that are can be hidden are the
ones that you want to hide because you
get that disproportionate value. But
back off is kind of unique from that
standpoint.
>> Yes, it does make it a tricky decision
and that's why we did see Mr. for Beefy,
you know, look over his cards a little
bit and decide what he wanted to do. And
we are seeing Ghosty do that as well
here of do I want to reveal this hidden
card or not or try to get my opponent
to.
>> And they're going to bring in the Ailia.
And of course, you do have fine runes up
and we'll see what happens here. And it
is going to be smoke and mirrors. You're
going to make a switch here. And of
course, with that Lilia switch, you're
going to generate another sprite token.
And which is exactly why we mentioned
Smoky Mirs being one of the uh the best
cards to be playing in this particular
aggressive deck.
>> I absolutely love watching Lilia players
navigate their decks. It just looks like
such a fun deck to play overall. Just
leaving tokens and we saw the power of
smoke and mirrors in the previous game
as well and seeing it now. Lilia just a
really cool champion unit as a whole of
leaving these sprites behind allows her
to do so much. And we do see the
discipline into defy come down. No card
draw, no buff here. And we are revealed
to guards.
>> Guards.
>> Okay, that's the dark horse we had not
really thought about. We have an
additional sand soldier coming into that
battlefield to help
>> reinforce, but it is going to be numbers
up for the sprites.
>> And then,
>> yep, the sprites will take it and the
sword will return back to base. That's a
really tough trade there. Really well
played by our Lilia player overall. And
the sprite fountain coming too. Going to
get that extra draw from Ceda Power. And
we are seeing the strength of that
battlefield over and over again in this
first round already. And I bet we'll see
it more today as well.
>> Yeah. So yeah, Seed of Power is going to
be a very popular battlefield. I I would
suggest and of course with that sprite
fountain, you're going to be able to
generate a ton of value into that next
turn because obviously not only going to
discount Lilia's legend ability which
gives you optionality, but if you have
like a sprite burst or anything like
that, all of a sudden Lilia just feels
like a free legend ability.
>> Yeah. And something to mention earlier
is we aren't seeing Mr. Beefy just slam
down more equipment here to activate
Azir. Oh, there it goes. Okay. I was
wondering where that where the BF sword
was earlier. But seeing that activate
Azir and looks like we're in a better
spot now than before. If we had missed
equipment again, it was going to be a
really tricky spot for Azir to navigate.
>> Turn pass over to Lilia. We do generate
that sprite from the sprite fountain.
Now, do they have the disarming rake? I
mean it's something that is uh being
frequently sideboarded in sometimes even
as a two or three of in the hand. Here
we do see the stupifies. We see rare
nice view of the hand there. We had
another sprite fountain. Couldn't quite
make out the others.
>> So we'll see if that other sprite
fountain
>> the heart of dark ice is there as well.
I know you've been excited to see that
get play. It's a mask that comes down.
>> Mhm.
>> I got to tell you, I'm loving these mask
plays here and they are going to score
point with that spray. going up to
three.
>> Yes. And as these sprites often do
attack or defend alone, the value here
from Power, I just I can't stop talking
about it. It's
>> It makes such a big difference where
Lilia does have all this utility as well
in finding those buff cards. I mean,
Lilia feels like she's in a really great
spot. Still has another defy in hand to
defend if needed. And the biggest thing
is, you know, will Arise come to play?
But we don't have the equipment to
really do all that much with the Arise
yet.
>> No, not yet. And uh I mean it does have
the benefit of the readied tokens, but
at the end of the day, yeah, you want to
get more inexpensive uh equipment out
there. Now, realistically, here's the
challenge, too, right? Cuz you can't
even like you can't bank on the fact
that the the sprites aren't going to
hold for a point. Like they they're just
they're generated almost every single
turn for very little resources. you know
that Lilia is going to be able to take
those battlefields if you don't have
some sort of presence. And then with
that seed of power, it's so easy to go
into hall of that's the other thing. You
got the Hall of Legends too, which can
also be utilized by Lilia. Uh this is
one of those situations where I think
that Azir is a little behind. I'd like
to see where they play here, but I
wonder if they're trying to conserve
some runes so that they can perhaps
utilize a couple uh you know, reactions
or actions to to take over a battlefield
here.
Uh
>> so they are going to swing in with the
sand soldier here. It is going to be it
is a five might sand soldier and they're
going to wipe out that battlefield
there. And uh it's notable that they
hadn't chosen to uh to play a sand
soldier first and then utilize the Hall
of Legends.
>> Yeah, I just have to imagine that the
hand is very low on equipment based off
what we saw from that turn two and then
also seeing it now and just not more
equipment being loaded on the board
because without equipment, Azir doesn't
really function. So, this seems like a
really unfortunate hand for our zero
player overall. And, you know, it's not
game over by any means, but it will be
really tough to navigate to come back
here.
>> Yeah. And you see the repeated Desert's
Call, which is a fantastic uh spell
because it's able to either be played on
turn two or of course repeated for four.
It does establish a bit of a board. You
do have three sand soldiers there, but
we'll have to see if that's enough to uh
kind of quill the tide of this Lilia.
Yeah, and the big question is if Lilia
is able to double conquer here and draw
again, it'll just put Azir in such a
tough spot. And because we still have
that Lilia champion card out, there's a
possibility that we will be able to do
that.
>> And there is the Heart of Dark Ice
coming in and it's going to allow Lilia
to be punching well above their weight.
Uh, now there are it looks like four
open runes if I can see correctly there
on Azir. So Azir's going to have some
answers.
Yeah, it's definitely a possibility
here. But the question is like what are
the answers here? Of course, we know we
said hidden blade potentially, but
>> that's still not going to do that much
if it's onto a temporary unit.
>> Um
>> I'm going to correct myself. I believe
that's three.
>> I didn't use this yet.
So good.
>> So currently she's just
>> So we're clarifying here that Lilia, the
heart of dark eyes was not activated
onto this Lilia. She is only at three
might going for the seed of power.
>> Yes, that's right. because you do have
to exhaust it to uh to assign a target.
That's not been done yet. Uh but of
course it can be used alongside a
readyied sprite which could perhaps
contest
the hall of
>> legends.
And we will be given here and it'll get
another plus one.
>> Let's see how those readyed runes work
for Mr. Beefy.
>> And with a full extra four P or four
might here with the back off coming.
Yes,
>> I just finished saying that you get to
play the back off and you draw a card
and we just finished alluding to that
Mr. Beefy's hand must be pretty rough.
There's not a lot of equipment and uh
clearly trying to search for that
equipment and to see the defy come
through to obviously it's a perfect
play. You're you're literally
threatening to win the game here next
turn. And if you're at home wondering
why did we conquer the Hall of Legends
second and not see the power, the reason
is because with the Lilia moving and
leaving that sprite behind, it reduced
the cost of our legend and so we used
all of our runes and that was the best
we could do there. Excellent shout out
there. Uh so yeah, Mr. Beefy is looking
at a situation where they have to
contest these battlefields. Ghosty is
threatening to win the game on this next
turn. They're at that vital six points.
They're going to come in with the sand
soldier Lilia.
>> And they do. That's right. The mask does
improve Lilia's strength here. And it's
going to be Vi that's going to come in
as the ambush.
>> And it's going to be enough to take.
>> Huge play with the Vi there. We talked
about how Vi is just a key part of the
yellow uh identity now because she stuns
a unit when she comes in. The ambush
mechanic is fantastic. So, love seeing
that VI come out once again, taking that
seat of power and pushing the Lilia back
just a little bit more here.
>> The utility of VI as well is you're able
to select who you're stunning, right? I
think that's notable, especially when
you're trying to make favorable trades.
It looks like Mr. Beefy is considering
an attack on the Hall of Legends.
>> And we'll have to see what happens here.
And it's just a simple sprite defeated
as Ghosty does not have any open runes.
Yep. So, being able to reestablish the
board here. But one thing that we know
about Lilia is even though it has
nothing in the base at times, it always
has something up its sleeve ready to go.
And we do have the mask out, we have the
heart of dark ice ready to go. And at
six points, a double conquer here could
win.
>> I believe we did see a spray found in
hand. So, that's going to generate
sprite. I believe we might have even saw
a sprite burst. So, I think that Ghosti
is going to be able to apply a ton of
pressure here with readied sprites. And
it's so funny, you look at this board,
you're like, "Oh, there's really nothing
there." Oh, you got the unchecked power
as well. We'll have to see. Unchecked
power is an option cuz you're going to
be able to wipe everything out here and
then perhaps
>> start to try to contest into the
battlefield. But unchecked power is
certainly an option. It's the one of
three. But uh
>> yeah, and a big note is we do have a
hidden card up above as well for this.
So it you know if we do have unchecked
power and a hidden blade is played and
it just takes out you know just a free
draw too essentially that makes this
unchecked power feel a lot less strong
than what it was. However, clearing that
VI and that seed of power battlefield
would feel pretty great. But I love the
setup here from the Azir player.
Okay. I think they're still thinking
about that there. And I uh I think
you're right though that the hidden card
does disproportionately benefit uh
because even if it's not like I mean it
could be like a guards again. And at
that point in time then obviously like
it's not as beneficial but hidden blade
is exactly what Mr. Beefy wants to do
because as we've said like there
actually has not been much equipment
being played which is so crucial to the
game plan of Azir. And I really like the
time that Ghosti is taking here to
navigate this because it is such a
critical turn. It really can decide the
game of what is played here. And it
looks like we will see that. Oh
>> yes,
>> there he is. Uh we haven't seen him for
a bit. He was played a lot in mid-range
E in set one and really we haven't seen
him so much here either. And it won't be
accelerated just played ready to go
which is interesting to see that as
well. Um it looks like it could be a
setup for unchecked power in the future.
>> Yeah, because uh so you do hold to six,
but he's not able Mr. Beefy is not able
to close out the game here and it's
still kind of Ghosty's game to win. So
we'll have to see especially with the
unchecked powers how Mr. Beef is going
to play cuz if he tries to stack the
battlefields,
>> he's just stepping right into the trap.
>> Yeah. And after seeing that as Mr.
beefy. I would think my opponent doesn't
have all that much and I don't, you
know, they are going to look for that
double conquer. However, I would still
be very aware of unchecked power in
Lilia. Uh there are a number of lists
that do run it as a three of so this
isn't like the
>> it's not the most common now since it's
died down a little bit, but I would
still have it on my radar for sure in
Mr. Beef's position.
>> It'll be very interesting to see. Now, I
believe what we saw in Ghosty's hand
prior to the end of this turn, I'm
almost positive um that there was a uh
we definitely saw the sprite fountain.
I'm almost positive there was a sprite
burst and then you kind of tallying that
together alongside the legend ability.
>> I think that Ghosti is going to be able
to send an absolute wave of might
especially when you consider
>> the heart of dark ice and the mask as
well. Now, the mask, I wonder I don't
know if you I'll have to think about
whether or not you'd want to send
something in individually, but
regardless, there is a lot of potential
power output on this next turn. And not
to mention, the Tasty Folk itself still
represents a six might unit.
>> Yeah, both these players are about to be
doing a lot of math. I'm pretty sure
that's what they're both calculating
right now is how much might can my
opponent produce this next turn can I
hold? Do I need to look at holding one
and then conquering the other one?
Because we're both at six points. We're
at the end game here. We have to figure
out what to do to navigate this last
game. Lots of runes available, lots of
cards available, lots of decisions.
>> Yeah. No, I mean this
>> and in Riftbound being scored at six is
so great because that next turn
represents the killing blow as they say.
And uh in this situation here, they're
both very carefully trying to consider
their actions. And uh for the Azir
player, I mean, he has some tricks, but
will it be enough to survive an absolute
onslaught, which I'm sure he realizes is
coming this next turn.
>> Yeah, and we've seen the lack of
equipment from the Azer player overall,
which always makes these games really
tough to navigate. Obviously, if we saw
equipment come down over and over again,
we would have a lot more might
represented here. We would potentially
have a rise represented here, but we're
not really seeing that. So, I do feel
like we're a bit favored into Lilia here
because I think they're going to be able
to find the might to take out these
battlefields.
>> And in on that note, actually, while
we've not seen much equipment, we've
also not seen the disarming rakes from
Lilia either. And so, who knows what
comes from that top deck, I don't
believe I saw the disarming rakes from
the hands here. Ghost is doing a very
good job protecting the hand. I think we
got one nice glimpse in there at some
point. But uh you know there there are
so many different variations as to how
Ghosty can close out this game. And I
think that uh Mr. Beefy is trying their
best to figure out how they best
position here cuz you can't you can't
just like leave the battlefields open.
You have to contest them or at least one
of them. And the question now becomes
will you be able to survive what Ghosti
is able to bring especially since almost
everything he's going to play is going
to be readied.
>> Yes. And um if I had seen my opponent do
a bunch of calculations and then play a
Tasty Fay Folk and pass, I would be
pretty worried that they would have
lethal for next turn. Obviously, they
calculated it out. So, I would be
figuring out what I can do to
potentially stop that lethal. And with
like I said, Azir, I mean, the hidden
cards are a way to potentially do it,
whether it be bluffing or saying, you
know, this uh you know, drawing with a
hidden blade. But you got to find out
something here to, you know, your
opponent obviously knows that they have
enough might to take this out. So, you
need to do something here to say you're
gonna have to navigate this in a
different way rather than just being a
clean we throw our units into the board
and we take the win that way.
>> And there's clearly no easy decision to
be made here for Mr. Beefy. And uh this
is one of the benefits I'm just going to
say throws out there. You know, you play
rather quickly in the first two games.
you get all this extra time in the third
game to actually think out these very
critical important turns.
>> Yes, both these players have definitely
taken their time, but they're also on a
good pace overall. So a lot of the
things in Swiss round is it's not about
being the perfect player, it's about
being a just good enough player at this
point because you have to execute and
both these players have done up to that
point and they know that they have the
time to be able to take those critical
decisions now which is the most
important thing as we are in game three
to six.
>> It is notable that uh that could be a
backoff as well. Um, the back off would
perhaps stun something like a tasty fa
fa folk. And the thing about back off as
well is that if you if you apply too
much might to one individual unit using
the heart of dark ice for instance,
it'll essentially just bounce it back
and perhaps allow uh allow you to
survive that next turn.
>> Yeah, spack off would be very good. Um
especially there I think there was one
other defy in the hand that we had seen
earlier,
>> but almost got a glimpse of the hand.
>> Yeah. And I think it's what I love to
see as well is again we've talked about
it a couple times with the sportsmanship
here. I think like like Ghosty does not
like he's like no this is a difficult
turn like I don't know what you're going
to do either. Take your time. You know
what I mean? And so you look see it
looks like Mr. Beef is thinking okay we
got to set up a set up a defense here.
>> Yeah. And I like playing it onto the
hidden card here as well saying you know
you're going to have to guess what this
is. It's going to be something that's
going to give you difficulty. You're
going to have to make decisions here of
what use your heart of dark ice on.
Love that play. Overall,
>> it does leave Vi slightly vulnerable,
but for Ghost to close out this game, he
will have to take both battlefields on
this next turn.
>> What's the total M there? Seven.
>> So, they're adding up the might there,
making sure they know.
>> So,
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, nine
>> cuz doing that calculation from Ghost
here as well.
>> Yeah, you got
>> we do have the BF sword there underneath
giving that plus three zero on board as
well.
network.
>> But yes, making sure that all those are
clear, easy to see, representing the
right number of might, being able to do
those calculations. I wouldn't be
surprised if Ghosty has the calculations
done here already. If not, we could
potentially see the unchecked power if
they don't think that they can get
enough might and then look to accelerate
units in the following turn.
>> Yep. It all comes back to unchecked
power, right? This is the risk. This is
the risk that Mr. Beef is playing. We
don't know if we if he saw it. Like we
really don't know if games one and two
resulted in unchecked fight. You can see
right there his thumb was just on. I saw
it there. Ghosty. I see what you're
trying to do there. But uh yeah. Okay.
We're going to get a sand draw here. And
it looks like it's going to be in base.
Goi's just taking a nice look at the
>> the overnumbered card.
>> I would too. It's beautiful.
>> And we'll have to see for sure. Um you
know, looks like this will be into base.
Might be deciding on that.
>> Mr. He must be thinking I if if I go all
in and he unchucks power like I'm just
>> yeah I mean I like the idea that he's
going for here. Of course we know about
the unchecked power just saying like I'm
going to really try to protect this
battlefield and we do see that pass and
this unchecked power might be brutal.
It may be. It may be.
>> Um,
>> it's one of those situations where like
>> it's easy. It's easy for us to focus on
as well.
>> And it looks like the heart of dice dark
ice is going to come in. So, they're
going to give up a point there. They're
going to go to seven.
>> Now, what's notable is obviously with
the uh with the unchecked power, it
would exhaust all units.
>> So, you're getting a point here because
otherwise the Tasty Folk would not have
been able to score, but it would have
been able to. And there it is. Yep. And
we'll see what this hidden card is
>> there.
>> Is it anything that is useful here?
>> Um
>> uh for FOP hasn't revealed it yet.
>> And then draw cards.
>> Trying to take it all in.
>> And it is a back off.
>> Back off. Yes.
>> And recycle one
>> as you had predicted earlier.
>> Now it's the sprite fountain. You're
able to close out the game.
>> Make a guy.
>> Very well played by both players here.
There's the fist bump. Ghosty taking it
with Lilia in an absolutely remarkable
game that came down to an absolutely
intense final turn there. I mean, for
me, I mean, we're just watching and I
feel like I'm sweating.
>> Yeah, I mean, we saw Unchecked Power
perform two games now for Lilia,
especially when you have those cheap
units that you can play afterwards.
Sprite Found being MVP, not only in
Lilia, but in other decks as well. But
Lilia really being able to utilize the
sprite found into conquer really well
navigated by Ghosty overall.
>> I think it's kind of interesting that
you know I came on to the stream I was
like, "Hey, like I love Lilia. I think
Lilia is really cool." And then we get
two highlight reel uh Lilia matches
here. But I have to say uh I can't I
can't relive Mr. Beefy I think might be
suggesting that I didn't see equipment.
Like I How do you play Azir if you don't
pull your equipment? It seemed as though
the engine just never quite started for
Azir and it ultimately cost him. Yeah,
it's definitely like the downfall of the
deck in some cases. Of course, we've
seen that perform very well over and
over again, but if you don't have that
equipment, it does kind of fall flat on
its face. And I think that Mr. Beefy did
a good job navigating what he could,
saying, you know, if you have unchecked
power, you have unchecked power. Good
for you. I can't do anything about it.
So, those are those risks that you have
to take sometimes of like, I don't have
another way to win. A double hold isn't
going to happen here. I know that. So,
going to one battlefield instead and
saying, if you have unchecked power,
good for you. If not, maybe I can get
this hold into a conquer and I can win
this game. So, I like that line decision
there because there's not much much else
you can do into the unchecked power.
>> I agree. Absolutely. I think that when
you're playing Riftbound, one of the
best things to do, of course, is take
into consideration what your opponent
can do to counterplay what your plan is,
but also let them like force them to
have the answer. Like, if you have a
line and you determine that this is
probably the most ideal line, the
highest percentage line, and it all
falls on whether or not they've drawn
unchecked power, I think you go for it.
>> Especially like we said, closed deck
list. Some Lilios run one, some two,
some three, some run zero. So, you don't
even know the deck list for sure. Of
course, if you saw the deck list of
three unchecked power, maybe the
analysis is a little bit different
there, but when you don't know your
opponent's deck list and you're just
taking a guess, I think that was the
best shot there.
>> That was an absolutely fantastic start
to the day. We're going to go to break
and then we're going to bring you to
round two.
One of the many stops here at the
regional qualifier in Vancouver is of
course the prize wall. Now you can find
the prize wall at all of the sort of
regional qualifiers that we have going
on, but every single time there seems to
be something new to pick up. Of course,
you can pick up your normal Ritbound
merch, playmats, sleeves, some oversized
battlefields, but we have something new
this time. We have these brand new
prizewall runes. Now, you can redeem
these and you get a full set of the 36.
Six from each domain. And of course, we
got to talk about the bladed legends.
You can still claim bladed legends here.
And now with Unleash being inserted into
the meta, they have been added to the
plated legend rule. But remember, you
got to be a little quick because they
only have as many as the supplies last.
So, make sure you check out the prize
wall and use those prize wall tickets as
soon as you can.
Now, time for some hot takes.
Do y'all have a favorite legend?
>> Oo, that's a good question.
>> Probably Rexai. still kind of near and
dear to my heart. Uh uh she's not great
right now, but uh she'll have her day,
I'm sure. But yeah, I like Rexi a lot
probably. Uh yeah, I'd say Rexi is
probably my favorite right now.
>> Do you have a favorite Fury legend?
>> Fury legend. Uh that I guess Rexi again.
>> We're wrecking it here. Do you have a
favorite legend?
>> Rengar.
>> Meow. Um do you have a favorite Fury
legend? Fury, Rengar, Roar.
>> What is your favorite legend?
>> Uh, out of all of them, I'd say Leblanc
is the most fun.
>> Do you have a favorite Fury legend?
>> Kaiso.
>> Uh, do you have a favorite legend at
all?
>> Uh, yeah, Volbear. That's my guy.
>> I would Do you think it's your favorite
Fury legend as well? Because I would be
furious to know that.
>> Yes. Yes, definitely my favorite Fury
legend.
>> Oh, no. Do you have a favorite legend?
>> Um, man, I've been playing so much
Ireelia. That's why I want to say
Ireelia.
>> Uh, I'm gonna go with Ireelia. I don't
know. I I don't have anything else.
>> We'll switch it up on you. What's your
favorite Fury legend?
>> Fury legend. Rexi.
>> I don't know why. There's just something
about Rexi. I used to play her in League
and then she's like good in Riftbound as
well. So, like it's kind of nice to have
that like connection to a champion.
>> I love Ivvern. He's not very good, but
it's it's a fun deck. It's surprising.
You can do some fun stuff with it.
>> Do you have a favorite Fury legend?
>> Favorite Fury legend? Uh, right now it's
probably either Pike or Jinx. I really
want to make Jinx work, but it's it's
rough.
>> Do you have a favorite legend?
>> Uh, Victor. Yeah, definitely Victor.
>> My favorite legend is Master Geek.
Do you have a favorite fury legend?
>> It's gonna have to be my boy Draven.
>> I would say my favorite legend is Civer,
but that was Miracle Civer, so I don't
play it anymore because Aurora is
boring.
>> Do you have a favorite Fury legend?
>> Draven, because it is welldesigned and
winning games is fun. That one, I guess,
is actually a hot take. Now, those were
some hot takes.
>> All right, we're going to do a quick
overview of the end of match one, which
was the VI vers Lilia. We're going to
look at the game play right there, but
we're going to go to it and see, you
know, is pretty close to the end of the
game, right? You can look at the the
point total, right? It's se six to
seven. Uh, and we do have kind of the
board for it. And VI is kind of set up
to be very good here. So, we're going to
move forward here. We're going to see uh
the activation of the falling star.
Going to see that happen and you know
really be able to clear the board, get
rid of the two sprite tokens. Uh so this
really set up for for kind of a victory
solution here, right? Not only do we
have two of these uh units here, but we
also do have the viability which will
let you uh you know reset one of your uh
units active and with ganking uh
potential with the uh fiora there is
really good. So we'll keep going forward
through it. We're going to see that, you
know, we are going to have not a lot of
units on the other side. We get rid of
those sprite tokens as mentioned and uh
we do have, you know, a couple runes
open for gale winds here. But this is
really a good situation for uh for us to
try to go for game. We'll probably go a
little bit faster, but we'll see some
equipment added to uh the Fior here.
We've got the BF sword. We've got the
signature gear here. And both these are
just going to give us like a lot of uh
of might on our Fiora here. So that also
get makes us mighty. That also means
that Fiora will be able to get uh the
additional deflect and ganking that we
need. And we're going to push it up
here, but uh uh-oh from Gail Winds is
going to look at this reaction window
here. It's going to play out the Jana.
So, we'll pause right here. Uh Jana is
going to be a really good reaction for
us. We're going to have a push back for
the Fiora. And with that, we're not
really able to get both battlefields in
contention. We don't have any runes open
for for Danny. And that was just enough
to get the game there. So, honestly,
could have gone a lot of ways. Really
good play from Gailwind to be able to
recognize that Janna was enough to get
the victory here. And uh yeah, very
close end there.
So that's going to be it for for this
one. This was just round one, too. So we
got a lot of gameplay moving forward. We
got a lot of matches and looking forward
to seeing uh what round two is going to
look like.
All right. Well, that handsome devil had
a lot to say, but we're back here. Uh I
am the Eggman. I'm joined by Ursy Day
and we've got round two upon us. How you
doing, Ursy Day?
>> I am doing great and I cannot wait to
see what we have for our round two.
>> The first round I absolutely loved
getting to watch Lilio play.
>> I loved seeing Azir. I love seeing Vi.
There was so many awesome legends and I
just can't wait for round two.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean, we've got 40 legends
in the game right now. There's a lot of
diversity. Uh and it's really cool to
see especially like round one, two,
three where uh you know you've got a lot
of hopefuls right off the gate. Uh
there's a lot of opportunities to see
some of the the lesser played legends.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I feel like early on
here is it going to be the perfect time
for it. There's just so many different
ways these players play it. Some of them
it's their pet deck that they've been
building. Sometimes they're set one,
sometimes just since la like this set
was released. But they're so excited to
show it.
>> Yeah. I mean, we saw two Lilia decks uh
on the the first matches and you know,
they still play differently. They still
are built a little bit differently and
and that's one of the my favorite things
of this game, right? We've got 40 cards,
but there's so much decision between
them and uh you know, 40 cards, 40
legends right now. There's just going to
be more and more. Uh it just really
prioritizes creativity.
>> Yeah, I definitely agree. And I mean,
we're so early into the set, who knows
what the correct way to play it is. And
both players of Lilia, fantastic
players. Gwind who did get the best of
especially during set one at Houston.
Ghosty has been I he did very well in
Houston as well very like in a lot of
like the grassroot tournaments and they
both still decided on that tour on that
play.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. So uh you know obviously
a lot of uh competition for just the
Lilia uh best of already but uh yeah but
we've got a lot of you know variety I
think today too. Uh you know what you
know we we looked at what we thought was
going to win. I said Diana with the rest
of the cast. You said Leblanc, right? Uh
you know, these are some I think high
skill cap uh legends as well. Uh but
what are some maybe hopefuls? I know we
we maybe said like Kha'Zix or like
Rengar for round two would be kind of
fun.
>> Yeah, I think both are really
interesting. I will say I was the only
Leblanc believer. Like what's up with
that? She's really cool. Um but I think
there's so many cool options. I love
Azir. It was my favorite pick for last
set. I know I think you might be an Azir
fan.
>> I would say Azir is my second. I mean,
like you we look at the Chinese event,
right? Like, oh, just choose one of the
in the finals, right? Easy, easy choice,
right? But uh you know, I think Azir was
what I ended uh set two with and you
know, there's just you know, just having
one more extra gear at the beginning of
the game makes a big difference. So, uh
it's cool to just see like these
incremental ads for older decks to make
them very popular.
>> Yeah, that's completely true. I mean, so
many so many pieces can still be added
from these new sets. So many things are
still I mean, obviously, set one,
Aurora, still very strong. Mhm.
>> It's so cool to see like how all the
sets are coming together here.
>> Yeah. And I think another example is
like Master Y, right? Got a new legend,
but that's also support for the older
legend for it. I know there's been a big
debate on if, you know, we continue this
mid-range build or we just going to, you
know, put the Aurora into the mastery
deck, right? Um, so like there are these
good decisions that one legend can be
played several different ways.
>> Yeah, I think he especially like is very
interesting with that because we still
are seeing mid-range. We are still
seeing Aurora. It's one of the few
Aurora decks that like does have two
different like play styles, I feel like.
And even more interesting, like I think
back to like set one where sometimes
they had like a hybrid where they could
side out Aurora, side in mid-range. I
wonder if we could see that sometime
today as well.
>> Yeah, for sure. Uh thinking of some
other kind of relevant legends. We we
did some uh you know, overviews uh you
know, looking at them yesterday, but
another one is like Vex. I think Vex has
been, you know, probably one of the best
hold decks that we've really seen in
this game, right? has always been a
little bit more aggressive leaning, but
uh that's been really cool. I really
like the hidden package that we saw from
Sydney. Uh that really just kind of
shakes up the dynamic for that legend.
>> Yeah, I think effects is like really
cool, especially with the fact that like
holding is already so strong in
Riftbound. Uh we saw that obviously like
Grow with Godwillow, uh some of these
different like holding battlefields and
now as a legend ability, I'm really
excited to see what she can do.
>> Yeah, because it's it's so easy like man
I've got, you know, all these resources.
I've hoped, but now I've only got two or
three cards in hand. So to really just
kind of get a double draw for most the
game uh ends up being really really
helpful. So I think that's why Vex has
been very popular. Obviously it's on the
domains of uh calm and chaos, right?
Which uh you know that already has been
shown very strong with Aurelia, right?
Uh probably one of the best legends
still in this meta.
>> Yeah, that is definitely for sure. We
saw it so strong in Sydney. I can't wait
to see like will pull more from Ireelia.
How is this going to work out between
these different decks that do share
colors? Because we've seen with other
legends that share colors that they
don't always play the same exact
>> Yeah. So, uh I think we're going to see
the uh the two decks that we're going to
be going into this one. So, let's get a
look over there and community choice
though. Uh looks like it's going to be
uh ooh Annie versus Rengar for first
match. And then we also do have uh Diana
versus Pike for our match B. Both
fantastic matchups without even looking
at the players names, right?
>> Oh, yeah, for sure. And then looking at
player names as well, obviously we have
Bagel Martini versus Sam D. Sherman.
Obviously, Sam D. Sherman, well-known
name in Riftbell, as well as CTCG Allen
ZQ
>> versus Axis Orbit. So, I mean, both of
these games are kind of looking really
cool.
>> Yeah. And real quick, if you're in chat
right now, put an A or B in the chat on
which match you guys want to watch.
We'll listen to you guys and that will
be the one that we start the uh the
stream for for the match. Uh obviously
if there's time we can jump to the other
one, but let us know if you want the
Annie versus Rengar, put A in the chat.
Otherwise, if you want to see Diana
versus Pike, press B in the chat and uh
yeah, we'll be you A or B. What are you
thinking?
>> Ah, I can't choose honestly. Both of
these look so exciting. We really wanted
to see Rengar, I believe, which is a
really fun one. I also was just watching
some videos on Pike this morning while I
was getting ready. So, and obviously
Allan's EQ so strong and Diana made it,
I believe, into top eight in Sydney.
Sydney. Yeah.
>> So, I think both of these would be great
to watch. What about you?
>> Yeah. Yeah, this is this is really
close. Obviously, you know, if I I think
Diana is going to win, I got to get some
evidence for my uh for that, right? Uh
Rengar has been, I think, a bit on the
up and up, too. Annie has been one of my
my favorite uh legends, too. So, both
are good, but I, as you mentioned, Pike
Pike is also on the rise, right? I do
think Pike could be on the rise this
tournament. I would love to see how far
Pike gets into the tournament. I mean,
we've really kind of been talking about
like Fury has disappeared to some
extent, but Pike might have a different
answer if we do go with the match B.
>> Yeah, I think yeah, B is going to be the
case. So, it's going to be Diana versus
Pike here. And yeah, really, really
cool. I know a lot of people have been
saying again Pike has some some secret
tech. I mean, if you're on Fury and
Chaos, right, we've seen that be very
popular and he's been good. Draven's
been good. So, uh, you know, Jinx has
been good. So, let's see if Pike can can
do the same.
>> I would love to see it do well here.
Obviously,
>> it's going to be up against a bit of a
monster here of Allen's EQ with CTG with
this Diana list.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so, we've seen Diana be
very popular, right? uh the uh
opportunity for like Hawaii, I think one
of the strongest cards from Unleashed
here offers a lot of draw, a lot of
flexibility. Uh and and really just
getting that one extra energy uh between
turns usually uh really really helps you
out. So I think this is a really solid
deck. Looking at the battlefields, uh
nothing too outrageous. Maybe the what
Raven Bloom uh conservatory maybe like a
little bit more peculiar, but not
outrageous.
>> Yeah. And obviously Vex Apathetic here.
such a strong card that we're seeing
played. I think earlier we were shared
some stats where she's in almost like
20% of the decks in this meta and over
half of them I believe were in Diana. So
definitely a really strong card in this
deck and a stay in Diana.
>> Yeah. Yeah, 100%. I think that's very
strong. And uh you know Allen's EQ also
loves their one of I've noticed. So uh
you know one flash, one copy of
smokeokescreen, one copy of the turn to
dust in the main. I think a lot of
people have been targeting, you know,
gear and equipment in their main deck in
this format, too. Uh, also the
acceptable losses love this. Uh, just
the fact that it's just, you know, a one
energy spell ends up being really,
really handy even if you know you're not
playing any uh gear, so it doesn't
affect you negatively. And, uh,
sometimes you just need one more little
tick for the abandoned hall.
>> Yeah, these like gear hate cards I feel
like are really nice when we're worrying
about running into Aurora. Uh, I'm
interested to see how we deal with Pike.
Obviously, a little bit different of a
deck, but just so many cool cards in
this deck for sure.
>> Yeah, and I think we're going to go
switching to the Pike deck to see what's
on the other side. Uh, so really a, you
know, new uh, legend for us here. Has
this ability to return a unit, a
battlefield, a friendly unit to get a
gold gear token exhausted. So, it allows
for a lot of, you know, reuses of
onplays here. But uh yeah, this Odyssey
is a little bit of a different build
than I've kind of been used to, I'd say.
>> Yeah, it's definitely a little bit
different. I'm really excited to see how
they end up using this list. I love
seeing the Baron Nasher. Really excited
to see if we can get that played. I
would love to see that third battlefield
come into play.
>> Yeah, it's it's honestly one of my
favorite cards. I know uh it's been a
little bit tricky to find the best way
to utilize it. I know people started
putting in Aurora decks and they've been
slowly kind of uh rotated out a little
bit, but uh yeah, there are some really
cool interesting plays you get to use
with Pike here and uh like that plus two
uh might across the board is really
really helpful too.
>> Oh yeah, that is going to be so strong.
I do see we do have that long sword
which does mean some of that gear hate
from the Diana list is going to have uh
you know some targets. Uh, but I think
my favorite card in the list just
because it was my favorite card in set
two is that Ferris 4runner which is
really nice because
>> if it gets killed it's the death nail is
that you get to play two three might
mech units which are going to be really
nice then come back that next turn.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh the fact that you
know when it goes away you're able to
have two units to push to both
battlefields as you mentioned very good.
Uh, we also do see Vex, right? I think
again it's going to be uh I think you
quoted what 20% of the decks are on
there. Uh, which we I would expect 20%
of the decks to be chaos decks, right?
That's almost the the numbers there cuz
this has been really really difficult to
take out of any deck that can run it.
>> Yeah. And it's just so strong being able
to stun units that come into play. And I
think it's definitely one of the reasons
that we're seeing it in play so much,
being able to help defend against
attackers, especially with so many ready
units coming in this set.
>> So, okay. Well, those are the two decks
that we've got there. I think they're
ready to go. And let's jump on into this
match. It's going to be again Allen ZQ
on the Diana versus Andy on the uh the
Pike.
uh since you do enjoy Diana too much. Do
you know too much about that like Pike
matchup or anything like that?
>> Not not particularly. I do know that uh
you know I I have been playing a lot of
Diana outright. Again, I've I've been
able to get a lot of like you know game
one sneaky uh acceptable losses, right?
That that ends up being really uh
important there. And it looks like uh
they've chosen their first Battlefields
too. We've got Raven Bloom for Allen's
EQ and then the ZH Warren for for Axis.
>> Yeah, this is going to be so exciting.
Zon Warren's really nice to help draw
through a bit of that deck. Uh I mean it
will work for both players and I know we
were talking about those one of Alan
ZQ's list.
>> I have heard that he's mentioned like
he's happy playing these one-offs
because he can draw to them but it's
really going to be interesting to see
like how that interacts here especially
with the draw the Z warren.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And if I remember correctly
it looks like you know I think Helen's
EQ has you know exponentially more uh
spells in their deck. So, Raven Blue
obviously can work for both sides there,
but uh going to draw more consistently,
I think, for a Diana deck than
necessarily a Pike deck.
>> Yeah, that is definitely for sure here.
It does look like we're just going to be
getting started. Uh I always love seeing
the fist bump.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And, you know, I've I've
played in a couple of these events, too.
Uh always respectful opponents, right?
Uh you take this really seriously and uh
you know, really uh love to love.
>> Yeah, for sure. Uh
>> let's see. It does look like we are just
going to be getting into the
>> game one. Yeah, turn one there. Quick
quick merchant, right? Uh love to see a
two cost unit. Uh when you're going
first here, uh looked like Pike put one
card back, another two cost. We got the
treasure hunter there and back to uh to
Allen's EQ here. But yeah, a lot of back
and forth. And it's nice that, you know,
both these uh decks have some pretty,
you know, easy champions to play out of
their champion zone.
>> Awesome. Yeah, definitely nice to get
some of these early units down. Both
these units really good for kind of
generating some of these resources.
Obviously, traveling merchant when it
moves able to discard and draw a card
and then treasure hunter also able to
help generate some early gold.
>> Yeah, we got the forcross vex off the uh
you know, as soon as we can play it,
right? Uh there probably was a decision
if we want to put it in the
conservatory, right? Uh we are out of
runes active, but we still have our
Diana legend ability that would let us
get one extra uh energy if we need to.
But we're going to go back to our pike
player uh on five runes.
>> Yeah, it is going to be nice for this
pike player knowing that obviously we
kind of only have to account for that
one energy from the Diana legend
ability. Uh but otherwise, as we decide,
do we want to go into Warren? Do we want
to go into Raven Bloom Conservatory?
Only one energy is all we have to worry
about.
>> Yeah, because like you you know,
especially if you're not used to playing
against Diana, that one extra energy can
be really big. Uh you know, if they had
one more open, they could do a ride the
wind, right, unexpectedly. So, looks
like we're going to start off though
with uh the stack deck looking at the
top three grabbing one.
>> Yeah, always nice to help us try to
curate our hand, figure out what we
need. And with that, we still have four
energy open here, whether it be to play
some different units. I also see I think
we see that like falling star that we
could potentially play. Uh
>> we'll go treasure hunter.
>> Let's see. And it does look we are
bringing treasure hunter up into that
Raven Bloom Conservatory now. Starting a
showdown versus the traveling merchant.
>> Yep. And we will be able to produce a
gold gear token uh due to the treasure
hunter. It's going to be one might to
two currently, but looks like uh Axis
has uh something to play as a reaction
here. Oh, but there is also the uh
defense step. Uh let's see at the top of
the deck. Oh, August, which
>> you we could be playing right now.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah, we definitely could. It does look
like long sword is going to come down
here potentially threatening to bring
this to
>> treasure hunter up to Oh, it doesn't
even matter.
>> Yeah, I mean, what a what a perfect card
to get off that conservatory, right?
Immediately gets the value from it.
Prevents them not only from getting the
battlefield, but prevents you from like
equipping the long sword. Uh like just I
couldn't imagine a better card for that
situation. Yeah, definitely a great one.
And Gus does do that unit back to hand
instead of killing it to the trash. Uh
but one thing that's really nice with
these equipment is
>> that long sword is still going to be in
play is a gear in the uh gear that
they'll be able to attach later if they
want to. And it does look like we're
going to be playing that treasure hunter
back into base.
>> Yeah. And you know, we might have wanted
to uh put it back to hand with our pike
legend ability, too. So, it kind of
happened, but we did miss out on the
Gold Gear token. And, uh, being able to
hold the merchant on the conservatory
means again anytime they move into
there, uh, and you get to defend, that
could be another card draw for Diana,
which is really nice. We've got, you
know, six whole runes open, which is
quite a quite a bounty here. And we'll
see what Allen's EQ is thinking here.
>> It looks like we are going to be playing
that Raven Bloom student to the
conservatory.
>> Yeah, I mean, you you got to put the
student in the conservatory, right?
>> Yeah. I I don't think there's a better
place to put it. if I'm being completely
honest here. Um, but it does look like
we're going to take that second
battlefield as well here with that Vex
apathetic into the Zon Warren.
>> Yeah, and this is a pretty, you know,
good start for for Allen's EQ here.
We're already at three points. We've got
four runes open and we might just
decide, you know what, I need these for
defense because I already have a lot of
tempo on my side.
>> Yeah, that is definitely an option here.
And it does look like we're going to be
able to be trying to hold both these
battlefields. uh potentially leaving
that traveling merchant up, but it does
seem like Allan is trying to decide if
he wants to move it back to base and
potentially get that discard and draw.
>> Yeah. And uh considering Okay, we're
going to play out the Diana champion for
three and we're going to pass from
there. Yeah, obviously you're always uh
you know, merchant moving is always a
boon for you. So uh but happy with the
cards on hand. rather keep the extra two
uh might on the battlefield and it's
going to be to axis who starting with
six runes and a gold gear token.
>> Yeah, this is going to be nice slowly
getting I mean we at least have those
energies to try to play some different
units. Uh again looking over at Alan
ZQ's board obviously there is that one
energy that uh could be turned but
obviously that Diana with that legend
ability two energies is starting to get
into a worrisome spot when we're trying
to figure out do we want to move into
zon do we want to move into Raven Bloom
Conservatory or do we need to wait a
turn or two to kind of build up our
base. Yeah, because it's it's so it's so
tricky on on so many levels, right? Uh
having, you know, that's could be two,
you know, one cost spells, right? Which
would mean that the Raven Bloom would be
an additional plus two. Uh if you just
even move to the conservatory, you're
likely giving them another card, like
probably like a 50/50. So, uh all of
that's really really tough for Axis
here.
>> Yeah, and that's another great point
looking at Raven Bloom student with the
ability to grow with each spell that you
play. Sometimes as you're trying to
calculate the might that you're going to
need to get, it gets a little tricky
with Raven Bloom. But we're going to
clear that math up really quickly here.
Playing that falling star to put three
damage on both the units on Raven Bloom
Conservatory and clear up the
battlefield.
>> Yeah. So, being able to use the gold
gear token for that was really helpful.
Uh, you know, will let you, you know,
one not only contest the conservatory,
but also allow you to uh potentially get
the the point there without giving them
the potential draw from that. So going
to equip the long sword to go three
here. We are going to use the effect of
the treasure hunter to be able to
generate the token again. And we are
going to play the stack deck using the
Diana uh energy which is good. So just
making sure that we're using our uh
legend effect while we still can.
>> Yeah. And this is going to be really
nice. Luckily we are able to, as you
said, use the Diana energy stack deck is
going to help us find hopefully a card
that we can use in this following turn.
Um, and let's see what Axis has. He
still has four energy up.
>> Yeah. And so we did end up getting uh,
you know, a conquer there. So that means
we could use the pike ability if we want
to. Uh, would help us get another gold
gear token generated, but we'll see. I
don't know. Again, three on a
battlefield's not too crazy.
>> Yeah, not too crazy at all. I do see we
have uh the
>> I'll tap two
play a tie turner. Oh, it looks like we
are playing tide turner here. Is able to
move the unit from conservatory back to
base
>> for not so full.
>> Yeah.
>> And we should be able to generate
another gold gear token from the
treasure hunter. Yeah. And there it is
there. And we've played a couple cards
now. So, uh, we do get the reduced cost
there. And, uh, passing it back to
Allen's EQ.
>> Yeah. It is so nice cuz Nox is hopeful
with Legion. Once you play another card
that turn, you are able to play it just
for two. And as we know, saving on
resources to play things is really nice
in this game.
>> Yeah. So moving there and then
considering using the Diana champion
ability. Uh and looks like that's the
case. Yeah.
>> Uh stack.
>> Not not too upset with that. And we do
have the defense uh for the
conservatory. Uh potentially
>> conquer to five.
>> All right. And yeah, uh, quick a quick
three to two there. So, we do get
another point. Uh, Vex is still in play
on a battlefield, so if they end up
playing anything, but without any runes
open for Axis, uh, you know, the
interaction is very, really limited.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's so nice, especially I
mean, for Allen going up there, he knows
exactly what to expect. There's no runes
up, so he's just able to get that Diana
in. It does look like he's going to be
playing a second Vex Apathetic here into
that Raven Bloom Conservatory.
>> Yeah, and leaving four open, which is
again a little terrifying here. Uh we
aren't necessarily on game point. If
both these hold, we're going to be to
seven points, but uh you know, even just
getting one of these to be held uh and
going to six of the star next turn is is
quite strong.
>> Yeah, I mean I would definitely be
concerned here as Axis. You don't know
what Allen's EQ could decide to put down
if he decides to move on these battle
battlefields. And we're getting a little
bit close to some of these like
worrisome points. We obviously don't
lose in one turn, but two turns when
we're at one point can be concerning.
>> Yeah, and there's only three cards in
hand for Axis right now. We've got uh
six runes and two gold gear tokens. So,
we've got like room for some plays, but
uh you know, we've been kind of on the
back foot momentum wise, I think, for
the majority of this game. Yeah, it does
feel like that for the Pike.
I'm trying to think
>> what Pike would potentially play here.
It does look like we're going to be
>> playing something turn. It does look
like Starross is going to be coming
down. So, uh we are going to be
targeting the uh Vex there. Uh does uh
you know have deflect. So, we do have to
recycle one additional. So, we got rid
of both of our gold gear tokens. But uh
you know this is a a pretty good like
tempo swing for our side. That does mean
that we can Nox is hopeful there. Uh
decide on any interaction.
>> And looks like we are going to play the
stack deck for one.
>> Look at the top three.
>> Yeah. And that's like one of the my
favorite things is like being able to
use like the defensive stack deck,
right? Making sure that you have a scary
amount of runes open and then still
being able to use them without passing
over too many open ones.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. and getting
to use some of these different triggers
to use stack deck. We get to obviously
give access as little information
possible with those four runes up now
three. And we also get more information
for ourselves to figure out what to play
here.
>> Yeah.
All right. So, thinking of the other
two, I mean, we do know that we do have
like the treasure hunter in hand if we
want to play it out. I think for like
the third or fourth time this game it's
been it's been played a lot but using
the two here
>> and oh looks like we are going to end up
using the ability on Pike to date
another gold gear token and put the
hopeful back into hand
>> and we could play it again yeah for two
since we did play the star cross. So uh
does offer you know a little bit of
mitigation for the uh you know gold that
we lost but yeah passing it back to
Allen's EQ here. Yeah, I think that's
like a nice use to kind of save the
Nox's hopeful. We're able to tiptoe into
the Zon Warren and then get out safely.
Obviously, it does cost a bit of a bit
of of energy, but it does keep it safe.
>> Yeah,
>> Moonfall.
>> Here is the Moonfall here. So, uh moving
the hopeful over does also cause a
another uh spell from the conservatory.
We're going to use the one from the
effect of the Diana champion and
currently it's two to I think seven. So
an easy clear for that hopeful.
>> Yeah, Moonball feels so strong in Diana.
Uh you get to choose a battlefield
you're already at, pull a unit from your
opponent's side to the battlefield and
also decrease its might. Uh which just
feels so nice.
>> Yeah. And it's when there is a Vex at a
battlefield and there's no units on the
board, it's so, you know, tough cuz
anything get that gets played gets
stunned, right? It can't move. Uh, Vex
really kind of puts you in these kind of
like mild checkmate situations.
>> Yeah. And now we're also I mean Axis
needs to do something. Allen ZQ has two
units in base and obviously would be
holding to seven. Could conquer Zon
Warren for eight and Axis does scoop and
it looks like we're be going to game
two.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's just, you know, Allan
had a lot of early momentum. Uh, you
know, going first, being able to play a
unit on two, which is great. Uh, and
just being able to continue it up,
right? Uh, I think honestly the biggest
thing was that gust. That gust was just
so good for capitalizing your momentum.
And, uh, Axis had a hard time, I think,
recovering from it.
>> Yeah, he definitely did seem to do um to
have trouble with it. I feel like Gus is
pretty strong this set. Yeah. Uh
obviously it's got like a lot of play
against a lot of different decks and
then it really just like stopped that
treasure hunter just like you're saying.
>> Yeah. And specifically when you uh you
know it move it with uh with Diana like
you have access to uh reducing might so
Gus gets more targets for that. So I
think that helps it quite a bit. But
we're going into game two. Uh we've got
abandoned hall and the arena's greatest.
I'm going to mildly assume axis is going
to go first. Generally if you're using
arena's greatest it's because you know
you're going first. And then the
abandoned hall, which again, we've got
so many spells that we can use on
Allen's EQ's side, that extra might that
keeps going up and up.
>> Yeah, I it definitely seems like Allen's
EQ has gotten like perfect battlefields
for this Diana's list. Uh on Axis's
side, I'm interested to see how he kind
of deals with Allen's EQ's tempo cuz
obviously he seemed to move very fast
last game and be able to really harness
that to get the win. And Arena's
greatest is going to speed this game up
even more
>> for sure. So looking at our opening
hands, Allen's uh ZQ thinking about
putting one back so far. Axis looking at
a couple of cards. I think I already do
see a merchant in hand, which is really
all you really want, something to play
on your first two runes and considering
the rest of it.
>> Yeah. And it looks like we have a Noxis
hopeful as well, which is one of my
favorite uh units uh just because you do
get to decrease that the cost of it if
you played another card. Uh so does look
like we're gonna get started here.
>> Yeah, we're starting us off and I think
we uh mulligan one hopeful for uh into a
KISSA. So I think that was a good choice
there uh for two and uh
>> getting the point there. So
passing it back to Alen's EQ.
>> You'll have to see what Allen has here.
Uh, I think mulligans are so interesting
in this game because you don't shuffle
after you mulligan, which means even if
you mulligan into something that you
maybe don't want. Obviously, I think you
may need want the Kai'Sa here, but even
you mulligan into something that you
don't want, it is still the card you
were going to draw anyway. So, you're
just moving further into your deck.
>> Definitely. And one of my favorite
things about Diana is because we have a
champion unit that costs three, that's,
you know, very good. Uh, I don't even
mind going second half the time because
I know I have a guaranteed play, right?
just being able to play it from the
champion zone and uh and passing it
back.
>> Yeah, and it seems like that's exactly
what we're going to do, but it is always
nice when you're going second to kind of
have that assurance definitely. So, uh
using the ability, we're going to get
rid of the Kai'Sa in our hand uh from
the merchant to draw one. Uh we do get
to two points for access here. Uh and
there, you know, obviously a
consideration on using the pike ability
right now if we want to paying the one
to uh then return to hand and get a gold
gear token.
Yep. Uh
I this choosing to discard the Kai'Sa
was was surprising to me, but I can kind
of understand it. It does seem like we
have a really strong hand and to some
extent
>> on the move
>> unless you're like fully accelerating
the Kai'Sa. Sometimes Kai'Sa you're
playing it for that draw one.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I mean I've I've played so
many games where it's like two drop on
two Kai'Sa and four, right? But uh you
know this does offer
>> a opportunity to Yeah. put the merchant
back here. uh get the gold gear token.
Um and we got a lot of cycle and the
gold here. So, we've you know, I think
had a pretty solid start from Axis.
>> Yeah, I think this is going to be really
nice. Hopefully, we can capitalize on it
to get this win. Uh but it looks like
Diana is going to be coming up into that
abandoned hall.
>> Yeah. So, uh which is a great uh
battlefield for us to defend with,
especially Yeah. Stupify off the top
there. Uh in abandoned hall, it's one
energy uh you know, plus two might def
def deficit. So that ends up being
really, really handy there.
>> Yes, this is going to be really nice.
We'll have to see what else we decide to
play. Looks like Raven Bloom Student is
going to be going into that base again,
especially with how many spells we play
in this deck. Raven Bloom can can become
a bit of a monster itself.
>> Yeah, I mean, if when it's in the
abandoned hall, you play one supify, you
get plus two might, you give something
else minus one might. That's a huge
swing for just one, and then you get to
draw a card. So, uh, really good synergy
there.
>> Yeah, that's going to be really nice to
see. I'm excited to see play it play
out. Um,
>> all right, we've got six runes for Axis.
I felt like they were at six runes for
most the game last time, but uh, you
know, we have to be a little bit afraid
of what the three runes on the other
side can be. I think ride the winds
should always be in your mind as a
potential card there. Um, but you know,
if we're able to continue kind of the
momentum, make gold to help us like pay
for some power costs too, can be really
helpful.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And you always have to worry
about ride the wind when you're like
moving into some of these different like
battlefields cuz especially if they ride
the wind into your battlefield and
you're not expecting it or your unit
doesn't have a lot of bite like that
traveling merchant, they can cause a bit
of a problem.
>> Yeah. So, we are going to play our third
Kai'Sa uh and we're going to accelerate
it and move to the abandoned hall which
is a little bold I'd say when one we
know that the stupify just got added to
hand.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. Stupify would
bring us down to three and obviously
that Diana
>> just would keep growing.
>> All right, but looking here. So we got
uh one I think Allen ZQ is thinking
about that Diana champion ability. So
again, we can pay one here to get the
vision, but looks like we are just going
to play the stack deck.
>> Use the ability. Look top three.
>> All right, there is a response window.
Okay, with the gust. Okay, on the other
side
>> and there's the stupify. Yeah,
>> yeah, stupify is gonna make Diana a
little bit too big for Gus to come down.
Uh, meaning that the stack deck,
>> we'll see what they get from the stack
deck as well. But
>> Kai'Sa versus Diana now. I think Diana
is just slightly
>> bigger than Kai'Sa.
>> So, uh, there is a couple of, uh, things
here. So, one, we played two spells. So,
Bannon Hall plus two here. Uh, Supy
gives the minus one might to Kai'Sa. So,
I think it's five to three. And uh
unfortunately our third and final Kai'Sa
does enter the trash there.
>> Ouch.
>> Yeah. And additionally likely not going
to matter, but you know, we do get the
plus two from uh the student as well.
We've played uh I think what three
spells. Okay. There's plus two might.
Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, we still have the choice to move
the uh merchant up. It's likely going to
get bullied next turn though when we are
out of runes to use, but we'll see what
Axis decides to do. traveling.
>> Yeah, it does seem like he is going to
choose to go in and move up into that
arena's greatest. Regardless, hopefully
we will get to see that discard and
draw. It looks like we're going to
discard Tide Turner potentially going
into a Falling Star, which could be
helpful to try to deceit some of these
different units on Allen's EQ's side.
>> Yeah, and you know, the numbers
currently make sense, but when you can
uh, you know, have a three might unit at
Abandon Hall, right? You just have to
play one spell with React to get out of
it. Uh you still take the damage, but
you know this is again you're hoping
that they weren't going to be able to
interact with you but Allen's EQ found a
way.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And it looks
like we are back on Alen's Q's side
playing Tide Turner kind of getting this
Diana safe
>> combat.
>> Yeah. So we're going to move uh the
Diana back with Tide Turner. Move it up
to the arena's greatest. We know that
they have no runes open, so it's going
to be three to two.
And yeah, we've just, you know, we've
been able to bully with these exact
numbers, I feel like.
>> Yeah, 100%. And Hay is going to be
coming down as well, but Allan's EQ up
to four points here, especially on these
even numbers. It's it's feeling really
strong for our Diana player.
>> Yeah. So, good things though for for
Axis one. Uh currently, you know,
doesn't have any runes open, which is
great. Uh and that also means like you
know if uh they're considering this
falling star it does get the full clear
uh without really any you know
opportunity for interaction uh recycling
two runes is a little bit expensive I
think right now but oh actually using on
the way uh which I think is valid that
card can get you so much value by
itself. It is a priority target.
>> Yeah, it's really nice to get that off
the board before it can really do
anything too disastrous to us. And then
obviously we have a good number of runes
up as well to try to figure out the rest
of this turn.
>> Yeah, and we don't have a Vex for
Allen's EQ. So, uh that's kind of the
other bonus point there. It does mean if
we have any acceleration, we are in a
good spot. Unfortunately, we did get rid
of I think every Kai'Sa uh already. So,
it's a little bit tough to to do so, but
we do have it looks like a hopeful in
hand still, which we can play for two
there.
>> Yeah, and it's so nice getting
discounted down to two. I still four
runes up. I'm assuming we're going to
play something else as well.
>> Yeah, I think so. I see a fizz there. I
mean, Falling Star again, you you'd be
recycling three more runes, but you
know, being able to interact with, you
know, three of their units could be the
Temple Swing you're looking for, but
it's it's a greedy play rune-wise.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. And you have to
lay weigh like do
>> is this the turn I should do it? Mhm.
>> Will it, you know, be enough? And it
does look like Fizz is going to come
come down just like you mentioned.
>> Oh, but we also we don't Sorry, we don't
even have any fury runes left. So that's
true. Yeah. So we can't even play the
falling star. Uh so I mean the Gust is
still a standard option. That's totally
fine. Uh so it does get rid of the
champion. So the tempo still is in our
way, but we did have to recycle a lot
this turn to interact with them.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. We still have
one rune up as well. Uh but moving back
to Allen's side, one is not the worst
act to count for.
>> Yeah. So, uh this does give them the uh
Allen's EQ a moderate opportunity to uh
get to even points uh which helps you
get like a double conquer for game.
We're going to use the uh student there
to go from five to six.
>> And looks like we're playing out uh
another copy of Hawaii here. So, you
know, we got rid of one. We're going to
play another one. See if it's able to
survive a little bit longer here. And uh
and then yeah, we do have the uh
returned previously Diana to the board.
>> Yeah, we are really building out that
base here. I mean, we're at six. Next
turn, we definitely can threaten lethal.
And we're just I mean, it's looking like
a lot, but at least on Axis's side, the
only energy we have to account for is
that legend ability. Yeah. Yeah. So,
like it shouldn't be too tough for us to
get rid of the student. We got to be
like a little bit worried that like a
stupify could, you know, get the deficit
for a uh hopeful.
>> Mhm.
>> But uh the the bigger thing is that
yeah, if they double conquer next turn,
they just win the game.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. We can we could
potentially hold up to seven. All we
have to do then is take back that
abandoned hall.
And I'm sure that is something Axis is
thinking about here as he tries to
figure out what he can do. if he could
hold abandoned hall, he could, you know,
save save this off for an extra turn.
>> Um, but he definitely can't leave it
open.
>> Yeah. So, uh, looking at cards in hand
that we can see, right, I think,
>> uh, you know, not necessarily the ones
we're looking for. Uh, we haven't really
played the Pike champion this match
either. It's just been kind of hanging
out on the board there. But, yeah,
again, we can the the answer to this
turn is not like too difficult. the fact
that next turn uh you know we're
potentially in a really really tough
spot with a double conquer potential.
>> Yeah, that is
probably weighing on Axis's mind here. I
wonder what he's going to decide to do.
It looks like we're bringing Nexus Hope
up into the arena's greatest. Raven
Bloom does die, but
>> no. Now, one nice thing is that uh we do
have the Fizz and we did get two fury
runes for turn, right? So, uh, if we are
able to move Fizz through the abandoned
hall, we could use our legend ability to
return it to hand and then use it to
replay the Fizz and play Falling Star to
get rid of two more units there. So,
that could be the play here. Uh, but
again, it's anytime you're using Falling
Star, especially off Fizz, it's a lot of
runes you're sacrificing.
>> Yeah, that is a great point. It is up
into abandoned hall here. I wonder if
he'll do exactly what you just said.
>> If you say every play that they could
do, you'll eventually be right. I think
so.
>> What are the days,
>> but looks like we are going to be paying
the one off the uh pike there. So, yeah,
going to return the Fizz at the
abandoned hall. Uh and then we do have
quite a few uh options here for not only
what we could play, but the targets from
what we play.
>> I'll play the Fizz for
>> Fizz. We're going to put it on the uh
okay, the Arena's Graves, which is fine.
Uh going to use it for the falling star
and then paying that for two to get rid
of uh both of the Diana and the TIE
turner. So, it's only Huei left this
time around.
>> Yeah, it looks like we've switched it up
a bit. Last time we used that falling
star to only take out the way. This time
we're leaving only Houe. So, we'll have
to see.
>> I mean, if that changes anything, but at
least it does mean that Allen's EQ would
need something that's an additional one
that's ready to be able to take back
both battlefields, which is the only way
he could win here.
>> Yeah. So, you also have three open, so
there could be some interaction from
Axis here, but honestly, not in a
terrible spot. It's been again I think
Axis has been on the back foot quite a
bit so far but going to just start with
the move trigger. See if anything
>> activates here. No, just get the draw
one discard one. Looks like we are going
to get the Baron out of hand. So this
would offer plus three might for the
Haye and we are going to react with the
Starross. So
>> that is going to be a huge tempo swing
here. Starcross being able to use it to
uh return the Haye and likely the uh Vex
to hand. And yeah, the Fista hand. Yeah,
and that's going to be the play here.
And now we're in a tough spot where
yeah, we just have to play out our uh
you know, Hawaii out again and we'll see
if there's any other units left in
Allen's hand.
>> Yeah, but that feels so nice for Axis.
He was able to hold uh well, not hold,
but
>> pretty good
>> to to temporary.
>> Yeah, the way it would get hold off the
the wind just yet.
>> Yeah, but force the ride the wind. Uh
the good thing about this is that um
they would have to essentially have a
second ride the wind if they want to try
to wind on this turn. So, uh it is like
a little bit more board clear up for
Allen's EQ. It does offer some
interaction from Axis next turn, but uh
still a really aggressive play and we
are going to play the unacceptable
losses it looks like to get rid of their
gold gear. So, another good play for
this as well.
>> Good.
>> And uh yeah, that's going to be able to
>> get rid of uh the hopeful. Put us to
seven points. Uh Haye could move back
into the base if wanted. So, it looks
like the K's going to another draw one
and discard one potentially.
Gets the Moonfall to get another draw.
>> And we do still have two runes up here.
It does look like we're going to use
them to play another unit. So, I mean,
at seven points, we still do have to
either conquer and then hold or conquer
both sides because you can't win or you
can't take the eighth point just by
conquering one side.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, uh, being able to play
out a second unit, I think was, uh,
needed. So, uh, it was good for Allen's
EQ to be able to represent that. Uh, and
then, yeah, it's it's something like if
they can't interact with just moving two
units to two battlefields, it's going to
be a W for Allen's EQ.
>> It definitely could be here. Uh, looking
for some card that can get these units
in, like you said,
>> and we've got five runes here again. I
think we returned a fizz to our hand. So
that could interact there. Going to use
the ability uh with yeah the uh star
cross there. Um so it will return both
to hand. So again you're not like
immediately uh losing next turn, but you
are just kind of running out of
resources pretty quickly. Yeah, I feel
like I mean we're trying to save off
some of these different turns, but
>> I mean Allan Q willing to move up into
one of these battlefields and if he is
able to take one of these battlefields
to draw an extra card. It does look like
we are going to be just going on
conceding though for that victory for
Allen's EQ.
>> Yeah. So, real quick, it was a Fizz said
I have ride the wind. Is that going to
be I'm I'm sure there's so many
different ways to do that, but with with
the unit there, uh that is enough. So,
Allan takes it. uh 2.
>> What a fantastic job by Allen's EQ just
showing how how Diana can so easily and
quickly kind of just like take over and
take control of the board.
>> Yeah. And the the other thing too is
that it's it's such a flexible deck when
there's so many interactions that can uh
happen, right? The uh losses I think was
again I'm I've been really liking that
card in the deck. So, it's been cool to
see even just like the usage to get rid
of a gold gear token ended up being I
think impactful. And uh you know when
you're playing it with abandoned hall
that plus one might can just be all the
difference.
>> Yeah, I mean it really has like the two
different uses there just like you
mentioned and I mean giving those that
plus might giving the ability to take
resources away from your opponent which
is really nice balance EQ.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It just always felt like
Pike was a little bit on the back foot.
Uh like Falling Star did help you like
even out on tempo but just meant you
couldn't capitalize on the next turn.
And I don't know like it looked like
that match up was really tough. I
wouldn't be the ma the master of it, but
uh it did look tough.
>> Yeah, it definitely did seem a bit
difficult and there's just such a
controlling spot that Allan CQ was in
the whole time.
>> Mhm.
>> I would love to see Pike do great, but
definitely seemed like a hard spot for
him.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Cuz uh you know, in those
situations, right, uh you know, there
was potential like maybe if we had like
a little bit more runes or a little bit
more ahead like uh the interaction with
like Fizz and Starcross just to be able
to continue having cards on the board
there. I think that sometimes Diana it's
really good at like playing uh units out
turn by turn, but they don't really have
as much movement outside of like Ride
the Wind or like maybe like the uh Tide
Turner. So like if you are able to kind
of slow them down on their units, you
can kind of capitalize on that a little
bit.
>> That makes a lot of sense. I wonder if
like if there's like some world where
with the Kaisen accelerate, maybe we
could have taken more control of board,
but
>> it's so difficult especially to figure
out what you're supposed to do to make
that win.
>> Yeah. Like I think that you know the
idea that man we had one Kaiso so we
could use that was fine. Uh seeing all
three of them hit the trash and two of
them from merchants was a little bit
surprising for me without seeing the
full hand, right? That's always
something that uh you know I don't get
to see all the cards that they've seen,
right? But uh you know there definitely
were times like man sometimes you just
play it for four and then you get the
value that you really need from it too.
>> Yeah. And getting that draw when you're
able to conquer as well just is such a
great ability on Kaiso.
>> Yeah. But it was cool to see like the
pike uh legend ability be used early,
right? To especially since you were able
to use it with uh you know moving the
merchant back and then like leaving the
uh battlefields empty. I think that was
a good interaction for you. But uh to
make the gold gear token and still get
the advantage, but uh yeah, Diana is
still able to capitalize I think on a
lot of cycle and card draw that Pike is
sometimes missing out on still.
>> Yeah, I would definitely agree and I do
think like what you said is so
important. It was so cool to watch that
Pike be able to keep the Nox's hopeful
safe. uh be able to take the
battlefield, bring it back to hand, play
it. Even with the Fizz when we then took
a battlefield and then kind of moved it
to the other side with that ability.
There's definitely some interesting
plays that could be done with the legend
ability.
>> Yeah, cuz I I love like a good combo,
right? And we can see like just some of
the lines that you can do with it
already. Uh you know, especially with
Fizz with it too and starcross like
that, being able to play, you know, play
Fizz, putting it back, play another
thing. Uh just all those interactions
for, you know, being able to use a card
more than once. uh you can really run
away with some abilities.
>> Yeah, it'll be really interesting to see
like especially as we get more cards
with different sets or as this one set
continues what Pike could do cuz I think
there's a lot of potential in the deck.
>> Yeah. And uh I think real quick uh it
looks like you know everyone who voted
for match A, you're going to get a
reward as well cuz I think we're going
to go through that one since this was a
little bit of a quicker one. But uh I
I'd have to remember I think it was
Annie was one of them versus Rengar.
Yes, Annie versus Rengar, which is going
to be really exciting. Obviously, Annie
has done well in the past.
>> Uh, but it's gotten some extra pieces.
I'm really excited about that Kha'Zix.
Obviously, it's running that Beex
apathetic, but honestly, one of my
favorite arts of this set is what they
did with the Porros. So, I love seeing
that in this Annie list.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Annie has been, I think, uh,
you know, uh, one of the best legends in
this game. Uh, you know, I played it
quite a bit in in set one, and we've get
more and more things. I mean, just two
runes open, like extra two runes every
every turn, right, is is really helpful,
especially when we have more and more
cards used with it. I think as you
mentioned, Kha'Zix for ambush has been
really key. Uh, and when it only costs
two essentially for you on defense, uh,
is it's even better.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. Getting to use
like these different uh, energy
returning abilities like this, the Annie
Dark Child's ability with those two
runes like you mentioned for Kha'Zix if
it wants to, if it wants to use it for
different spells. It's gonna be so nice
to defend. Uh kind of like cheating in
this extra energy.
>> Yeah. And oh, if we want to talk about
ambush cards though, we can look at
Rengar, too, which is going to be the uh
the on the other side. So, we'll look at
that real quick. But honestly, you know,
I I looked at this the first time like
I'm not sure uh what the synergies are.
But when I see more and more people
play, I'm like, man, this is this is a
lot of fun, right?
>> Yeah. Rengar looks like so much fun. I
do think the best of list from Sydney
had a bit more dragons in it than this
list. Yeah.
>> Uh, so I'm excited to see how this one
plays, but this is such an interesting
take on Rengar.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Honestly, just being able to
ambush, you know, a champion from the
champion zone. Love that. Love that
mechanic that so many different legends
from this set get. So, uh, we're just
going to go right into the game. I think
they're ready already. So, uh, we're
going to jump over there. It's going to
be Annie versus Rengar. Uh, and yeah, I
think we're going to get the full match,
which is a nice treat there. So, uh,
game one is going to be Zon Warren, as
we saw, uh, for our first match, uh,
versus, uh, the Emperor's Das on, uh,
Rengar side,
>> which is going to be really exciting. I
actually love ambush with Rengar. I
think Rengar is one of the first cards
as well to have ambush back in Spirit
Forge, and I know when I used to play
League of Legends, Rengar jumping out of
the bush and ambushing me was a
nightmare.
>> Yes. Yeah. And when you are able to get
that additional might, uh, and one thing
I I mention it every time because it
took me an extra read to realize this.
You can just choose any of your units to
get the plus one might. It doesn't have
to be the card that you play. Uh,
whenever you play something, Rengar
gives that boost and that's really,
really helpful.
>> Yeah, that is so nice to have that
option. And obviously Sam Sherman, we've
seen him before, especially from Las
Vegas. Uh, he is a, you know, seasoned
player, and I'm really excited to see
how he pilots this list.
>> Yeah, and looks like we're getting
started pretty quickly. So, Merchant on
one there. We've seen that pretty much
the first match as well. Uh, and then we
have the uh Grim Apothecary on uh one
for Sam.
>> Um, let's see what they do with it.
Um,
>> and one of the nice things too is that
like Rengar can take advantage of some
of these hidden cards that are units.
So, you can get like an additional
surprise plus one might. Uh but looks
like we are going to use the merchant
and we are going to move that over to
the emperor's uh dis here. Real quick
too if you guys don't know what this uh
battlefield does because it's a little
bit more unusual. When you conquer here
you can pay one and return a unit you
control here to your hand. If you do get
to play a two might sand soldier unit
token here. So uh definitely understood
why Sam a battlefield that plays a unit
means that you can give an additional
plus one might somewhere. Uh and that
can be again uh really helpful for some
situations. So, we got the Porro, we've
got the uh Noxis Hopeful, a good combo
for four runes and passing it back to
Sam.
>> Yeah, and I can only imagine as well
with so many ambush cards in this Rengar
list that getting to return the ambush
card to your hand, be able to
continually use that is just going to be
so nice. Seems to synergize really well
with this deck.
>> Yeah. So, uh we got the whole five runs.
And we can uh you know push into the uh
battlefield there against the merchant
especially when they've got uh nothing
up. I think they meant to un uh they
could have two runes open I think right
now but it is a an up to ability there.
So
>> we do have the pit rookie there which
will offer a buff to that and then again
we did play out a unit so it's going to
be a five might apothecary there.
>> Yeah that is going to be one strong
apothecary. I absolutely love pit rookie
especially with those different buffs
and it does look like it is gonna be
going up into that emperor's das just
like you mentioned
>> uh one to one
>> traveling merchant to the graveyard or
to the trash.
>> Yeah. And then also using the initiate
there uh since we did have a mighty unit
uh off of all the additional plus ones
and and buffs we got uh an additional
draw which is great. So uh some really
good synergy there and yeah it's going
to be one point to one as we go to bagel
martini.
Let's see then what they're able to do.
We do have those two units that we
played last turn. Uh and stacked deck
will help us try to find some of those
last pieces that we want to be able to
make this into our perfect turn. Both
players are at one point, so we could
potentially go up to three here.
>> Yep. And yeah, it's going to be a little
bit tough to uh get across the
apothecary. It's currently at four
might. So uh you know, we could get some
additional might to challenge it there
with no runes open for Sam. is going to
be a little bit easier for us to say
they don't really have any interactions,
but looks like moving the Noxus hole
full. We'll see where it goes.
>> Let's see. Yeah, and Noxle is going to
be coming up for that Emperor's Das uh
up against the And it looks like they
are both going to die there.
>> Yeah,
>> just trading it off. And the Porro up
into the Das now.
>> Yeah. So, uh yeah, unfortunately, yeah,
not just having any additional ways to
interact. Could be like a long sword or
something, right? But uh you know still
I think a valid trade for us. Uh we're
going to play four
>> for a uh a Vex. Nice. So that will
prevent uh you know this is a pretty big
counter I think to uh what Rengar wants
to do with ambush being able to stun uh
you know units the turn they're played.
This could be a big wall if Sam doesn't
have an answer to it.
>> Yeah, it definitely seems like it
counters a lot of this like ambush idea.
Uh because even if you played ambush
because they're stunned, they will not
be able to deal damage to your other
opponent. Uh which is going to be a bit
of a problem here. Sam is taking a bit
of a look here trying to figure out if
he has any answers to that Vex.
>> Now one one thing you could do is that
you know you could play a unit. You can
make your initiative a four might and
you can try to go four to four to get
rid of it. Um you know Vex is also a
card that it is really capital when
you're already ahead, right? So, if
you're able to interact with it now,
it's going to be difficult to set up a
second one later. So, uh if you have any
ways to interact with it, even if it's
costly, it might be worth it right now.
>> Yeah, I think that is definitely a good
play. If we could get that Vex off the
board as quickly as possible, it does
look we have that option for pit rookie
to increase the might as well uh of that
unit. I mean, there's a couple options
and obviously Sam does have a bit of a
hand that he'll be able to try to figure
out the puzzle with.
>> Yeah, but it's just like it's always so
scary about Annie, like they always have
runes up, right? There are so many
different things that could happen. Uh
some negative interaction for you and
and then you just, you know, lose the
tempo, right? So that it's just being
able to be offensive and then be able to
have that safety net of having the runes
open is super scary. But we're going to
just start with the pit rookie. Uh
trying to just go two to two here.
Yeah, sometimes it's so nice being able
to just move one unit at a time up, try
to pick off some of the different uh
units on the opponent's side. We could
still kill the Porro here, potentially
then bring in the other unit and
hopefully finish off Vex. Uh but let's
see. We are going to go and use two
runes though on Bagel's side. And that's
also another great part of moving in
these units one at a time.
>> Yeah, and looks like we're going to get
the long sword. Uh, but we're gonna add
it to the Vex here. So, we're still
going to be able to go into the uh the
Porro there, which is still, I think, a
pretty good trade. We could have also
put it on the Porro uh to prevent a
trade uh for either of them. It would
have been just two four might units, but
uh I think I think Sam's kind of okay
with this interaction here.
>> Mhm. Uh yeah, I think let's see.
Now, if we can play three units, we can
get plus three might and we can go six
to six. So, that's, you know, I would
generally want to do that. But, Pit
rookie offers plus two might with the
buff and the uh plus one from Rengar.
So, if we got another unit to play,
there's a good chance that we can just
do a full trade here.
>> Yeah, that would be really nice going on
getting that Vex off the board. Also
does go and set up two more units in
base. And obviously, we do well, we had
five, now we have three runes still. And
just as you said, another unit comes
down
>> and another unit. All right. So, it's
going to be uh seven might on Sam's side
to six might on Bel uh Bel Martini's
side. And that will be it looks like
enough uh to be able to get that
battlefield. And that's going to be
really really good for Sam and tough for
Bego Martini to reestablish that Vex as
we mentioned.
>> Yeah, for sure. I think that was such a
like smart play by Sam D. Sherman by
playing in that pit rookie first. We got
a lot of information about what he was
actually going to have to deal with.
Obviously, more runes got played on Bigo
Martini's side. We were able to see how
much might the Vex would actually have
when we needed to finish it off. And
then we can use that information to then
take not only trade the Vex against the
Vex, but actually take the battlefield.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, you know, if we put the
long sword in the the Porro, it would
have made it a little bit, you know,
harder to take the battlefield. It would
have been easier to remove just the Vex
itself. But looks like we're going into
the Kai'Sa here. We're going to
accelerate it. We're going to get the uh
draw one and then also the discard one
draw one from Zan Warren. So, some new
cards entering the hand. Getting rid of
the merchant.
>> Fortunately, we are out of fury runes,
too. So, there won't be any way for us
to uh you know, attach the long sword
there.
>> Yes, too bad. Uh we do get those extra
cards though to figure out what we want
to do with the two runes. Obviously,
when we pass back on our turn, we will
get two runes back with that Annium
ability, just like you mentioned. Uh,
but for now, just two. I mean, there's a
lot of options though in red, purple for
what you can do with two runes. And not
having to worry about not having any
runes up is going to be really nice.
Tide Turner is going to protect this
Kai'Sa once it's played. You get to
switch spots with another unit, meaning
Kai'Sa is going to be safe in base where
that Tide Turner is a little bit more
vulnerable in Z on Warren. Yeah, the
more I play this game, like tie turn has
never been a bad card, man. It's just so
good. There's just so many situations.
Uh the fact that you can hide it, the
fact that you can use it to move things,
like it's it's just been I think the
backbone of like one of the reasons uh
you know, Chaos has been so strong.
>> Yeah, for sure. The hidden tide turner I
feel like is what always gets me at
Nexus Knights.
>> Uh when I've gone, I for some reason
never think it could be a unit
>> switcheroo, right? Is it you know, it
can't be uh you know, what are the
options here? Just plus two might.
That's enough for me. A dang.
>> Yeah, you never know what it could be.
But uh yeah, other unless we're against
Teemo, then I'm like maybe it could be a
unit.
>> Could be a unit. Yeah. But uh it's it's
a definitely a sneaky hidden unit for us
here. But Sam's got uh I think a bit of
the front foot now. We've got I believe
what nine runes open for us. We've got
quite a few units on the board here. uh
you know, we still have our Rengar uh
champion unit that we can interact with,
but this is a really good kind of uh
change of pace for them.
>> Yeah, this is going to be nice. Trying
to figure out what here. Obviously, we
don't have to worry about the stuns this
this turn. Um and we have a good bit of
runes to play with.
>> Let's see what he decides to do.
>> Almost like too many decisions, right?
Like some when you only have like two
choices, it's easy. But when you've got
uh like this wide open world, you got to
make sure you're you're doing it right.
But we got the Darius here. Uh one of
our, you know, best best cards I think
in Fury uh by itself. Uh you're giving
the plus one might off the Rengar uh
ability there. And then we're going to
pay another two it looks like and
recycle one for
uh sorry
second. Oh,
>> let's see. Oh,
>> thinking think again. Yeah. Um, but
yeah, Darius is so interesting. If we
can play that second card, Darius also
will be ready and have another plus two
might. So, be plus three on top, making
it eight might. And then it could
potentially go into that's on Warren's.
We could see obviously the other units
as well since Tide Turner is a little
bit on the smaller side, but you do
still have to account for those two
runes up.
>> Yeah. So, uh, my guess is like maybe
thinking about playing something like
challenge here. uh you know being able
to get rid of the Kai'Sa in the back I
think would be very strong. Uh we're
currently at six knight uh to their four
and then with the additional uh effect
as we play our second one. Yeah, we're
going to choose challenge here.
>> Yep, you are correct. Challenge is going
to come down. They'll both deal their
might to each other. Uh meaning
currently it is that four might into the
Darius. The Darius doing
>> and then
>> eight might. But then we additionally uh
that's the second card we've played. So,
we do have the plus three here.
>> Oh, okay. There's the I was curious what
what what color dice was for the the
damage taken. So, uh we currently have
eight might. We've taken four damage.
So,
>> uh there is a potential for us to just
really get rid of the the tide turner,
>> but we've got the assault two, I
believe. So,
>> that will be enough.
>> Get the Z warren battlefield activation.
this heels.
>> Believe we're at four points to three
now. And
>> again, just
>> being able to get rid of that Kaiso,
something that can offer a lot of card
draws. Really nice.
>> Yeah. And that turn by Sam, he was just
really able to take control of the
board, able to wipe out all the units on
Bagel's side. And now Bagel's going to
need to reestablish.
>> Yeah. And you know, Annie, I think, is a
bit of a, you know, aggressive leaning
tempo deck at times. uh and you you're
able to be greedy because you're trying
to, you know, be defensive with the
extra two runes you get, right? But uh
when your opponent's really able to
clear board, it's hard for you to
reestablish. But looks like maybe paying
five could be a Darius of our own here.
>> See,
maybe another Kai'Sa.
>> Definitely could be. Yep. And it is
going to be another Kai'Sa. uh
accelerated it does appear which means
it could come up into either of these
battlefields, take a point and get a
draw if is able to be successful.
>> Yeah. And the inferna
>> could be the the choice here, but we're
just going to go into uh the Emperor's
Das here. Going to go to four points.
And that does offer us another drop.
>> Yep.
>> Let's see.
>> Still three runes up to play with now
that we have this extra card.
And you know, we could be uh attaching
the long sword if we want. You know, get
the extra two might on our Kai'Sa. Uh
but again, we we really don't have any
fury runes left.
>> So, we'd have to remove all of them
again. Using the two here, though, uh
another tie turner would be
okay. Again, like it again, it's a
little bit tougher for you to interact
with the Kai'Sa.
>> Mhm. Tieer would be nice, but Nexus
>> Nox's hopeful will be able to be played
for two runes, which is always nice to
be a cheaper Noxis hopeful. And that
will put us back to three runes as we
pass the Sam D Sherman, who is able to
hold for one point. And honestly,
holding is just such is so strong in
this game. A lot of times when you're
committing to a battlefield to take it,
you're kind of accepting that that unit
is going to die. So, not only are you
getting a second point by holding, but
you're also getting that same unit back.
>> Also, this is probably the first time
I've seen an Inferno hold a uh
battlefield. Just that one might is
enough there. Uh we do get to play out a
unit there. So, we're going five to four
and we'll see what uh uh is going to do
about it.
>> Yeah, I mean, he obviously has some
options here. He's got that those three
runes up. Uh he's got I mean a couple of
different spells in his deck and it
looks like we're spinning.
>> Yeah, for the for the Rangar, right?
We've got some ambush of our own, right?
So, uh it does offer some more might on
this battlefield here. Um
>> challenge.
>> We're just going to use challenge
though. Super strong. So, challenge on
the uh the Rengar there.
>> Yeah, that second card.
>> That'll be interesting. Taking out the
Rengar again.
It's kind of audacious, you know, to try
to use a Rengar versus Rengar,
>> but
>> yeah, it's uh it's look working out kind
of that way, too. So, uh being able to
use the uh challenge ability, we are
going to actually use the uh battlefield
ability, too. So, we do get out a token
>> by returning that to hand.
>> Uh we do play out another uh unit and
then we get to draw another off the
initiative. This is some really really
good synergy I'm seeing from Sam's side.
>> Yeah, Sam's deck seems to flow so well
here. Uh I'm really liking his take on
Rengar.
>> Yeah, so currently uh we're at six
points, we're moving everything back. So
hoping to do a double conquer for game
next turn. And with cards in Bagel's
hand, we might be uh going to game two
pretty quickly.
>> Yeah, that is true. I mean, he still has
that Noxis hopeful that he could play,
but it does, as you said, look like we
are going to see that scoop and we are
going to game two.
>> Yeah. So, uh I think it's understood,
right? We're pretty far behind. Uh you
know, time is of value in this game,
too. So, we've got a whole 44 minutes to
try to win two games and uh looks like
we uh you know, since I think this is a
little bit pre-recorded, we are able to
jump right into the next ones. So, we've
got Arena's greatest for for Bagel. Once
again, this is looking pretty similar to
Pike, right? Uh, I don't know what it is
with Fury and Chaos, but they they have
a hard time choosing other battlefields,
it seems.
>> Yeah. Well, Annie always has liked,
especially these two battlefields, Zon
Warren and Arena's greatest. I think
we've been seeing her play these
probably since set one.
>> Uh, she definitely liked in set one and
set two, the Arena's greatest able to be
pretty aggressive. Uh, it shortens the
game length, so hopefully that you can
get moving a little bit faster and kind
of move underneath your opponent's deck.
But we'll have to see how that does
versus this Rengar.
>> Yeah. And then the uh battlefield from
Sam is the Star Spring. Probably one of
my favorite battlefields from Unleashed
here. Uh just has a lot of interactions
for whenever you play a unit, you can
move one of your units back to your
base. Uh when you're playing a deck that
has a lot of hidden cards, too. And when
you're already so uh you know, you get
so many benefits from playing units
already. Uh having a battlefield that
you know, synergizes with that is really
nice.
>> That makes a lot of sense. Yeah, I think
it is a really interesting card. It
almost kind of gives like some level of
like pseudo ganking sometimes.
>> Uh because especially if like the unit's
already ready, it moves it back to the
base and then you could still decide to
do something with it because it
maintains that ready state.
>> Yeah. So, uh we've got the tide coming
in and we've got that for two and
passing it back for Sam. Once again,
we're both at one point a piece thanks
to the arena greatest. Uh and we've got
oh, two units. Uh, and you know,
bypassing the Rengar effect, it doesn't
really matter at this spot, but already
back to Bagel at four runes.
>> Yeah, I mean, I'm sure Sam really likes
being able to play both those units
here. I mean, like being able to play
one already feels nice on your first
turn, but playing two.
>> Yeah, it's it's great. So, uh, and off,
you know, obviously being able to uh,
interact with that. The sentry also, you
know, it's it's just a little unit, but
when it offers like a plus one might for
one uh in situations, that can be good.
We've got the sneaky deck hand being
sneaky playing into the spring going to
three points for Bagel here.
>> I mean, Bagel's definitely going to be
happy to do that. Being able to go on
and get that unit out and into a
battlefield. Now, next turn, Sam can't
take it uncontested for one, but also
just starting to get ahead on those
points because Arena's greatest. We're
already up to three points now. We're
off to the races and Sam is still at one
and he's got to actually fight to take
these battlefields.
>> Yeah. Yeah, we do have I believe assault
two. So, we can pressure one of these.
Uh which looks like we're going to do
immediately. It's going to be three to
two here.
>> And thinking here I think I I see a hint
of a gust which could uh potentially put
this back in hand. But it looks like
we're gonna maybe play the full three.
>> Starross.
>> The star crossed here. So going to be
able to move uh both the deckhand and
inferna back to hand if we get to do so.
>> Yeah, that's going to be really nice if
this dark cross can go off. I mean
getting sneaky deck hands back into hand
kind of means that in some world Sam
might feel pressure to take this dark uh
the star spring just because if he
leaves it open that sneaky deck hand
could be replayed next turn to take that
point. Uh, and as you can see, up comes
that sentry to take Starring.
>> Yeah. So, uh, being able to have the
Kai'Sa, I think, was a a bit of a good
punish for the Star Cross, right? Um,
but, uh, you know, we are at both
battlefields, so we can't be sneaky
about it either. Uh, but yeah, I think I
think this is a good spot, but again, we
did have to use all of our runes for it.
And if there's a Kai'Sa on the other
side, that could be uh, pretty good for
Bagel here. Yeah, this we interested to
see what Bagel does. Obviously, there's
a couple different options to try to
take these battlefields back. It looks
like we are going to be playing all five
of our runes here and recycling one.
That is going to be an accelerated
Kai'Sa uh coming into Starring as well.
>> Yeah, the determined sentry can't move
to base, but it can move to the trash
there. And we got another point for Bego
Martini back up to four. And also that
additional draw is going to be very
nice. still gonna be able to use the two
defensively. And uh and there it is.
>> I will.
>> Yeah. Let's see what they decide to do.
We're getting I mean pretty close to
some of these important numbers for
Annie. Six points is definitely a
dangerous spot to be in when you're
facing Annie. So, uh
>> probably watching those points right
now. It does look like we're going be
playing a hidden card to that Star
Spring.
>> Yeah. And we've seen it in the deck
already, right? Uh, but being able to
play the tide turner, uh, that can work
really, really nice with the Star
Spring. Uh, we can play unit, we can
move the Kai'Sa back, keep it safe.
We've got two runes open for, uh, some
other interactions, too. So, you know,
in a game where you can just keep Kaiser
around, he's keep conquering, drawing
one card per turn. Super nice.
>> But going to four for Sam as we start
with six runes on the board.
>> Yeah, let's see. I mean, that's I mean,
good number of runes. Obviously, we only
have to deal with those two from Annie.
Annie is down to three runes though, so
next turn only back to five. Looks like
we are going to actually be playing that
Rengar though straight into Starring.
>> I love being able to do that. Just like
scoop it all the way over there. Uh we
are going to show the tide turner here.
Uh and so currently it's going to be
seven might to six. And let's see if we
have any interactions. It looks like
we're just going to use the flash to
move both of them back. So keep them
safe and potentially get some
interaction next turn. So that's going
to be five points for Sam. Uh you're
pretty far ahead now.
>> Yeah, I mean the defensive flash we are
still giving Sam that point. However,
the thing is is both those units are
still alive. They can still be used the
following turn. Uh and we can then use
that five runes for something else.
>> Yeah. So we're likely going to try to
keep our Kaiso safe. Uh which I think is
strong. Does offer the opportunity to
conquer again uh next turn and draw a
card. Uh, Rengar being at the six might
is strong. It's going to be tough for
uh, Bagel to be able to immediately
interact with it, but if we give them
like a free Kai'Sa, uh, that could be
great, too. Oh, thinking about the
sentry.
Not sure on it.
>> Yeah, and if we do play something else
to this Starring, we will finally get to
be able to use that battlefield ability
that we haven't really uh, seen too much
this game. um which would mean we could
potentially protect the Rengar, but it
does not look like that is going to be
what we choose to do instead of just
bringing Kais safely back home.
>> Yeah. And again, like the sentry uh in a
lot of decks, it's it's a little bit of
a weird card, but in this one when it
says play me for one, give something
plus one might. It's it's it's very
strong. So, you know, there is like a
mentality of using all of my runes as I
can or sometimes that plus one might
might be better for even trading my
Kai'Sa above their Kai'Sa next turn.
though. Uh, but looks like we're
starting with five for Bagel over here.
We've got a pretty good board. Kai'Sa
being able to conquer for free
essentially on the other side is really
nice. Uh, but that Ranggar on the
Starring is a little bit of an issue.
>> Ooh, and the sneaky deck hands straight
up into that arena's greatest. So, he
still will have that Kai'Sa and Tide
Turner to potentially deal with the
Rengar on the bottom. But, it is so nice
to be able to play that card straight
from hand into a battlefield, get that
next point, and we are at five points
now. Yeah, and looking at hand, uh, from
what I can see, three cards. Uh, looks
like we are going to play out the
>> the stack deck. If we get a cleave,
which I believe they're playing, uh,
that could be really good. It could make
our Kai'Sa go to seven uh, to get rid of
their Rengar, but without it, it's a
little bit tricky.
>> Yeah, if we do have that cleave,
obviously be make that Kai'Sa just
slightly bigger than Rengar. We'd get
that draw, and taking that big unit off
the board against Sam could kind of put
Sam in a bad position as well. Yeah. So
adds one,
>> put the back the rest in the bottom. We
got one rune open for Bagel here
>> and we'll see what their choice is. But
yeah, this this Rengar is really tough
for us to interact with.
>> Yeah,
stack deck. So nice though, able to get
like try to figure out what our hand can
look like. Even if it's not a cleave or
something like that, we can still set
our hand up for that following turn.
We'll have three energy when it comes to
defending. We do need to defend the
sticky deck hands. Uh so no matter what,
still really nice to try to curate this
hand to make it into what we want for
these following turns.
>> Yeah, it looks like we're just going to
do the the full trade potentially.
>> Yeah, it's going to be six to six. So
>> you get rid of it, but it's a bit
expensive and we're going to pass with
just a sneaky deck hand on the arena's
greatest.
>> Yeah, kind of costly for sure. But I
have to think like as we're coming up
into these like later turns, we're
potentially threatening six, seven
points on Sam's side here. Maybe it's
nice to get that Rengar off because
especially with Starring, he's not stuck
in Starring. He could potentially use
Starring to move back to the base and
then take out the CE hands as well.
>> All right, Sam goes to the arena's
greatest and uh you know, a little
hesitant, but you know, happy to see
that it was just a a trade there. We're
going to move the uh the sentry there
into the Starring.
And for one, we're just going to gust it
back to hand.
>> Mhm.
>> Looks like we may have something we want
to do though with our runes here.
We do have seven up, so we have some
different options for sure. Yeah, I mean
if it's going to be tough to
>> play for three, but oh, we can play the
inferna as a reaction here
>> and give it itself the plus one. So
>> we do go to seven points now.
>> Definitely a really nice use of I
believe it's the ambush cards being able
to use as reactions being able to kind
of circumvent what that Gust wanted to
do. Yeah, in general, I think one of the
themes from Unleashed is there's just so
many opportunities to play units at
times that you wouldn't expect it,
right? And Rengar, I think, just really
encapsulated. You get the additional
benefit of that plus one might. It comes
up so often. And uh we're kind of at
game point here for Sam. We're not going
to be able to win this turn in
particular, but uh now we're just
thinking what's the best way to set up
our battlefields to be able to to do
well. Looks like we're just going to
play out uh these irresistibles uh the
sentry that we just added back to hand.
And if either of these battlefields get
held, uh, Sam's going to win this one.
>> Yeah, Bagel is in a bit of a pickle
here. Uh, different food, but he's still
having some difficulty. Um, because
yeah, as you said, if either of these
are held, then Sam will win when it gets
passed back to him. So, we need to take
out both the Kai'Sa and the Inferna
here. And
>> yeah, it doesn't does not seem possible,
unfortunately. So, uh, looks like maybe
Falling Star could have gotten rid of
one of them, but uh, Sam takes that in a
in a quick 20, uh, with, uh, with that.
Yeah.
>> Yeah. Fantastic job, I feel like, by
both these players.
>> Yeah. But and, you know, really
fortunate we were able to watch both of
those matches, right? I was when we were
asked I wanted to see a Rengar game,
especially like a Rengar without Aurora.
I think it's cool to show all the
interaction of, you know, the benefits
from uh, you know, the legend ability to
get that plus one might. And, you know,
Sam's starting the day 2. Yeah, I'm feel
he's I'm sure he's feeling super
confident here with that 20. He did such
a fantastic job and obviously he I mean
he is a fantastic Riftbound player.
Really great job to see him be able to
take Rengar and do so well with it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So hoping uh they have a
good rest of the day, right? Uh to get
to day two, we do need a record of six
and two or better. So uh we've got four
more wins needed to get there, but uh
Sam pretty confident with their plays,
too. Yeah, I would definitely say so. I
mean, he seemed super confident. He knew
his deck and a 20 start is I mean, it's
doing really well to get to that 62.
>> Yeah, I'd be I'd be a little confident.
We'll see. We'll see how round three
goes for it. But, uh, you know,
especially with a deck that, you know,
uh, people are less experienced with,
right?
>> Mhm.
>> You get a lot of these interactions. I
think Rengar in particular, when you
have all these unique timings, a lot of
these unique react windows, that does
mean you can catch a lot of opponents
offguard if they haven't played against
Rengar before. Yeah, I think that's
something that we're seeing a lot in the
unleashed meta is all these different
like reaction windows that players are
really able to capitalize off of. And
you can see just how strong that was,
especially for Sam just in that last
turn being able to react to that gust to
able to still maintain their spot on the
Starring.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And if you're just joining
us, we also did see a game from uh
Allen's EQ is Diana versus Pike. uh
another 2 on that one and just kind of
had a lot of the same momentum, right?
Where uh we we've seen like, you know,
Fury and Chaos be, you know,
historically a really good uh
combination of domains uh and but they
they've been a little bit, you know,
held back by all these new kind of
reactions and windows coming up.
>> Yeah, it seems like they're having a
little bit more trouble this time. That
being said, both uh Sandy Sherman and
Allen ZQ fantastic players. They
definitely know how to play to the
highest level. So, it's interesting to
see like both interactions, but also
kind of what can Red Purple still do.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And and one of my favorite
things is to watch people who are just
confident. Uh, you know, there's it's a
it's a m minor thing, but uh when
they're confident with the cards they're
playing, they've said, "I've seen the
scenario, you know, a dozen times. I
know this is the play that makes the
most sense for it." Uh, you know, that
also just helps you when you've got
eight rounds in one day. uh you know,
you need to make sure that some of these
plays are automatic because you're going
to have a lot of decision-making and you
want to kind of mitigate the least
amount of that, you know, automatically.
>> Yeah. I think that's like something
people don't really think about as much
when they're talking about like the card
game tournaments. Like you get to round
six, you get to round seven, your brain
is so tired. And so being able to
decrease what you need to do early in
the day so that some of those later
games when you really need to think is
going be really nice.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So obviously even just
having like one less game to go into
right a 2 just means I have another 30
minutes to be like all right just reset
take a take a breather uh remember what
my plays are cuz you know there is also
the other side where your plays are a
little bit too automatic when if you
took a second back to think oh actually
this is a reaction that they can play or
this is something I got to play around
uh that can be a big difference too
>> yeah that is true and they also have
obviously time to take a drink find some
food uh so I feel like they're
definitely happy to have finished so
quickly with these like two O's and
especially after the last meta or set
where the rounds are going a bit longer.
I'm sure they're very happy here.
>> Yeah. I mean, also we're in Vancouver.
It's a beautiful day outside. Even just
taking a 10-minute like gaze into the
sea, you know what I mean? Just like
look at that. Feel the feel the ocean
breeze, right? I could definitely, you
know, consider just a little break from
there. It's It's so nice out here today.
>> Yeah, it really is. We're right beside
almost like the like a cruise ship area.
There's beautiful mountains in the
background. like a 10-minute break to go
breathe some fresh air.
>> I think Vancouver is absolutely
gorgeous.
>> Yeah, it's it's really really beautiful
here. So, uh again, we do have eight
rounds today. This is going to be the
end of round two. Not sure if we're
going to have another quick interview or
overview on that. But, uh we did see
this round specifically, we had uh Diana
versus Pike where Diana was able to take
it. And we did also just see an Annie
versus the Rengar where Rengar was able
to take it. Yeah, it was I mean it was
so awesome getting to see these like new
unleashed uh legends. The I mean
obviously Rengar, the Diana, the Pike,
all of these very new, very fresh.
Really exciting to see kind of how these
interactions are playing out. Again,
obviously Pike didn't win, but I loved
seeing it being able to use that legend
ability to pick the units up, be it to
kind of reset it to base and save it, be
able to like reuse abilities like the
Fizz. Uh, you know, it's going to be so
interesting to see how this meta
continues to build out.
>> Yeah. And I think something that gets
overlooked sometimes is this like, you
know, someone could be look, you know,
look like they're on the back foot for a
lot of the game, but uh, it's usually
because their opponent knows what their
interaction they really want to do,
right? And so being able to prevent them
from doing it or preventing them from
having enough runes open to get their
good play because they have to, you
know, they they feel forced to recycle
them for some ability cost. Uh, you
know, that's that's like the big
difference. So I think you know both
Allen EQ and Sam both players who are
wellversed in this game in this meta and
they can understand this is what they
want to do and I'm going to try really
really hard to make it difficult for
them to you know fire that away. Yeah,
100%. And I have to wonder like both of
them game two having to deal with like
Arena's greatest. Do you feel more
pressure going into it? Maybe these
decks they feel still confident within
cuz obviously it seemed like it seemed
like Rengar was very happy. He hit two
units going second uh on that turn one
was obviously sneaky deck hands was
still a bit of like a took both the
battlefields, but
>> it seemed like both players were happy
going into arena's greatest where that
would be a pressure point in some of
these earlier
>> sets. I think you're right. I think
Diana again having uh the champion unit
that you just get a free turn one play
essentially which is really really nice.
Uh and then generally speaking in this
game it's very unusual for you to be
able to make two units on turn two on
the other side right maybe like a victor
and a two cost right that can be
historically but uh the sentry there I
think is a is a cool tech that ends up
working really good with Rengar. You
mentioned the interaction with the
legend ability is really good and then
just being having ways to like you know
pressure two battlefields where most
other decks it would have been like a
free you know two or three points for
the Annie player.
>> Yeah 100%. I was actually talking to one
of Allen's Q's like testing partners
Randy and he was saying that honestly he
thinks this set going second is not as
big of a deal as it might have been the
earlier sets. And again maybe that's
just what we're seeing here for both of
these top players.
>> Yeah and uh I I think that's right.
That's been a big shift I've noticed as
well. And I think we're going to have an
analysis for our first match. So, let's
send it away that way.
>> Masterful game from Allen. And what
we're going to do here is we're going to
actually take a look at some of the key
moments that revolve around first of all
a little bit of good luck from Raven
Conservatory, but also we're going to
take a look at what happened where
unfortunately Axis was trying to catch
up from behind and just couldn't close
out the game. So in this first clip
here, what we have here is we do have
Allan. He is on the Diana, of course,
and on Raven Bloom Conservatory here.
When it's defending, you're able to
actually check the top card of your
deck, and if it's a spell, add it to
your hand. Well, why don't we just play
the clip here? What could possibly come
from this top deck here? Okay, so we
have the uh so we have the uh the
movement in word here. We're going to
have the uh the sword come in as well.
And then what's going to happen is once
the defense trigger is generated, we're
going to go to the deck
and we're going to try to bowl. Okay.
Yeah, there's the uh the trigger there
for the uh the treasure. And of course
with the Raven Blue Conservatory, I'll
move out of the way here and you're
going to see it's of course it's a Gust.
And I wonder what card Allen's looking
for right in this moment. Well, would
you believe it? It just might be a Gust.
And so Allen is going to play this Gust.
And of course, this is going to be a
massive tempo swing in Allen's favor.
And it this kind of is a good theme for
the entire match because what was
happening here was Access was
continuously trying to maintain a board
state. And if we go to the next clip
here, we're going to see a great example
of how that's going to work here. And so
ultimately on this next clip, we have uh
a situation where Axis has Falling Star
in hand and Axis is going to try to do
the best that they can to try to
mitigate one of the carry cards in
Allen's deck, which is Huay. So, Hu here
and Falling Star. I mean, often you use
it to try to mitigate some uh some three
three might cars that might be causing
you a bit of a problem, but in this
circumstance here, if we roll the clip,
what we're going to see is that Allen is
going to have his way wiped out
utilizing that falling star. Now,
falling star is a heavy price. You're
going to be using two power and you're
going to be dramping. And we're going to
see in our next clip here where Axis
once again is in a situation where well,
you got to use Falling Star. So, if we
roll it here, we're going to see Fizz,
that falling star, come back. And again,
what we're going to do here is a little
bit of a different strategy, though.
Huay still on the board. Allen did bring
it back. You could commit the procs to
Hui, but instead chooses to try to thin
out the board to try to survive as Allen
is threatening to close out the game on
the next turn. Now, finally on our next
clip, we're going to see once again,
Axis trying to fight from behind. The
board presence of Allen was significant
the entire time and we are going to see
if we can roll the clip here from that
final clip.
We're going to see starcross being
played. Uh starcross is fantastic here.
It helps to really uh obviously it's
disproportionately beneficial for Axis.
Uh but ultimately it just wasn't enough.
It was a good tempo swing. It almost
brought the game back, but at the end of
the day, when Allen's constantly
controlling the board, you're dramping
constantly is just enough to maintain an
advantage. And Allen did ultimately
close out the games in two. Let's bring
it back to the desk.
>> All right, thank you very much, Alex,
for that analysis. And yeah, just that
first play, right, being able to get
Gust off the top right when we had a
chance to use it. Really, really tough
to come back from that.
>> Yeah, I feel like that Gust was just
like so well timed. It was so nice of a
top deck that as well as I don't know Al
such a great job at like pointing out
the choices that uh Allen's EQ made
deciding how that the the who would get
the damage uh knocking out Hui when it
was needed and then also kind of just
leaving Hui alone when it was time to
take out the other units.
>> Yeah, and I think Diana is a deck that
again is a a deck of decisions and I
won't be the master of them, but I think
Allen's EQ would have some opinions. And
let's throw uh our interview over to
him.
>> An excellent cast to a very prolific
player who I am now privileged to sit
next to or stand next to I should say.
Allen EQ representing Diana once again
still the chaos and mind afficionado.
Allan, a pretty dare I say uh quick work
round two for you. And I just got to ask
you, you know, how are you feeling just
coming into the tournament today? I'm
sure the people at home, they really
wanted to watch you. So, we picked you
for your first feature match for today
so far. Very early. I try to keep away
from you guys pretty early on. But how
are you feeling coming in today? Just
overall
>> amazing. Uh main difference is coming
here now. I had a 5 hours sleep actually
one night across a whole week like in
the Australia. So that's a nice uh
change definitely. So feeling well
rested, feeling well better prepared on
the deck because just more much more
time to prepare before the Sydney much
more event Sydney and yeah very happy
with the deck. There's like two versions
that I believe are very good of the
Diana. And literally I was flipping the
coin at 6:00 a.m. and I flipped to
change it like 10 cards uh back and
forth and I end up with different
version when uh I was playing mostly in
the testing, but I believe it's like the
two best versions of it.
>> Well, so then let's kind of dive into
that specifically because I think a lot
of people are used to your last version.
Obviously, you top it in Sydney. You
were on the list of course. um didn't
get the best of, but still took home a
top eight representation with Diana,
this new legend. So, tell me about this
swap to this new deck specifically. I
mean, I had the pleasure of playing
against you in Sydney, but uh I really
liked the Kha'Zix like as an ambush
unit. You know, you still get to use
Diana in showdown, so like why not focus
a little bit more towards the ambush
mechanic instead of having more spell
oriented. So, why specifically the
changes to all these cards?
>> Uh Kha'Zix was a one event tweak when
people were not prepared. It was just a
surprise factor I wanted to have in uh
it's a good one but the problem is when
you have mana open it's very foreseen
and it's good spec in very small case
scenarios and it doesn't have the bet
matchups and I'd rather have teched the
deck one version of them was the dual
version with the consult the past uh
where you use utilize the consult the
pass as a defensive layer two trigger
jewel to have a plus two plus four with
the two jewels and even like student or
abandon hall so you can grow your limit
where it's like even if opponent can
walk over it, it taxes them heavily on
their own turn and then it just
snowballs from there and that's like the
main version we're testing and like a
lot of people that brought this like
Sean Kasa and a lot of people from the
our discord are playing this version so
look out for that and I'm playing the
gear type of the version of the deck
with the main deck uh acceptable losses
uh last yeah a bit more spell heavy uh
that's why I can uh reason enough for
the conservatory game
And because of the field, I I was
looking at the stats. I'm like into 70%
of the field, it's pretty good. And into
others, it's just a pitchfork way for
the extra draw. So, and I run the two
extra merchants just to make sure I can
keep the deck fluid. Uh, so those are
the two versions that I believe are the
best now. Like the Kazix was nice, but
again, it was just used for the surprise
factor. I never consider it like to be a
staple. Uh, unless it's very like key
heavy meta. It's the only matchup that I
really would like to have like one or
two, but outside of the that that I'd
rather have either dual version of the
one or the one that I am currently
running.
>> Yeah, that's kind of like I think what
we talked about where like the surprise
factor makes a lot of sense because
typically it was like hey are you
playing around Moonfall? Are you playing
around this Kha'Zix? And you're like you
can't ever play around both, right? So
it meanwhile I think things like you the
jewel or like flash for example kind of
still get that job done of like hey
they're playing around one thing but
they're not playing around this other
one and you still get all the advantages
of course like flash synergizing with
the way getting the extra movement of
course so it makes a lot of sense. Um
you mentioned obviously some other names
that are playing Diana and it's no
surprise because she's pretty popular
probably due to you and the other
representation in top eight in Sydney.
Um are you necessarily dare I say afraid
of anyone else playing this deck right
now? Obviously, you're a very good
player, but people are looking at your
lists and very much honing in on wanting
to try and play those similar play
styles. Do you think maybe you have a
lot of competition you have to worry
about?
>> I mean, if I was worried, I wouldn't be
giving the list and the tips and the
sideboard how to play the deck. Uh, I
would be hiding it and just never
sharing. And I fry for the competition
to be at its peak. Uh, just to make it
harder because like you don't forge into
the weak environment. You get better
only if the environment is better and
forces you to get better. So, I'm much
for the better and the tougher comp
competition if it mean even if it means
that I'm not going to make it.
>> I that makes a ton of sense to me and I
think no one else in this room what's
the best environment for the tournament
except for you Allan. So,
congratulations on your round two win. I
look forward to seeing you more so in
the tournament of course. But thank you
so much. We're going to send it back.
>> All right. Well, thank you guys. And I'd
be shocked if that's the last we see of
Allen's EQ not only today but this
weekend. So, that will be the case. But
honestly, I think we're we're kind of
wrapping up uh our second round here.
>> Yeah, it was so awesome getting to see,
you know, Allen's point of view on his
deck and talking about it. But, man,
that was a fantastic round.
>> Yeah, for sure. So, we're going to go
into our break. We've got round three
ahead of us. We've got again eight
rounds for us total today. So, you know,
here in beautiful Vancouver, Canada,
having a good time and we'll see you
guys in round number three.
one of many stops here in the Vancouver
Regional Qualifier is the merch store,
which is usually always popping as soon
as the doors open. So, of course, they
always want to come and pick up their
premium benefits. And one of the
benefits, of course, for this one is the
Jin Virtuoso playmat featuring that nice
overnumbered art. But for everyone else
that doesn't have a premium badge, you
can of course still pick up mini
plushies, statues, and any like mini
figures. Some of the new ones here
actually featuring KDA, some of my
favorite champions from League of
Legends of course, but there's even fun
little hats, things that like Rengar
wears and the plushy kitty things. So,
so much more that you can pick up here
at the Vancouver regional qualifier. So,
make sure you check out the merch store
at the regional qualifier that you
attend.
Let's get into top eight Diana from
Allen's EQ in Sydney. First off, she is
Diana's Score in the Moon with the
chosen legend ability of whenever you're
in a showdown, you can add one energy to
your pool that you can use in a
showdown. Her chosen champion, Diana
Lunari, she has the ability to pay one
to predict and then draw it if it is a
spell. Let's go ahead and take a look at
the key cards in the deck. The first one
being Weii. Weeyi is really important
because he acts as the whole engine of
this deck. And the big part of him is he
allows you to draw, discard, and
navigate through your deck while also
getting value from it. For example, when
you discard a champion or a or a unit,
you're able to get three might. You
discard a spell, you're able to draw.
And if you discard a uh a gear, then you
are able to ready two rooms. This makes
his versatility really important for the
deck. And really the deck has a hard
time operating without him. And because
of this movement, you also play a lot of
movement based cards. For example, we
have tide turner which acts as a two
drop and also the fact that you're able
to use it in the late game to move way
to safety or to filter through your deck
more. We also have flash which also
allows you to move way to safety and
filter through your deck more as well.
And this is a really key card as it has
been throughout the meta especially when
you're taking first. then you're able to
usually establish yourself onto a
battlefield and then come back from it.
And that makes this a great card for the
deck. The next one is Moonfall. And with
Moonfall, we I love Moonfall first off.
I could talk about this card all day,
but it allows you to win most of your
fights because you target a battlefield
to give minus two might to everything
and not just the unit that you target,
which makes this really important. It is
also that movement base that we've
talked about earlier where you're able
to move a card from a battlefield to
this other battlefield where you have
units and this can turn fights so
quickly. It is such an extremely strong
card in Diana and really allows her to
do everything she does along with that
way that we talked about earlier. And
because we have way, we also have other
units that um can accelerate in this
case, such as the thousand tail watcher,
which is a unique pick for this deck.
But we also have Vex apathetic more
importantly. This has been one of the
key cards in the game overall as it is
kind of turned everything on its head.
And what it does is it has deflect but
also stuns every unit that enters play.
On top of that, it also allows it not to
move in that accelerate. So, it's really
good against certain strategies and
decks. And we'll go ahead and take a
look overall at um the next deck which
is the best of Diana from Sydney which
comes from Nice Boy. And a big lot of
key differences in this list. A big
thing is the number of gust in this is a
three of which allows the Diana to get a
lot of tempo which is critical at points
but it is less valuable. However, this
was made up from the fact that we have
Mindsplitter in the deck, a little bit
taller than what we saw in Allen's
version of the deck. And this is really
good against Aurora or anything that has
those critical parts that you want to be
able to discard before your opponent has
the ability to play it. And with that,
we also have the Frigid Jewel in this
list, which is highly criticized right
now of whether is this card actually
good or not. And the reason being is it
has a small amount of things that it
actually works with. It works with Wei,
it works with Diana, and it also works
with stupify. However, if you don't have
those cards, then this kind of becomes a
little bit dead at times. With the
exception with Weey, you can discard it
and ready two runes. So, it does give
the ability to ready two runes a little
bit more flexibility. You might be able
to do an extra play that you weren't be
able to do before and throw your
opponent off guard on top of that. I
also want to highlight that there's
smoke screen in here, which wasn't a
very common card that was played in
Diana. However, it did perform very well
in the last tournament. Obviously, we
have the the best of Diana here in this
list and being able to break holds with
this was extremely important for the
list. And Eclipse kind of operates
similar to that, but I like the smoke
screen tech quite a bit. And that's all
I have for you. Thank you so much.
Round two was an absolutely splendor to
behold. It was a lot of fun to watch and
I mean I think we got lucky. We got to
see Allan right off the rip here in
Vancouver in round two and uh he did 2
and 0 and it goes to showcase just how
powerful Diane is.
>> Well, an interesting thing about that is
in Sydney, Pike was actually highly
favored against Diana as well. So, we
get to see that expert piloting with
those big deck changes from Allen to be
able to take that down pretty quickly.
>> Yeah. And the thing about Pike as well
is like you have this aggressive play
style where you're trying to stay on
board. you're trying to utilize the
balance mechanics. But but but Diane has
so many answers, right? And I think we
found that there and and one of the
answers that we saw was the use of Gust.
Now, I want to take a second to talk
about Gust because Gust, its friend
Fighter Flight is no longer with us, but
we still have Gus. And Gust, I think, is
a core component of the chaos domain.
So, why do you think we see so much Gust
out here?
>> Well, the big thing is it has such high
tempo being able to completely
essentially remove a unit from a
battlefield at three might. And we have
a lot of things that our variety of
three might. On top of that, we do see a
lot of Leblanc in the meta. And because
of that, um, Leblanc wants to get onto
the battlefield so early, being able to
say Gust and just slow it down so much.
So Gust's tempo is just hard to match.
We really can't match Gust.
>> And when you have something like a
Leblanc fragmented, that's a good target
to Gust.
>> Oh yeah. anything that's high cost or
high tempo and just being able to take
that tempo right back, especially if you
even are able to hit something like a
Raven Bloom student who usually can
potentially get up to that four might
and say no actually you can't do that.
But when you are keeping it to that two
might you know just being able to reset
the board state slow everything down
just a critical card overall. Now,
similar to Gust is starcrossed and we
did see Starcross in Allen's game. It
unfortunately access was not able to
maintain the board state because
ultimately at the end of the day, Hui
was able to generate a lot of value. So,
with Starcross, why do you feel like
that is such a key component to the uh
chaos strategy?
>> Well, quite possibly starcross could be
considered one of the best cards in
Unleash that has been released. And the
big thing is once again it's that high
tempmpo gameplay that we were really
looking at. Being able to remove
something very cheap and efficient and
then being able to take care of anything
tall with the star cross is really nice.
It only costs one power so it's not the
worst thing in the world there either.
Um that's just it just gives you so much
tempo. A big reason of why we've seen
less forerunner in the meta is because
of the starcross is being able to say
like oh you played this six cost unit.
Let me just put that back in your hand
here real quick. It just makes the game
be a lot more efficient overall.
>> All right, guys. I got great news for
you. We're ready to vote for the next
match up here going into round three.
So, get ready to submit your votes. And
oh my gosh, it is the battle of the meta
here. We got some absolute bangers here.
We have Leblanc versus Kai'Sa. And then
your second option is going to be Darius
versus Aurelia. So the first thing is is
that we do have Randy down there who is
a play test partner with Allen
Imprismat. So would love to see that
Aurelia deck that's being cooked up.
Also Darius, there are multiple versions
of Darius right now. There is the hook
version which has been here since set
one. But the Darius aggro deck that's
been, you know, making waves on Twitter
has absolutely been part of, you know, a
lot of players have said like, "Oh, this
deck is really quick and it can just get
under some of these more mid-rangey
style decks." And then up top, of
course, LeBlanc making waves as well.
We've seen two variants of her, the
temple Leblanc as well as the hook
Leblanc with the hook Leblanc being a
little bit more favored, especially
after top eighting in Sydney.
>> Well guys, I got some great news. The
results are in and we're going to watch
Aurelia and Darius Ry's taking the stage
here. And I mean, the Riftbound
community, we know Randy, we know his
talent capabilities here. And we're
going to see it on full display with
Aurelia. Now, I'm going to say with
Darius, I Okay, listen. We've talked a
lot about Fury and it having some
challenges, but look at this deck list
with Darius here. Um, what really stands
out to you here? Because for me, I think
it's Pike. Like, I think that Pike and
Rexai, these are great cards being uh
splashed into this deck.
>> Oh, yeah. There's a lot of options here.
Something that I actually want to
highlight is once again is the gear hate
or even just cardate in general with the
Ash on the main board. We've been seeing
a lot more main deck gear and being able
to react with um with cards a lot better
and being able to say, you know what,
you wanted that card in your hand. Nope,
you don't get it anymore. So, that's a
really big thing is having this Ash here
to disrupt your opponent's deck.
>> And you did mention Furious Forerunner.
Furious forrunner is here. Um so, we'll
have to see if it can uh obviously have
the full impact that it seeks to have.
Uh we do have a lot of you talked about
uh gear hate. We have some unit hate as
well. a single variation uh or version
of call the week in the main board here
to falling stars and falling stars was
actually a big part of the Allen game as
well as falling star did tend to
drastically damp access and I also want
to highlight here Inferna Inferna has
been one of the lights at the end of the
tunnel for Fury overall because it has
struggled so much inferna said like I'm
going to give you a consistent two drop
it has ambush it has assault and it's
been a card that's been performing
really Well, in Fury decks overall, like
I said, the bright light at the end of
the dark tunnel for it for sure.
>> And we would be remiss if we did not
mention that we do have the Noxis
Hopeful and a Darius. A fantastic
combination uh that can be used to not
only generate a large body state on the
board, but of course, Darius has the
tremendous capability of being
incredibly aggressive as whenever you
play that second card, it does come in
readied with that additional two might.
Let's go to the second deck list here.
This is going to be our Ireelia. Uh what
stands out to you here? Oh, there's that
affforementioned Gust as a one-off star
cross as expected. What else do you see?
>> Well, a big thing has been this whole
scuttle verse lonely porro. Really, you
can only fit one into the deck. And we
see these scuttles starting to take
advantage of, you know, the card draw
and then also seeing your opponent's
hand. So, personally, I like the scuttle
crab a bit more than the lonely porro.
And it's been a really big part of this
deck overall.
>> We do have two not so fast sitting to
protect the Aurelia. And uh I should
also mention one of the absolute best
signature abilities in the game, Defiant
Dance.
>> Yes. And then on top of that, something
once again more gear hate in this deck
with Disarming Rake. It's in the main
board of the deck. Once again, we are
seeing some of the best decks be uh
having the gear hate in it, including
Allen had multiple forms of gear hate,
and with them being testing partners, it
makes sense. We've seen it be very
popular in the Chinese meta as well. So,
it's unsurprising to see it be here,
too.
>> All right, we are ready to go to our
match here as we see Aurelia take on
Darius.
Just getting set up here. And I have to
tell you for me like is it advantage
Aurelia here? Like what are you
thinking?
>> Well, the issue with Ireelia is is that
or should I say the benefit is there
isn't really a true weakness of her. I
mean, being fast and going under her is
one of the ways or being a little bit
slower and going over as well. But
Aurelia just has a great way to shore up
pretty much every weakness in the deck.
So the Darius deck, I've actually played
this matchup of myself a couple times.
If Darius can be quick and get on board
quickly, it can beat Ireelia just by
going a little bit quicker than it
overall. However, we will see the
abandoned hall for Aurelia, which is an
extremely strong battlefield for Aurelia
to start with. Yeah, the abandoned hall
because Aurelia gets a double dip on
that effect and all of a sudden the
amount of power and the amount of might
that she represents so rapidly
increases. It is absolutely one of the
uh top tier game one battlefields for
Aurelia as we get started here and it
looks like turn one is going to be Randy
>> and a big thing is we are seeing that
seed of power once again. I've talked
about how much I love this battlefield,
but for these fast tempo decks that can
get on board nice and early, we are able
to take advantage of that battlefield.
Well, and with Darius's effect,
sometimes we can play two two drops
here, but we will be playing the undying
here.
>> All right. And uh the uh the guardian
angel is out of here.
>> Have a dice just to keep track of my own
>> as we go on to uh Randy here.
>> I just want to keep track of my lore.
>> Yes, the guardian angel being a key
piece of Aurelia as it does help protect
your units. And we will see stack deck
which is an interesting card because a
lot of Ireelia players have considered
cutting stack deck almost entirely or
going down to one or two copies saying I
have enough cards that I can find
through cell her but we will see the
stack deck for Mandy always a tough
decision because you have so many great
cards that you have access to in the
chaos and in the calm.
>> I love that you bring up stallic corn
herder because that card carries so much
weight in this domain. it ability to
draw cards rather rapidly throughout the
entire course of the game is notable.
And then when you combo it with that
stack deck, you're able to find the
answers that you're seeking throughout
the course of the game because Aurelia,
while obviously, of course, you're
really focusing on that chosen champion.
You need to protect the chosen champion
as well. And so, you have to have the
tricks available to get that done.
>> And of course, we see one of my favorite
cards, the scuttle, which is really
important as we draw the card. And it
gives so much access to hand information
as well.
>> Yeah, the scuttle crab. I mean, in card
games, information is everything, and
the scuttle crab not only just replaces
itself when played, but of course, it
gives you the uh the opportunity to
reveal not just the hand, but the hidden
cards on the field of play, which I
mean, if you're a Teimo enjoyer, that
looks pretty scary.
>> Yeah. So, for this turn for the Darius,
we're really going to need to see a very
high tempo play. Really being able to
get on the board nice and early. It does
often run accelerate units. So, looks
like we are taking a look at what the
battlefield does here. the abandoned
hall, we get plus one might for each
time that we play a spell with the unit
at the battlefield.
>> Okay, it looks like we're getting a uh
exhaust of four runes here.
>> Yeah, go for it.
>> Dino thinking about what they're going
to do.
>> Might even be going up to all of the
runes here. Yeah,
>> Ash.
>> And it's Ash. Let's see the hand.
>> Great time to check that out. We have
charm, defy, defy, guardian angel, and
defiant dance.
>> Okay,
>> so looking what to choose here because
we there's a low number of units. Uh
they'll want to protect the units as
much as possible, the scuttle and of
course the Ireelia in the future. Um,
this deck does run coal, so potentially
looking at the defy as a possible, but
defiant dance is almost always a good
choice as well.
>> That makes perfect sense to me. Yeah,
Defiant Dance, it represents such an
immense uh power spike when played on
Aurelia, of course, and uh and it's
basically it's just it's five might of a
of a gap there because of the uh the the
debuff that it provides to the opposing
unit. Here, we're going to go in. We're
going to score a point.
>> And it is important to note here that
the Defiant Dance isn't discarded. It's
actually essentially banished. So, if
there is a hold available for Randy,
then he will get that defiant dance
back.
>> Yeah, it's almost like a soft mind split
or something like that. It's like, well,
you can't use it right now, but if you
manage to hold, we'll give it back to
you.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, the Undying Legion being checked
out by Randy there. I don't see too much
of it, but it's actually a really cool
card because uh if you happen to play it
uh if well if it goes into the trash
with Legion, you can actually pull it
out from the trash, play it again for
three energy or three runes and one
power.
>> Yep. It's not a very common card that we
see, but it does give that extra value.
So, if you do have to grind out games a
little bit more, you have an option.
It's just not like, oh, I threw all my,
you know, Darius aggressive cards on the
board. I'm out of cards. Oh, no. You
have another option now. I actually love
the idea though of a player like, you
know, let's say you're playing some
Darius, you want to cook a little bit. I
like the idea of adding some cards that
perhaps players aren't seeing all that
often. I think that's an advantage
towards you if you're able to bring some
surprise factor to your plays. And uh I
think ultimately if you're if your
opponent's having a less of an
opportunity to anticipate what you're
doing, that's advantage you
>> and Scuttle Crab is going to go in and
uh capture the seat of power.
>> Yep. We do also use our Aurelia to, you
know, essentially move our Aurelia
through. So, we do lose one power here,
but we get to take two battlefields,
which is fantastic. And we do also want
to hold to get that defiant dance back.
>> It looks like that is exactly what may
happen.
>> And I'll pass my
>> turn has been passed. Dino is going to
drop.
>> Yes, this charm here was excellent being
able to take this Ash out. Nothing left
on the board. And really, this stereo
stack is so it's high tempo. It wants to
be on the board early. It wants to be
the one scoring the points early. And
with this, it sets it back behind quite
a bit. Aurelia looks like in a really
dominant position here.
>> All right, I'm gonna do this.
>> Now, what I'll say as well is like we're
in a meta where uh baited hook is very
popular, but not in this particular
variation of Darius. We're seeing it
more in Leblanc, which I think is kind
of fascinating.
>> Yeah, it's important to note that in
this deck list, we do have things like
cleave that can potentially add a lot of
might and get over. So with the Darius
option, there's a potential that we
could look at killing the Celia.
However, it does have Guardian Angel on
it, so it will just end up recalling
back to the base if that were to be the
case.
>> No pressure at this point. Game one, 53
minutes still on the clock. Take your
turn uh through no problem.
>> Yeah.
Yeah, it once again really tough spot
here because the Darius, especially
going second, you have the option of
playing two two drops because you have
the Darius legend,
>> but we missed that and had to play in
dying, which is a lower tempo play
overall.
>> All right,
>> that's fine. Okay, inferno ready.
>> Inferno. Oops.
>> We have the Noxium hopeful out there
ready to go. and ready to Darius.
>> Excuse me.
>> Drastically different cards here.
>> Come here.
>> And it's important to note that he is at
seven might right now because he was
ready from that second card played.
>> Sure. So I will hold here. Trigger.
>> There's the hold. And we're going to get
our Defant dance back.
>> Let me just put the dice.
>> Yep. Big hold here. Definant dance being
part really important as well. There we
go. Back to hand it goes. Scuttle doing
his job like the hero he is
>> and scuttle crab is a card that I think
that on first read people might have
downsold a little bit. It might have
been a card that when unleash was now
like this looks pretty good. It's a card
that replaced itself but it has become
an absolute meta staple and for good
reason. I think that with good
information you can do anything in this
game.
>> So a big thing to note here is the
Darius player is tapped out. So I really
is just going to be able to come in here
and there's a stack deck. We're gonna
end up playing something here to make
this Well, first we got the plus one
from abandoned hall. She was ready.
>> Yeah, I really was just going to get
>> abandoned. Then of course,
we don't quite know what's in his hand,
but even something as simple as a ride
the wind.
>> Uh well, not in this case, but ride the
wind does represent a threat to score
two points on any given turn with an
Aurelia. Here, they're going to be
holding the two battlefields. Scuttle
crab on one, really on the other.
Scuttle crab is going to come back.
>> G for two. And there is the guardian
angel.
>> This second guardian angel is actually
key here because we are be able to
protect Aurelia just a little bit more.
We knew the defiant dance and stuff is
still in hand. But the fact that Aurelia
is able to be at this battlefield and we
don't have to spend more power to use
Ireelia to move her back is so ideal
here. And on top of that, we don't have
much development from the Darius. Like I
said, just kind of ended up with a
slower tempo hand. And against Ireelia,
that makes things really tough.
>> Yeah. on this next turn for Randy. He's
going to want to go into that uh that
that critical six points. And for Dino,
they're going to want to actually set up
a board here and start to contest. Now,
they're going to hopefully try to find
some removal as well. Uh the potential,
we did see in the primary deck list. You
did have the one of call the weak. Uh
but in this circumstance, that's another
benefit to having that scuttle crab out
there because if you call the weak, I
mean, they're not going to choose
Ireelia. So, you have to do a little bit
of work here to perhaps clear the board
a little bit. It's one of the reasons
why you might care about something like
a falling star, right? It makes that
call the week a little more viable.
>> Yeah. On top of that, we do know about
those defies in hand, too. So, call the
week isn't going to be able to do that
all that much. And this scuttle is
actually representing a big amount of
well conquer and also draw potentially.
So, the fact that we might be able to
get just a few more resources here,
especially when we haven't drawn that
Stellorn Herder yet, this draw
represents a lot of options and
potentially being able to push those
final points. Yeah, one of the
challenges that you have here if you're
Dino is that you do have removal, but
that guardian angel is going to cost you
some resources. I mean, you'll have the
call of week, you have the hidden
blades, but
>> it's just a it's just a reset with that
guardian angel, unfortunately. And so,
as a result, you you got to try to
capture the board a little bit here and
see if uh you can slowly make that
Aurelia a little more exposed.
>> BF sword,
>> that's fine. There we have the BF sword
which is part of the mini equipment in
this deck and a way to potentially try
to well I would if I were in this
position I wouldn't be looking to try to
push over this Aurelia. It's an
abandoned hall and you know Defiant
Dances in the hand so okay looks like
we're going for it
>> considering his options here. He does
have two runes up
>> and we do know about the defiant dance
as an option as well. Has to decide is
this worth it or not.
>> Yeah, discipline's also an option.
>> I mean, if this were to work out for
Darius, that could be a huge Well, with
a guardian angel, not too big of a
change, but there is that discipline as
you said earlier. We'll get the draw.
We'll get the target. Lots of might for
Aurelia. There she goes again. taking
off like a rocket ship.
>> Target.
>> Yeah, target.
>> And that is exactly why you play
abandoned hall game one with Aurelia.
>> Exactly. So, we will lose out on that
trade which is just going to be tough
overall. And if we don't have a way to
develop here, it's going to be even more
tricky, especially with that seed of
power open for the scuttle to come.
>> But it looks like we will have some more
development,
>> potentially more gear. We'll see which
one it is.
>> I'll do two.
>> Looks like we have another play coming
here. skip to the next game cuz that was
a misplay and a half
>> and okay
>> that just kills.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes. Uh we haven't seen this guy for a
bit but the Noxian guillotine is out
here and does have to pay for a deflect
cost as well because we were targeting
Ireelia scoop the next.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> It sounds like they might be scooping
here. Going to that next game.
>> It looks like uh the advantage that
Randy had was a little too far for Dino
to overcome. So they're going to be
going game two. Now, the story of this
game, I think, was simply that Aurelia
got out there early and the pushes that
Dynino had made to try to kind of
offseat the champ. It just it just
wasn't enough here.
>> Oh, yeah. And the double guardian angel,
huge amount of just being like, "Oh, you
killed Direlia. No, you didn't. Oh, you
killed Aurelia. No, you didn't." So,
really good start overall for Randy
here. And we will be going on to the
next game. It looks like we have the
arena's greatest, assuming that Darius
will be going first. And this should be
a great spot for Darius overall. Making
the game a little bit faster is what we
said Darius needs to do to be successful
in this game overall.
>> Yeah. And sunken Temple's going to be a
great option for Aurelia. Um but yeah,
that arena's greatest. You want to try
not to allow Aurelia to kind of get
flowing, but it's one of those things
where like when you when you're playing
against Aurelia, obviously it's coming
from the champion zone as well.
>> So something really important too about
the sunken temple is often Darius Gas is
out. However, because it can get up to
the amount of might needed, five to get
cards from Sunken Temple, this could
actually be a pretty good battlefield
for Darius, too.
>> Yeah, of course. Especially when he's
able to uh, you know, ready himself on a
whim uh alongside that uh that Legion
ability. He's able to get in there and
uh take take over that battlefield, take
the effect and gain an advantage. We're
going to game two here. Randy won game
one. I know the first one.
>> Dino, I'm assuming, is going to be going
first.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah. Let's hope he can find a better
start this time. Was pretty unfortunate
with that last start, especially going
second. Undying. Once again, we talked
about it being something that's really
more valueoriented than tempo oriented.
And in this deck, we really want to see
that fast tempo against Ireelia. And
hopefully with the arena's greatest and
taking that first turn, we'll be able to
see a better game for a Darius. Now, in
this given circumstance here, Ireelia,
now I don't think in the main deck that
we saw a Vex apathetic, but running
purple, if there's a chance to sideboard
a card like that, it would be
detrimental, I think, to the uh the game
plan of of Dino for the most part. I
wonder if that is an option that Randy
has.
>> Yeah, it's hard to say without having
direct access to the sideboards. Also,
there's a potential that the Darius deck
is running gear removal as well. And I
really does use a lot of gear cuz we saw
what happened with that guardian angel.
So, it'll be interested to see what
these players do decide to put in their
sideboards and if that changes the
outcome of this game.
>> We're in the mulligan phase here.
Mulligans are always so tough because
they you have to decide is what I have
in my hand better than if I get two
cards deeper in my deck in some cases or
one card deeper in my deck. So having
that quick tempo, Darius did mulligan,
too. So that shows that that hand isn't
exactly what he was looking for. So
we'll see if we have another slow start
for Darius or if we're able to find it.
However, it looks like Darius did opt to
take second instead of going first here.
So, Ireelia actually gets on the board
first with the tide turner.
>> Yeah, that's not what I expected at all
to be honest with you. Um, what do you
what do you assume is the the strategy
here by by uh kind of conceding uh the
go?
>> The big strategy is with the idea of
playing two two drops at the same time
because of the Darius legend. So, you're
able to play one and then we don't have
that second two drop though. So, that
that is tough
>> cuz even the Nox is hopeful there,
right?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> There's a lot of options in this deck.
That's the big thing it takes advantage
of.
>> First point being scored by Randy here.
>> Yeah, you did.
>> Second point, assuming we didn't miss
the greatest.
>> That's right.
>> Literally,
>> we've seen that in the past even from
the game's greatest where the arena's
greatest trigger there. It looks like uh
Dino's uh
>> that it's not displaying that he took
the point, but
>> yeah, there's a possibility of a mis
trigger here, but we'll have to see.
>> Right.
Once again, my hero scuttle is on the
board drawing a card and the G as well.
A very similar look to what we saw last
game.
>> Yeah, very strong opening from Randy
here.
>> We'll have to This is a very important
turn here. I think that Dino needs to
set up a board here.
>> I guess I guess
>> absolutely needs to something. And the
other tough thing about Darius in the
future is the star cross is pretty scary
into it. Hopefully, and we know there
weren't two two drops. Maybe he's able
to get something else here that helps
out. The inferna being with that assault
is able to take out that tide turner
with ease, which is very helpful.
>> Yeah, I like this play a lot. It's a
good tempo play here. And I think that
uh like of course the scuttle crab now
can't actually contest these
battlefields unless you try to utilize
that uh that G, but I don't I don't
think you're putting a G on a scuttle
crab, of course. So, it looks like uh
it's going to slow the pace of the game
down for Randy quite a bit.
>> And we do see that unsung hero there
maybe will be the hero of drawing more
cards. Must have been the top deck most
likely because we didn't see those two
drops earlier. So Randy can make a read
here a little bit as well.
>> Holding two battlefields here from Dino.
Now Randy does have the chosen champion
early available.
>> Yeah,
>> the guardian angel is on the field of
play.
>> So that's exactly what they're going to
do.
>> Recycle one. Well, so here comes Ireelia
and it will be targeted with the GA and
then we will ready her with the Ireelia
as well. I believe so.
>> Yes.
>> Just making sure all the runes are in
order here is tapped out. So I really
will be able to do what they wish and
we'll be able to take either
battlefield. It looks like we're seeing
the sunken temple and will we see the
pay for that extra card draw here?
>> It's an important question. Yeah, you do
have one mana up here. And I think that
like with the one rune up, you could
consider holding it. Now, there could be
a defy in hand. There could be
optionality for him to try to protect
that Aurelia, which is obviously very
important,
but also with the draws involved, too.
>> Yeah, personally, I think tapping out
our Aurelia is one of the most scary
things you can possibly do. However, we
do have the G on it, so it makes it to
be a little bit less scary, but you can
pretty much always represent something
at one energy for Aurelia. So, why would
you not in a lot of cases if you're not
worried about gassing out and running
out of cards, then it's something that
you're like, "Oh, I will at some point
leave this battlefield and come back
anyway, and you can take the card draw
when you have a bit more runes to work
with."
>> So, I like what Randy just kind of did.
He kind of tipped his hat a little bit
there. I think he was thinking about
maybe sacrifice or just throwing the uh
the crab in there just to kind of take a
quick glimpse at maybe what like does he
have to float this rune like what's in
the hand? Like I kind of like that he
ultimately decides to pass the turn
here. But uh it's kind of an interesting
thought.
>> Yeah, it is. And that's one of the great
utilities of scuttle and why so many
players have decided to play scuttle
rather than lonely porro is being able
to understand what is in your opponent's
hand especially when there is so much uh
gear that adds might and potentially
could make uh playing scary because we
could target Aurelia and or we could pay
one for the conquer and then uh reready
our Aurelia and then target her and then
move her out to safety. That would be
very expensive though, but it is a
consideration when Ireelia is so core to
this deck and we know the Stellorn isn't
ready either.
>> We have the unsung hero coming out. This
is a card I've always loved actually.
And in this particular deck, uh your
goal obviously is you want to get it
mighty.
>> So hopefully that'll provide some hand
advantage for Dino here.
>> Yes, I have one.
>> Yes. So a lot of options here as we
didn't see a ton of cards played yet
from Dino. So we'll probably see
something coming here. Of course, every
player says, "I see this Aurelia and I
want to remove it." But with the
Guardian Angel, not the best possibility
here. Uh we saw what happened last game
where it was essentially a blowout of
not being able to do anything against
Airelia. However, that was an unbanded
hall and this is on Sunken Temple. Two
very different battlefields and you
operate much differently for Aurelia.
>> Now, I'm trying to think to our
discussion back about the decks. I do
not remember seeing a salvage in the
main deck. Um, which obviously would
help to alleviate some of the pressure
from that uh that GA, but uh, okay, we
have a play coming out here. Looks like
Dino's thinking it through.
>> Looks like it might be the uh, the
Darius from the champion zone.
>> Okay, I'll bring out
>> just making sure those runes are turned
all the way to the side. So, go ahead
and recycle that red rune as well. And
we're going to use our Darius. And what
will we be bringing out here?
>> And it's the salvage.
Must have been sideboarded in. We do get
the salvage. And that changes
everything. That makes that Aurelia
significantly more vulnerable. And uh
thankfully Randy does have one rune up.
>> Yes. Will we see that defy or not is the
big question. And if it is even there
regardless of Randy has it in hand. He
has to pretend like he has it in hand.
Uh that was the bluff that we saw there
potentially. Or maybe he does have in
hand decided, oh, I'm going to do
something else instead. But likely a
bluff there from Randy just playing
slow, not being like, oh no, you're
good. You're good. Because oftent times
players try to do that saying, "Oh, you
know, it's fine." And they just tipped
their hand by doing that. So Randy being
a seasoned card game player has taken
his time and said, "Okay,
>> that goes through my four."
>> This is a lot of might coming in. It
does look like nine might coming in from
Dino against Aurelius 4.
>> Yeah. And we'll see what happens here.
We have the on guard
>> three and kill.
>> Okay.
And it looks like Adarius and Aurelia,
the two champions are going to trade
here. The Unsung hero remains.
>> So, we do get that conquer there as
well. No option of paying to uh get that
extra card draw. However, the infernal
move back, which I love doing this
because the assault is so good on her.
You want to be able to attack in as much
as possible. So, really strong play from
the Darius here.
>> And for the most part though, like this
is this is a big moment for for Dino.
for the Darius player, taking out that
Aurelia is going to be a huge asset
because it's going to put the uh the
power in his hands to slowly start to
chip away at these battlefields and
hopefully close out the game.
>> The big question is, are there any units
in hand for Randy? If there's no units,
then we have a tough time here. So,
we're going to stack deck first. Uh we
would love to find Cellicorn Herder
here. Like, that would be the hit if you
had the option for it because you want
to be able to draw and have something
else. Now that the Aurelia is gone, we
need to find a unit here or else we're
in big trouble.
>> You're absolutely right. At the end of
the day, Aurelia really does focus in on
that chosen champion. It's one of the
key powers that it has. It's so
consistent coming out of the champion
zone. But if in the event that it's
answered and then all of a sudden like
what are you going to try to do, you
know, use a scuttle crab as a carry?
Like it's not going to work. You have
the tide turner maybe, but at the end of
the day, you're right, Randy desperately
needs that stole corner. And then even
from there, like realistically, you got
to try to trick yourself into a a
position where you're able to, you know,
actually challenge these battlefields
cuz there's going to be a lot of might
on the field of play from Dino. Like
Darius can put up serious might. He can
be aggressive. And so, as a result, I
think that uh Randy might be on the back
foot here.
>> Yeah, I' I've tried buffing up my
scuttle to do the work before. It does
not work very well, especially when we
don't have the gear option either.
There's no boots of swiftness out. Uh
it's just too much resources to a card
with not that high of value where you
can get away with the Celicorn because
it just has so much value. We do have
Tide Turner as well. So at least we got
something there. Um I'm a little I'm
surprised that we didn't see the scuttle
come in to conquer first and then Tide
Turner back just didn't want that back
on the board. Trying to keep everything
safe, I guess, is what we're seeing
there.
>> Okay, makes sense.
>> We're attacking here. Yeah, the unsung
hero is definitely vulnerable here.
>> Yes. and trying to kill it. Well,
killing it without it having that five
might, not drawing the extra cards. So,
yeah, really great play from Randy here
saying, you know, I didn't find that
Celicorn obviously cuz or else we would
have played it and instead I have to
just do something with the cards that I
have. At least he has one, you know, one
unit outside of Scuttle that actually
has some might on it. It's not ideal,
but it is manageable. one rune up from
Randy here, which is very helpful
because uh in infern there can actually
assault to a three might, which would
then just trade the uh the tie turner.
And of course, you don't want to you
don't want to necessarily uh kind of use
the G so fast when you really need this
tie turner to survive to maintain a
board state.
>> Yeah, it really is going to come down to
card quality from Randy at this point
and if he is able to find another unit.
Like I said, great play from Dino being
able to recognize that he had an
opportunity to kill the Ireelia. The
salvage in the sideboard as well doing a
lot of work. So, a lot of good things
here from Dino.
>> So, that's a cleave
checking the sideboard. Not the
sideboard, sorry. That is the trash.
>> Yes, always good to do. I've noticed
that the farther you get along, the
stronger the players, they check the
discard a lot more often, especially
against decks that they're not used to
playing against as much. So things like
the Darius, for instance, a lot of
players probably don't have repetitions
on Darius compared to playing against
other well-known meta decks.
>> And there's the Defiant Dance.
>> Does it swing the numbers in Ry's favor?
>> All right, I will.
>> He is tapped out here.
>> Okay, I'll play a cleave again.
>> A second cleave comes down. That's three
more assault. That is likely more than
enough.
>> Yes, that pulling back that Inferno
earlier making a big difference here.
And potentially can pay one to draw an
extra card. And we just saw a lot of
cards spent just to pop a guardian
angel. That's one thing that I am
concerned about here. So I am interested
to see if we are drawing that card or
not. And it looks like we are not.
>> The Undying Legion does come down. It
definitely looks like Dino is in a very
strong position here holding that
battlefield
>> and uh I I love the uh the energy from
Dino there.
>> Yes, once again tapped out which is or
it looks like we have two up. Uh pretty
common from Darius just because you are
very low to the ground. You are playing
very high tempo and that's what we're
seeing here. And we'll see if Randy is
able to find some answers or find those.
We did get the stack deck again. very
good at drawing stack deck and if we can
find that Celicorn and just able to
start filtering through our deck uh
Randy would feel in a much stronger
position but for now we'll have to see
what is up his sleeve.
>> Something tells me he might not be
looking at Stellorn Herder right now
because he's really thinking through
these options and if there was an easy
option it might have been chosen by now.
So we'll have to see if that card added
to hand is in fact the Stellorn Herder
that Randy so desperately desires.
Uh,
>> Scuttle Crab going in for a point.
>> Yeah,
>> five.
>> Scuttle crab getting a point.
>> And up to five we go. So, we'll see the
star cross come out. Wow. To me, this
feels like I won't quite say a desperate
play, but far from ideal. And not
because it's a bad play necessarily, but
it's definitely
>> if this isn't if you were to think about
how you wanted this game to go as
playing Ireelia, you wouldn't think,
yeah, I want to start cross and and
dying.
>> No, of course not. And oh no, long sword
coming in. That is something. And there
is still one rune up from Randy here. I
mean,
>> sorry about my
>> And yeah, it's just uh fortunate that
tie turner is gone. So we are just
>> we're in top deck mode for that uh
stolorn her at this point. Uh yeah,
that's fine.
>> Yep.
>> That was a pretty quick takeback, too.
So, showing
didn't, you know, no defiant dance in
hand is a big read here for Dino. And
that's a huge card in this matchup,
especially when we are having a lot of
unitto-unit combat. So, that gave Dynino
quite a bit of information here, which
is helpful.
>> If you are looking for good news though,
if you're Randy, thankfully the game
can't be ended on this turn.
>> So, you do get a chance to stay in it
here. Uh so, you you do survive to fight
another day. the uh the Undying Legion
does come out. I like this tech. Was not
expecting. There is the Nox is hopeful
as well. Very strong board state already
here. And again, Randy does not have all
that much.
>> And now Dino's positioning to close out
the game.
>> Yes, I love this positioning and uh
being able to pull everything back,
getting that assault ready to go. This
is a great setup for Dino overall.
Really, Ry's going to need a bit of Oh,
he found a scuttle, so it's something.
But this is a draw with your fingers
crossed hoping to be able to do
something. You have to be able to hold
one of these battlefields with a
scuttle. That's going to be entirely
hard to do.
>> And if you don't have an answer, right,
it's kind of hard to say. It's one of
those positions where like how much do
you want to reveal about what's in your
hand, what your game plan is, like if
you're Randy, you think, okay, do I try
to apply all all the spells and all the
reactions and all the actions I can.
Okay, it's a discipline
>> too. Ready?
>> Trying to trying to search through that
deck. Yes. And specifically needs to be
able to target the scuttle to activate
Aurelia because they do need to hold for
sure. So, we're able to put scuttle up
there. And then we have to say we're
going to hold with this and defend with
it one way or the other. And we see the
pass here. I'm not sure what card
combinations we'll be able to do that
because even with double defiant dance,
I don't think we quite get there.
>> Yeah, we have two runes up. Randy doing
a great job of hiding his hand from us.
So, we have no idea what he can be
doing. But uh yeah, I mean this is this
is a uh do or die moment here. You're
going to be able to walk into the
arena's greatest and then the scuttle
crab is going to have to put up a fight.
>> Just trying to think of
>> Do you believe in him?
>> Sure.
>> Can I be honest with you?
>> I I do not I do not believe the scuttle
crab in this given situation. I'm sorry.
I know you love it, but I I just
>> I'm a bit disappointed.
>> I'm going to bet against him here.
>> He's just minding his own business at
the sunken temple. Is this like every
time I take out a lonely Porro, I just
feel a little bad. Is that Is this uh
>> just can't believe that worked.
>> We scooping here.
>> Like actually, bro, I don't know.
>> Looks like we are.
>> We're going to game three.
>> Holy. Okay, let's lock in.
>> Yeah,
>> really well navigated from Dino here. Uh
really like the play overall and opted
to go second
>> and Miss Arena's greatest trigger of
their own and still won that game.
>> Oh, I forgot about the arena's greatest.
I don't think I ever saw end up on the
board. this one.
>> So, that was quite amazing to be able to
come back from that.
>> You know what's funny? When I'm at my
LGS's and I'm playing locals, I always
just say, "Hey, I say that. Can I just
put it on now? Can I just do the point
now? I don't want to forget."
>> And um you know, and I I feel bad like
honestly with with Dino, you're you're
on the camera, you're on the stream, and
then like a little more extra nerves. I
know the feeling, you know what I mean?
And you make a little mistake like that.
But you know what? At the end of the
day, he overcame it.
>> Yeah. Something that I do to try to
remember those triggers easier is I
actually hold my pointer finger out at
the battlefield while I'm doing other
things. So then I look at my finger. Um
Oh, yep. Especially if I'm going first,
but that's the way that I remember is
just holding my hand out. It looks a
little silly, but it works really well.
>> Some I mean, you can even take notes in
in Riftbound, right? You can record
their hand when you're doing the
scuttle. Why don't you just write down
get your point? Get your point and just
do a bit big circle on that. Uh, but you
know, I'm actually excited to see a game
three here. I think this was fantastic.
I think Randy definitely took that game
one with uh with strength. And then you
saw Dino make an absolutely fantastic
comeback, but you brought up something
really important there.
>> Randy had to almost
>> I don't want to say I don't want to say
pretend, but definitely showcases if
okay, I I might have a defy here. I got
one up. He could have used the draw. He
could have paid to draw. Did chose not
to. And it was almost like he was
figning. Oh, I can defy your salvage.
And Dino went for it and ultimately went
through. That was the major turning
point of this particular match.
>> Oh, for sure. The difference of salvage
gets defied there. It's a different card
game for sure.
>> Targon's Peak, that's something that
Randy definitely wants here because it's
going to help him defend that Aurelia.
Doesn't have to worry about those
floats. Can actually just utilize uh
that battlefield to the greatest
effectiveness.
>> Yeah, and Targon's Peak is really great
for going first overall because you
typically are the first person to
conquer, which means you are ready to
ready those runes nice and early. you're
able to potentially hold with the
Aurelia as well. There's a lot of
options there. And he finds that scuttle
again. He's really good at doing that.
>> If you can find any unit turn one, I
mean, scuttle crab is a great option.
You get to draw a card. You get to take
a look at their hand when he inevitably
dies. I mean, this is a it's a great
card. We are seeing a lot of skull crab.
>> So, something to point out here, of
course, you know, Randy did take that
going first, but we know from what we've
seen with Dino, going second is his
comfort zone. This is where he wants to
be. He chose to go second live. We were
like, "Oh, he's going to go first.
Arena's greatest game this and that."
Now that he skipped the arena's greatest
trigger, but he got the win going second
with Darius. I mean, he must know
something that we don't in that case.
And I'm glad that uh it worked out for
him in that case. So, he's thinking out
his turn here.
>> Looks like we do have I think that's a
cool the weekend hand. It's a little bit
hard to see, but
>> yeah.
>> Uh it might be that. And ideally, you
know, that two two drop. That's the
dream start that we've been looking for.
Getting on the board nice and early, but
we might not quite get to that. Looks
like we're going to get a three drop
going here instead.
>> Yeah, main board. I think we only saw
one call the week if my memory serves me
correct.
>> And I mean, it's a good card. And not
against the
>> sure crab, but generally speaking, we
got Pike. Pike's coming in.
>> That's fine.
>> Early point
>> and the first to conquer as well on
Targon's Peak. We'll see those runes be
readied. on top two
>> being able to have that long sword
potentially activated.
>> An excellent call there from Dino.
Definitely want to hold that there.
>> Randy thinking his turn through four
runes up.
>> Once again, probably missing out on the
Stellicorn because we haven't seen that
pretty much all game. And if we were to
have the Stellicorn here, there isn't a
ton of backline interaction with the
Darius deck. So, we probably haven't
found it. Once again, having to filter
through his deck. We have seen stack
deck over and over again and not very
quick choices on it. So, we know that
they haven't quite been the way. It
looks like we have a gust and ong guard
and I missed that middle one, but a
couple options there.
>> Randy gave a little head nod as if he
wasn't that impressed with his options.
>> I wasn't very impressed with them either
from what I could see.
>> But you're right. We actually have not
seen the Oh. Oh, I thought he was going
to do it. I thought he was going to do I
was just going to say
>> you got faked out. I was just going to
say we haven't seen the scuttle crab
sacrifice itself for the greater
knowledge of Randy. And it almost did it
there. Randy thought about it.
>> Hey, we're voting. I mean, I don't want
Scuttle to die. But
>> I want him dead. I want him gone. I want
to see what's in that hand.
>> That's the only reason. I mean, it
almost brings a tear to my eye. I think
I'm just dying like that.
>> Oh, he had a plan. It's more than that.
It's more than just sacrificing the
scuttle crab. On guard comes out. likely
what we saw from that stock deck as
well.
>> Dino did not expect this.
>> No long sword then. I mean, would it go
down to only one rune if he were to have
that, but the long sword would do
something here. However, two runes still
up for Randy. Could easily be blown out
by another spell as well.
>> Thinking about it.
>> Sure.
>> Hidden blade.
>> It's hidden blade. So, yeah, he wants to
draw cards
>> and going down to one rune. We'll see if
the defy is in hand. Randy, once again,
like we talked about, taking his time on
making this this decision because a
hidden blade getting out for a scuttle
feels, you know, he still has access to
the Aurelia in the future. Is it really
worth defying this even if you were to
have it in hand?
>> It does feel a little bad to have to
play it out from hand like that.
>> You pay the two, you pay the power, but
>> that's fine.
>> And ready to sign. That's fine. You
know, I'll take reveal your, you know,
reveal your hand and then also I'm going
to get some Oh, define. Oh, it's on his
own. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Trying to get the draw.
Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Scuttle crab wins.
>> Ah, he did it once again.
>> I should have had faith. I didn't.
>> But still going down to one rune here.
However, Darius is very low to ground as
we talked about earlier. Very efficient.
So with this three, it really becomes
four if we do get the Legion proc with
the Darius Legend. So it could be okay
here, but definitely needs to
reestablish and develop this board. If
we have another lower tempo turn, it's
going to make it really tough to come
back into this game.
>> And I guess another point worth
considering is the Scuttle Crab is now
even more valuable because Dino has more
cards in his hand.
>> Scuttle just keeps winning over and over
again. Why isn't everyone playing this
card?
>> I guess, you know, maybe actually I'll
be honest with you. I cut Scuttlecraft
from my uh my Ivvern deck. Maybe I gotta
change that.
>> And it's an Undying Legion again. Seeing
a lot of this card. Not seeing the
ability like we're not seeing it come
back from the trash, but we're just
seeing it show up, I guess.
>> Yeah, once again, just not quite the
tempo that you're looking at here for
Darius. A big reason why we saw a
success in that second match was because
of the higher tempo plays we were able
to do, especially when we saw that Nox's
hopeful come out. just missing some of
those is tough and so many cards in the
hand too. So we know the options are
there and I think we did see a call the
week as one of them but really you're
not wanting to call scuttle crab here at
all.
>> Yeah and if anything even if you think
about bringing uh signature only targets
battlefield
>> you bring the scuttle crab back just so
it's like
>> cuz you know Randy knows that well I'm
against the order here. There's
definitely the option to call that's why
I'm asking you.
>> They could target anywhere
>> anywhere. Okay. So with Ireelia having
access to Ireelia pretty much at any
point,
>> we're still in a really good spot. The
big reason why we lost that second was
because we did lose out on Aurelia
pretty early.
>> I know you play no Stella. So
>> that's been tough as well.
>> And we still haven't seen Stellorn
Herder because Stellorn Herder comes
out. It generates a ton of hand power
for the uh for the Aurelia player and
then it gives all the the options you
need, all the reactions you need to then
protect Aurelia as it drifts in and out
of the battlefields.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Okay, that's pretty scary.
>> Looks like we'll go ahead and see the
start of this next turn come up. Six
runes available
>> and he's back protected. And as we
suggested, it is Aurelia's time to come
out and shine.
>> Yep. Keeping
Nice and safe here. Can also potentially
add the guardian angel on here. Could
look at using the power for the Ireelia
to go conquer as well. However, you
really want to keep that one rune up.
The Targon's Peak though can't even be
conquered because we move scuttle back
from it. And is the sunken temple worth
the draw? We're going to guess no, but
we're going to go ahead and pass here.
Keeping as much runes available to us in
the future as possible. We learned from
last time that if we get a little bit
too fast with it, a salvage can take us
out and that would be potentially game
ending for Randy here. So, being a
little bit more safe with this, playing
a bit slower, saying, I know I can get
the value out of this. I can get the
draw in the future. I have ways to be
able to continue this game and the
longer it goes, it's better for me as
Darius potentially gasses out here.
>> Still in the early stages. It's 2-1
Randy. So, and I think you're you're
exactly right. He learned hard the last
game that losing that Aurelia just
completely deflated his opportunity to
make that comeback here. Um he's got a
decent hand. He's got five in hand
threatening one rune up.
>> Not too many options, but I mean you pay
the cost on that Aurelia turn, get it
out, and then now he gets to actually
work and start trying to score multiple
points. And as you suggested,
>> you know, you get into that sunken
temple
quite remember. Did he have a boots of
swiftness? I think he did. We did have
two boots of sweetness I think in the
the main deck there. So then he with
Aurelia you could gank over to the
target peak to then protect the Aurelia
further.
>> Yeah. And really the Darius has a lot of
options in hand here too. A lot more
than I'm used to expecting with this
deck with it being as high tempo as it
is. But we have kind of seen this be a
little bit of a slower version of the
Darius deck. Uh looks like we are going
in for that Targon's peak.
>> I'm gonna Oh, wait.
>> Should be a point scored there.
And I think Ry's thinking about
something here.
>> Probably Gust, I would assume.
>> Stack deck. Yeah, uses the trigger to
get a stack deck there,
>> which would indicate that he doesn't
feel threatened by needing to have the
one up for a Defy.
>> So, that was a really quick choice here
from Randy. We've seen him think about
his choices pretty thoughtfully in the
past. So, I'm wondering if we did
finally find that Stellicorn Herder that
we have been looking for game after
game. or maybe we found those boots of
swiftness. It seemed to be a pretty easy
decision for him overall. Something that
he knew that would push his game plan
further.
>> Yeah.
>> Dino thinking about this next play.
Holding two cycle.
>> Yes.
>> Is that a falling star that we're going
to see?
>> And it is the falling star.
>> We get to finally reveal the hand.
>> Yes.
>> So he is setting up here for a cold
week. So, he wanted to take the scuttle
out, not play the deflect on the
Aurelia. And we're going to see Cole the
week come out here because of the tap
out by Randy. We'll be able to play one.
However, the guardian angel will be
popped. Um, but we will see Darius get
activated. We'll see that second call
the week come out here and actually kill
while also losing our units. But, we're
going to have a reset game state here.
And that big question becomes, did we
draw that Cellicorn Herder and we're
able to then continue get resources? If
we didn't get that,
>> this game could be very Darius favored
quickly.
>> Bomb.
>> Yeah, Darius is definitely threatening
to take over state here,
>> which is exactly what happened in game
two.
>> And then bomb.
>> Finding the answers to this Aurelia is
so critical.
>> And it looks like with two called the
weeks in hand that uh that's definitely
an answer that he can perhaps have.
>> And just like that, I'm down to one
rune. I like that.
>> Yep. Down to one rune as we see. but got
rid of the Aurelia and we saw second
game that worked. That's all that was
needed. So, a big question here is do we
have the units now? What can we do now?
>> And it's also notable that we do have
Darius from the champ zone for Dino. So,
even if his hands a little like, you
know, underwhelming, he has that
immediate option and that that Darius
with his ability to get readied,
>> it could quickly start chipping away at
the point total.
>> So, we did get Ireelia back out onto the
board. a lot to get rid of.
>> So was spent so much to get rid of it
and she is back.
>> I'm pretty sure I heard Dino from here
exclaim in fury.
>> Oh, I mean you always want Diana to go
away whenever she is. And it looks like
a very quick turn. We play out the Rex
eye and it's back to Ry's turn.
>> Ry's going to carefully think this
through here. We It's okay. We I got I
don't know if you notice we've only got
two points on each side here. It's
actually been a much slower pace to
these games.
>> Yeah, overall um the idea is like we're
generating value here from the Aurelia
side. That is if you can get Stellorn up
and Darius does want to be pretty quick,
but with Airelia definitely slows it
down as well. Targon's Peak also giving
a lot of access to additional energy
that we don't usually see access can
make a big difference as well. But yeah,
been a you know, overall much slower
played game. We do still have plenty of
time left in the round. So the players
are really taking their time on these
decisions as well. And Randy does take
advantage of the sunken temple. Pays the
one. Gets the extra card here. Has a
decent hand now. So should have. And
there's the charm.
>> We're charming Rex in. And Rexi is just
Dunzo.
>> Yeah. And it looks like uh in the main
board, we do actually have that
additional Aurelia. So we were able to
find it this time for situations just
like this.
>> And Aurelia now gets ready. Goes in,
gets the Targon speed. before.
>> No, no, pass, pass priority. Sorry.
>> So, we're passing priority saying like,
do you have any actions here rather than
passing the turn itself?
>> Dino is tapped out, though. So, can't
really react in any way.
>> And it's Vex apathetic. That is an
absolute death now to the aggressive
nature of something like Dino's Darius
deck.
>> Yes. And the big thing is we still have
Darius in the champion zone and now we
can't even advance him anymore. We can't
move him. He gets played and he gets uh
stunned and then we advance him. Well,
we can't. Uh we've seen Vex be well,
this is really the beginning of Vex's
reign. We are going to continue see Vex
do really well and slow down these
opportunities and that's part of the
reason why Fury has had such a rough go
is it has accelerate units. has things
that are able to move early and Vex just
says no.
>> To the surprise of literally nobody
watching, Vex has proven to be a good
card in Riftbound. And and you're
exactly right, like we've not been
utilizing Darius early on. And then now
you can't because if he comes in, you
ready him, then he's just going to sit
there. He's not going to move. And so
you lose a lot
>> of pressure and tempo there. And now
with Vex sitting there and obviously you
have a massive hand from Randy. Three
runes up. He's going to be able to
defend that uh that Vex apathetic. He's
going to be able to defend the Aurelia.
But notable that uh we don't have
another G come down which I think he
would have been searching for if uh if
he could because I think that would
obviously help Rain in this game.
>> Yep. And looks like we will see Vi come
out. A very strong unit but won't be
able to attack quite yet. So really just
developing here. Randy is going to be
able to hold. So really tough spot for
the Darius now. Has to deal with so much
and like we said the Darius and champion
zone is just a bit dead here. I would
expect Randy here to pull these units
back likely position for the
game-winning turn. He's got a lot of
options here. But at the same time, it's
like you got Vex on the battlefield. You
want to leave Vex there. And he cho he
chooses to leave Vex there understanding
that listen, Vex is there. You're not
going to be able to like push right in.
I got all this runes. All these runes
are ready to rip and he's just laying
out his five cards. I got stuff to do
here. I got reactions. I got actions.
Come at me. Try to win this game.
>> Literally all cards on the table here.
Uh so really saying, "Hey, you have to
come break one of both of these holds.
Uh one of them for sure, but I you know,
in this situation, you have to break
both of these holds for me to not win
the game." And with the cards, I mean,
there's just so many options here. Uh,
Aurelia just has access to so much stuff
overall. So, as Dino,
>> I mean, what do you even do here? You
have to try something. You can't do
nothing. You probably go for the
Ireelia. Oh, Ireelia though with Defiant
Dances. Maybe you actually go for the
Vex side because you want to, if you are
able to clear that, you can use the
Darius in the future.
>> I was just going to say that is a heavy
price to pay. Can you imagine falling
starring a Vex apathetic? The one thing
about the Vex apathetic, too, is it has
the deflect. It seems like such an
unnecessary game where it's like, oh,
you got to pay all these all this power
just to take out one card. And he had to
do it, though. Because if he doesn't,
then he can't he can't compete. He can't
contest. He has to have an answer for
that Vex.
>> And we see the star cross come out as an
answer of just saying, you know what, my
Vex is going to go back to my hand. You
paid all that deflect. And also, I'm
gonna take your VI off the board, too.
So, she can't threaten my Aurelia. A
fantastic play from Randy here, being
nice and reactive.
>> And now we have it. Aurelia being
challenged here by Darius. One v one,
>> but I'm sure I'm sure Randy likely has
an answer here.
>> I would be shocked if he didn't. It
looks like we are adding that plus two
because Darius was ready. Yeah, that's
the plan. Plus two, plus three
>> and that is the game. What an absolutely
fantastic match between Dino and Randy.
Randy is going to take it here in three
games. I got to tell you that was going
to be really nerve-wracking. And they
went back and forth game one, game two,
and then with this particular game,
Randy did finish it off, especially with
getting that Aurelia back.
>> So that third match, the difference
there was being able to find that
additional Aurelia. Imagine if we were
stuck like the second game where we
actually lost out on the Aurelia and we
weren't able to find a new unit to
really take control because without
Aurelia there or Celicorn also too
seeing a game without Celicorn in
Aurelia is insane.
>> And shout out to Dino. Look look how
happy he's having the time of his life
here on the stage. That's fantastic. I
again we we've talked about it so many
times. The the spirit in these regional
events is absolutely through the roof.
There's so much energy, so much positive
energy and to see competitors like that
is it just it just warms my heart. But I
absolutely love it. And that game was
remarkable. All three games really
showcased the power of not just what
Aurelia does and why you might see
Aurelia later on in these events, but of
course why in some ways Darius is a bit
of a dark horse and probably, you know,
one of Fury's main ways of perhaps
breaking into the top cut.
>> Yeah, and I would say too overall the
Darius deck wasn't even high rolling
either. It was actually even a bit of a
low roll in some cases. I would say when
that deck high rolls and you do get the
second turn or turn one, two, two drops
or two drop in Noxus, it makes a huge
difference where you're able to just
take over those battlefields really
early. This one did have a bit more of a
control element to it. So, we saw those
cold weeks um come into the main board
as well. And we did see the work that
they put in and Ireelia does notoriously
have a little bit harder uh harder
matchup into the yellow decks for that
reason. Like we see why that'd be an
issue for it. However, very well
navigated by Randy had that second
Ireelia which made all the difference in
the world and even without the Stellorn
Hurders was able to find a way to win
that game.
>> You bring up a great point. We actually
did not see Stellicorn Herder at all and
that is such a vital unit for the uh for
that archetype and obviously for the
domain to actually just generate that
hand size to then protect the Aurelia
with all the the skills and of course
the uh the reactions is what I meant by
skills. But let's go to game number two
here. Uh because you guys you voted on
Ry's game, but we got another game to uh
go to here. We have the second matchup.
We're in game two. We have the first
setup here. It is Leblanc. Now, I know
you absolutely love Leblanc, and now we
get a chance to actually see it in
action.
>> I do. I love this deck because it has so
many decisions to be made because
Leblanc is, I would say, very high skill
intensity, a lot of decisions being
made, and she just has the opportunity
to to do the most incredible things
because of the death nail effects and
with Carthus especially seeing this card
be a card that came out in set one and
then wasn't played at all. And then all
of a sudden, we are seeing him as a
staple in this deck. So, it's really
cool to see how the new set was able to
rise up some cards that hadn't been seen
that much. And of course, the MVP Glass
Mixologist is the card that we see that
generates so much value in this deck and
also can bring back Leblanc Fragmented,
which allows this deck to not run out of
cards. It just has so many options to
it. This is a very standard build of it.
So, we're able to see a lot of pieces
here. Of course, uh we have the baited
hook itself, which is another set one
part of a stable. And what it does is it
allows you to kill off that glass
mixologist to get lots of value uh which
is uh it's great. One thing I want to
note here though is we're not running
Gallo, which is very common uh for the
tank and then also the high roll
potential of it. So if we do want to
find these higher might units, we
actually have to sacrifice pretty big
units and pretty costly units as well.
However, we do have the three of VI in
it, which a lot of decks have been doing
one or two of, but three of eyes. Uh,
love seeing this card being part of the
staple in our yellow as well. So, really
excited to see what this deck does.
We've been talking a lot about Vi and
how much we love Vi. It's great to see
VI Peacekeeper being a meta uh contender
in the game of Riftbound. And we also
have the Thousand Tail Watcher. You need
a little bit of speed now in the
battlefield side. And I mean you do have
windswept Hillick which is obviously a
huge opportunity to generate value but
alongside that thousand tail watch
allows you to get on the board and then
obviously push into the battlefields.
>> And something I want to talk about is
aspirants climb in this deck. It's a
really great battlefield for going
second. Um it also can be a neutral
battlefield as well but a lot of players
have said if my deck is inevitable
Leblanc will outvalue you at some point
and there's nothing you can do about it.
If I extend this game to be a little bit
longer, Aspirin's climb allows me to do
that. And it also allows me to come from
behind on tempo when I'm going second as
well. So, this has a key component of
you're going second isn't as weak as
some other decks because Aspirin's Climb
just allows you to have that extra time
to generate the value you're looking at
for winning with this deck.
>> Let's take a look at that second deck
that's going to be facing off against
Leblanc. And of course, we have Kai'Sa.
Kai'Sa was the deck to beat in Origins.
hasn't quite had the same success now.
>> So, Kai'Sa is personally one of my
favorite decks and I played it almost
all of set one. And I want to note the
return of Void Seeker. Void Seeker was
very popular in Kai'Sa in set one. It
kind of fell off during Spirit Forge
with all the equipment that we had.
However, with the rise of Vex apathetic,
we are seeing Void Seeker make a return
to the meta because it's a very clean
way of dealing with Vex. you just have
to um pay one power for it because you
can use Kaisa's champion ability. So,
Void Seeker coming back into the meta is
huge. And then Falling Star also has
been a staple card in the deck. It has
never really really left, but it has
some matchups that it can just turn up
on its head. It's still a very strong
and prevalent card. And Rocket Barrage,
this is a card that I think it's a
little understated. It is very flexible.
It gives you the opportunity to target
either a gear or of course a unit at the
base. We saw a lot of target barrage in
the Ezreal meta because you're able to
take that that uh that unit out. But
being able to target the base or kill a
gear is extremely valuable. And in this
case, of course, it's a natural main
deck gear hate that you might need in
this meta.
>> Yeah. Another card that I'd like to note
about is Darius was also very common in
set one and had really fallen off and
I'm a little bit surprised to see it
now. It might be one of those one of I'm
going to, you know, surprise you with it
because we are in a closed deckless
format overall. However, because Vex is
so common in the meta, we saw what that
struggle looks like when you are playing
against Vex and you can play that Darius
and move him early. However, though,
he's still such a strong card. You can't
really go wrong with it either either.
>> I have to say, I love me some time warp.
We got time warp in this deck as well. I
think it it uh offers a very unique way
to win the game. and we're going to warp
to game number two right now.
Okay, we got flex on Leblanc,
traumatized on Kai'Sa. We're starting
off with game two and it's that Asper's
climb you talked about coming in.
>> Yeah. So I'm going to assume here that
likely the Kai'Sa player is going to be
going first and the Leblanc will be
going second would be my assumption as
when swept is usually saved at the end
for going first because you want to be
able to conquer first and get on the
board early. It also is really known to
be Leblanc's strongest battlefield as
well. So using it when you go first to
really try to ensure that win. So on
this game, we'll have to see what we get
here from Kai'Sa.
And of course, the Raven Bloom
Conservatory. Fantastic for Kai'Sa.
Being able to peek through that deck,
try to get those spells which you
obviously use to amazing effectiveness
here.
>> Oh yes, I love the Raven Bloom
Conservatory overall is just fantastic.
And because you're playing such low cost
cards a lot of the time for your units
in Kai'Sa, you don't mind that defend
trigger at all. So, and if you discard a
unit, it's not usually too big of a deal
either.
>> I'm looking too Getting
started here.
>> Good luck.
>> We are going to nine points on this one
here as it's an aspirin climb game. Game
one did go to Leblanc.
>> Plundering. Go ahead.
>> Mhm.
>> Plundering Porro. I love me some
Plundering Porro.
>> Yeah. And you might wonder like why are
we playing Plundering Porro when we
already have the Kai'Sa ability? Well,
generating gold is just good overall
because there's multiple cards that cost
more than one power and including even
things like the time warp in the future
as well, but we'll probably use that
gold before. And also, Kai'Sa's legend
ability can only be used for spells. It
doesn't include units.
>> Uh, go ahead.
>> Okay, we did get the proc of the Raven
Bloom Conservatory there.
>> Channel two drop.
>> On to the next turn.
Kai'Sa survivor is played down. One of
the main stays of the meta for Fury.
>> Yeah, and um excited to see Fury kind of
be back again. I personally, like I
said, I love Kai'Sa. So, being able to
see her play, but I mean this feels like
>> falling staring.
>> It's interesting because Kai'Sa can just
do a lot against Leblanc with the
falling stars and with all the removal.
If Leblanc really can't establish
herself on the board, it becomes really
tough. Obviously, that first game went
to Leblanc, so they did find a way to
get through all that removal.
>> And I love the Black Rose Dignitary.
It's not only does it have assault, but
you can leave it out of battlefield cuz
you're like, you know what, you want to
take this out, that's fine. You take
this out. I'm going to channel a rune
exhausted. I'm going to uh kind of uh
progress my game plan. And the further
Leblanc gets in that game plan, the more
dangerous she becomes. Yeah, as we said,
Leblanc is an inevitability, especially
with Hook. We don't know the sideboard
for Kai'Sa, so we don't know if there is
any gear removal. Part of the reason
that we've seen gear also be so common
is uh we don't have thermmo beam that
often because Fury isn't as common, but
I would be surprised if Kaiso wasn't
sideboarding in the beam. That would be
a high potential here with the hook
variant. Um, some hook variants also do
run seal of unity, but this one doesn't.
But that is something that the Kaisa
player won't know as it is a closed deck
list.
>> Yeah, and we do have uh in the back.
>> Yeah, with
>> so we have the the scout coming in.
Fantastic death. Draw a card. You always
like to see that. And yeah, I like that
call out on the thermal beam because uh
it's actually a good meta call as well.
Not just for the dazzling auroras which
comes to mind but as al also like we we
talked prior games we talked about Azir
being a meta contender had fantastic
results over the last couple of weeks
and thermal beam completely wipes out
that board state for Azir makes a rise a
complete non-factor and so it kind of
it's like you know two birds one stone
situation you have something like a
thermal beam it's a very expensive
answer to those right it's not like an
inexpensive salvage you can just
mainboard but uh most certainly in the
sideboard you'd expect perhaps a thermal
beam
So looking at what to do with this
Kai'Sa here. I mean obviously once the
card draw because at some point
>> is going to get out.
>> Sorry Raven Bloom trigger.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> There's a dragon and goes to the bottom
right.
>> Yep.
>> Okay.
>> Uh stupify
>> one of the dignitaries
>> and Raven Bloom trigger did go off. We
did see that harness dragon recycled
there.
>> Uh yeah. You did you draw off?
>> I haven't drawn yet.
>> Yeah. Yeah. You draw for stupidify.
Waiting for the draw here. And the draw
is done.
>> Damage. So I'll channel two.
>> Yeah,
>> I'll go to two.
>> Y
>> I'll draw for Kai'Sa.
>> Yeah.
>> So we get the Kai'Sa draw. We're
channeling two from the death there. And
with this pretty decent Oh, the falling
star is huge here.
>> Tapping.
>> Yeah, that's absolutely massive.
>> Leblanc fragmented
>> to the trash.
>> So really Leblanc would love to see a
glass mixologist here. We have really
great units that we could take out of
our graveyard. So, it would be really
nice to see that uh we need value here.
This is that's We have so many rooms. We
have to find value here.
>> That was quite a turn from traumatized.
>> You hold the three.
>> Yep.
>> And we have Rift Herald, which I'm
really excited to see personally. He's
really cool. Uh, as you move, you're
able to look through your top three
cards, find units, and when he dies,
also is able to summon an unit with
ignoring his energy cost, which is or
its cost, which is great.
>> So, Kai'Sa did get the rare hold. You
don't see Kai'Sa hold very often just
because she's a threat that people want
to take off the board very quickly.
>> There is the forerunner set down and
we'll probably see Kai'Sa retreat here
as well.
>> Very interesting board state here. Fious
4Runner great for holding a position
there. Um we'll have to see here what
the next play is here. Now obviously we
did get a lot of ramp from Leblanc on
that last turn
>> and Kaisa did expel a lot of resources
to wipe out the fragmented. Now I think
you're right to call out the uh the
glass mixologist. I think that's the
kind of card you want to see. You're
right about now. Bring that fragmented
back so you can continue alongside your
game plan.
>> Thank you.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah. essentially in this matchup
because Kai'Sa can remove cards over and
over again if you're are able just to
get past that onslaught at the start and
then start generating that value and the
fact that this Rift Herald here is
sticking is a could make a big
difference here. We have so many runes
that we have access to. Really, we need
to see Leblanc start really putting that
value out and start putting a little bit
pressure on Kai'Sa is only at two
points, but we need to do something here
that starts adding the pressure and
saying, "If you don't have the removal,
I'm just going to win here."
>> And uh Okay, got the trigger from the
Rift Herald here. And it's the Glass
Mythologist. That's exactly what what
they were looking for. And they did pull
it off. You saw how quickly there were
two of them in there even, but take took
that really quickly because glass
mixologist being able to get the draw in
the future from Leblanc just ensures
that you don't guess out. Most Leblancs
are only running one of the Leblancs
currently. And we also are going to get
the deceiver as well here. So, we have a
nice seven might unit here.
>> And of course, that that death now from
the uh the Rift Herald is going to be
sought after. Yep, there's a glass
mixologist.
>> Recycle order rune.
>> I can tell that the Leblanc player is
definitely in their comfort zone now. We
got the Carus as well. Oh yeah, once we
ripped the glass mixologist, we knew
that this was going to be a game in our
favor. At least that's what we're seeing
the reaction here quite a bit. Kai'Sa
has to figure out a way how to deal with
this. And the question is too is if
there is like singularity on the
sideboard that's for six a piece and
that makes these rift heralds at seven
just a lot more resistance resistant
against the Kaiser removal. So this is
looking like a great spot. Um that is
the second carus we see in the game. So
another star to be able to take out the
Carus is helpful but it just there's so
much value on the board. there is and I
mean if you get that uh the Leblanc uh
fragmented back then all of a sudden you
might be in a position start to draw
more as well get more answers but this
game is starting to look like Leblanc's
game to win and with Carus on the field
to play like even something like a
ruined Rex like if you think about what
like Kai'Sa has and the kind of uh units
that she plays that four damage death
nail is dramatically effective against
their board state. So, we'll have to see
how this plays out. Traumatized is
definitely going to have to have some
answers here. And again, like it's just
it's such a powerful board state that
LeBlanc built in just these past two
turns. And of course, with the ramp from
the uh the channelneled runes, it's like
they're just they're just ahead here.
So, we'll have to see what Traumatiz
does to try to make a stand.
>> And a big reminder that is the Aspirin's
climb. We are going to nine this game
which heavily favors Leblanc in this
position because we're at the point
where because the glass mixologist was
found we are always going to be able to
find ways to draw more cards. The only
exception would be this Kai'Sa is
running smite which has to be a tech
into these car uh specifically Leblanc
who relies on that death nail. Oh
>> unchecked power. I feel like you and I
are drawing these unchecked powers out
in these games. Is that the second or
third one we've seen? uh reflection
token.
>> Yep.
>> Yes. But the hit of blade actually makes
us not even feel that bad because you
just get to draw extra. Here we have
death nail triggers that are going to be
going off.
>> So the resolution of the spell is going
off first. So we're drawing two.
>> Um
>> I got really excited. I'm referring to
the unchecked powers from the Lilia
games we casted earlier, not from this
one here. Might have been a surprise for
everyone watching here. But uh but yeah,
that's an absolutely massive play here.
It does it does exhaust all of the units
in the base, but I think that was a very
necessary price to pay. But again, you
have those death nails coming and it's
oh my no it's hard to watch.
>> And also reacting with the sacrifice. So
we will also channel more here and draw
two. So with the Carus uh just so much
value here and this is why this deck is
favored by so many players. We don't
even have the hook. We don't even need
the hook in this case because we just
have all the value in the world.
>> That was absolutely insane. Yeah. and
Carthus coming from Origins. It's kind
of quietly sat in Origins, then quietly
sat in Spirit Forge. And whenever you
see these double effects, you're like,
eventually these double effects are
going to be relevant. They're going to
be good. And then what we got here is we
have it on full display going absolutely
crazy here. And uh those are by
Peacekeepers, too, which of course have
added value and trying to be aggressive.
Like this is this is just wild. And uh
>> and I uh love moving in the glass
mixologist here because you don't mind
if that dies. And if you don't have
another sacrifice, then you don't have a
way to control why it dies. So, he is
going to go ahead and think about this a
little bit more. But I do think the
initial thing of I want to move my glass
mixologist in here makes a lot of sense.
I love that play.
>> Uh, we'll have to see here what the
decision is. And this is a great example
as well when you're playing Leblanc
Deceiver like Flex is obviously very
well practiced. This is the kind of uh
kind of deck that, you know, it takes a
lot of mastery, a lot of time to uh play
these lines. And when you look through
these lines here, it's like you want to
start scoring these points. It is a long
way to climb to nine from three.
>> Yeah. And overall, we've seen him move
pretty quickly here because this deck
does have so much things that you have
to do. So, he is used to playing this.
Even his hand motion there to move the
bird is pretty quickly because there are
so many critical decisions with this
deck. You want to move quickly. So, you
can take your time on the critical
decisions.
>> And there is the baited hook.
>> Just a little bit more value for us if
we need it. Um, really killing this
mixologist isn't the worst thing in the
world. We might look into that. Uh,
killing a VI doesn't feel great,
although it does have a lot of six might
or less units that you could find. Um,
really finding a harness dragon here
isn't the worst thing. We did see one
get recycled earlier, so likely would
only be a chance of two in the top deck,
so that's a pretty low chance.
>> I'm going to attempt to sacrifice
>> and it is the glass.
>> So staged there. I'll resolve this
first. Okay, so we are looking for six
smite or a less here.
>> Uh we'll put uh
rift herald to that battle rift herald.
>> That's
want to cut those.
>> I resolve two of the rift out.
>> And there is fragmented coming back I
think. Yep,
>> there she is.
>> Yep.
>> Do you like drawing cards? Because if
you do, I have a card for you.
It's Leblanc fragmented.
>> Oh yes. Uh bringing her back over and
over again will be very useful,
especially if she does die in that
beginning phase, drawing two instead of
one. But uh even more with the Carus
Death Neil, of course.
>> However, drawing two seems pretty good
to us. I'm guessing we'll see it happen
at some point.
>> Okay,
>> you can see Flex trying to uh kind of uh
>> trying to figure out what he wants to do
here, knowing he has to play fast. It
isn't Aspirin's climb game.
>> So, I'm assuming there's
>> a situation if this game drags out like
they're going to they're going to hit
the time, right?
>> Well, it depends if just takes the win
here or not. I mean, we are going to
nine and we have so much value on the
board. I don't I have a hard time seeing
how Kai'Sa comes back. We do have a lot
of units on the board. We can make some
good trades. Uh Smite could do
something.
>> I mean, I I screwed up. That's fine.
>> You're fine. I'll be right back.
>> I thought about that and I was like,
"Oh, maybe." So, we are looking at the
uh
>> I'm just about
>> the baited hook here.
>> We have a judge call here.
>> Yeah.
>> So, looks like they're discussing a
prior play.
>> But yeah, like it's kind of interesting
to look at this board state. I mean, you
have the baited hook here, and it seems
like it's kind of funny. The baited hook
is like one of the engines that uh
Leblanc's trying to utilize. It's like
they don't even really need it all that
much right now. You have such a strong
board state.
>> Yes. Oh, we get to see the hand a little
bit here. We got the mirror image.
>> Uh,
>> all right.
>> Just going to have it arc
>> and we are moving back into the game.
So, mirror image, a huge tool of this
deck because you're able to copy
anything, including your opponent's
units. So, I something I like to do
sometimes is copy a Kai'Sa here and
conquer in the future. But, of course,
we can't do that quite now because we
already own this battlefield. But, the
fact that you can copy your own unit or
your opponent's unit is insane with this
card. It just offers so much value and
you potentially get the um the you know
sacrifice it too. There is just a lot of
options here. We have so much on the
board again. It must not be scared of a
second unchecked power because I'm a
little bit scared of a second unchecked
power.
>> Yeah, going all in like this is it's
something. I mean, you're basically
saying, hey, you either have the answer
or you don't because you're going to
have to try to peel all of these off for
the next several turns. And I mean
obviously you have the reflection and
like not all is lost on a reflection
dying but you do have that bottom
>> I'm going to
>> battlefield and it's going to be hex
tech ray it's going to come in and that
is going to be the carus paying the
price that makes sense right you want to
get rid of that first you don't want to
have death nails going off on
>> multi and it's thousand tail watcher and
it looks like it's accelerated as well
three across the board
>> if there were to be a punishment for
this it's thousand tail watcher um just
taking out the carus right away on top
of that so the thousand tail watcher is
the ultimate punish of just stacking
this battlefield. I do wonder what the
uh I'm trying to think of what the idea
behind it is. Maybe once some of these
units die, for example, the Leblanc
being able to draw more cards, you're
channeling more runes here. Uh really, I
think it was just more like, you know, I
had the value anyway. I I just want the
runes at this point is what it looks
like. The only one that really kind of
becomes a question there is Vi, but Vi
just adds a little bit more might
against the Forerunner. So that's
definitely the reasoning behind this.
Although is very risky into the watcher.
>> Okay, we're going into Raven Bloom and
it's going to be a solo furious 4Runner,
which is actually a cool idea cuz you're
going to get those uh those bots there
as well.
>> Um and oh, we got the trigger.
>> Dragon on the bottom.
>> Another dragon to the bottom.
>> Yeah, I'll pass. Yeah. Okay.
>> So, the good news about the hook deck
though is you don't really mind having
to put these units back because you're
playing hook. You will find them again.
>> Yeah, no kidding. And we do have a
conquer from Nefarious Fro. That was
actually, you know, that was a
surprising turn. That is the value of
Thousand Tale Watcher, a card that has
been a staple if uh if you're you're you
know, playing uh playing blue in
Riftbound. Has been since Origins and it
continues to be an absolute force to be
reckoned with. And you saw the perfect
reason why.
>> And still has more decisions to be made
here. Is tapped out. Um
>> we'll see if that Kai'Sa gets moved in
here potentially, but that that's still
at a large amount of might we have. Plus
six there. Minus three.
>> You go to five.
>> And that reflection. Is that the rift
hero?
>> I do. Uh I don't go to five quite yet.
Trigger. Um
>> F8.
>> You know that I would have
>> You passed the turn there.
>> Yes. I will let the uh I will let this
go. Um
>> we'll see what it is here soon.
>> That was a Ferris 4unner in place. So I
believe I should be getting four mechs
in base.
>> Four mechs.
>> Yes. They're all over here.
>> We'll have the mech come out here.
>> No, you got me.
>> So much was happening there. I forgot
what was reflected.
>> Uh, and then now we will hold that out
>> and then I will change
>> for So that is one of the neat things is
that you do get the death nail triggers
from the tokens and so we do get the
forerunner.
Just a lot of options here now. Didn't
get that bird death like he was hoping
to be able to channel more.
>> Now the bird's alive. Yeah, bird held.
>> Didn't get the channel run there.
>> Yep, there was no attack in, so Bird
just gets the hold.
>> Ken declined the Leblanc trigger here
for the Siver because you really don't
want to copy Bird when you will likely
have the option to conquer something
else and get something with higher might
and more value here.
>> I got to say that was a fantastic turn
from Traumatiz like we were kind of like
>> doing his eulogy there trying to figure
like what do you do? What do you And
obviously we had the unchecked power,
stuff like that. And then that was an
excellent play and it really did flip
this game back into a position where
perhaps he can make a go at trying to
kind of get back into it. And I love the
fact that he's being very patient. Could
have taken that extra could could have
taken the uh the Battlefield Aspirin's
climb, but chose not to and instead is
positioning to perhaps try to make a run
at the uh the next few turns here.
>> And also has this VI available and
looking to go ahead and go in with the
Carus as well. That's not something we
see very often here because Carthus, you
usually want to keep them safe in base.
We do know that Kai'Sa does run things
that hit at a battlefield such as Void
Seeker. We know has become more meta.
Although, like I said, those closed deck
list, it's something you'd have to make
the readum. Uh we don't see Leblanc
players going with Carus unless it's
usually mandatory.
>> That's a Round Rex. We did mention
Ruined Rex prior. Uh that is one of
those units that you don't want to see
Leblanc replicating cuz it will cause a
lot of damage. The only unit here
resilient to the effect in the death
nail of ruined Rex is going to be that
thousand tail watcher. And they're
coming back in and it is Ferious 4Runner
that's going to be stunned by the five
piece.
>> And we do have the Raven Bloom trigger.
And we saw that Nox's hopeful was the
card that was flipped over and just
recycled because it was not a spell. No
draw.
>> Copy of
Vi.
>> So Vi will be the copy that we see here
on that. So, we have five Mai, an
additional five M on the board. Thank
you for the extra die that will help us
remind us what it is.
>> Sure.
>> And it looks like we have a second
baited hook and a thousand tail watcher
>> place a ruined Rex to this battlefield.
>> Second ruined Rex comes out.
>> Um,
>> threatening a lot of power here.
>> You can cut those if they want. So, this
will dial two death.
>> So, a big hook here as the ruined Rex
will trigger twice because we have the
Carus out. will be able to do four
damage to this Kai'Sa and to the Nox's
hopeful. Yeah, which is really really
strong here. Of course, essentially
clearing out the board. However, I want
to note we are very stacked on the board
again. We do have a mech behind safely,
which I like. However, our Carthus could
potentially be in trouble here. We'll
see what happens.
>> Yeah, you definitely generally want to
try to protect that Carthus as you
mentioned prior. Um, now the thousand
tail watcher,
>> it's an awesome target. So strong.
Can't really threaten there yet, but
we'll have to see what's available to
Traumatized here.
Thinking his play through. Can't quite
see how many cards he has to take. And
it's a second,000 failed watcher.
>> The answers are coming.
>> And that is going to be that actually
might be a really big punish. Honestly,
you're going to lose your carus here.
Now, the rune rex, I mean, do you just
take out the mess? Like, it's kind of a
tricky spot to be in here. I'm going to
>> That doesn't seem too bad.
>> Um, however, the big question is Kai'Sa.
Yes, we've had Thousand Tail Washer into
Thousand Tail Washer, which is great
value. Uh, the question is, how many
cards does Leblanc have left to play?
Because the answer is probably likely a
lot. However, I believe that might be
our third Carus that we're about to lose
here because we know one was lost at the
beginning of the game and I can't
remember if this guy has stuck around or
not, but it's either the second or third
Carthus that we're losing and being able
to find that final one could be tough.
>> And if my memory serves me correctly,
that reflection is the VI. It's not the
Ruin Rex because the Ruin Rex as a
reflection would have done a little bit
more for us. And there's the hex tech.
>> Not sure what the target is yet. He's
got a lot of options.
Yeah, slots a minus three there. Uh
wouldn't be surprised if we did
potentially see it on that Rex just
because
you're talking
>> and there's a sacrifice being played
here
>> and uh the sacrifice can't be played
because it can only be on five might
units.
>> So that's why we are seeing that being
pulled back there. It's no longer
mighty.
>> It's a good call. Thousand tail watcher
doing it thing.
>> So Vi will die.
>> Yeah.
>> Um and then move to damage.
>> Sure. Move to damage.
>> Yep. Everything dies.
>> Yeah. So still
>> death nail trigger.
>> Um
>> and it looks like that thousand tail
watcher will take that conquer.
>> Wow.
>> And
>> dice is back in the game.
>> The death nail trigger for the ruined
Rex is now going off as well. So he is
deciding what he wants to kill with
that.
>> Two here.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So you do have the Carthus. You do
get two procs there.
>> So no con and
Yep. Coming on back
>> at seven. I had you at seven or I had
you at six. Six.
>> Now, it's it's also notable that
traumatized, if I remember correctly,
>> we did shout out during the the deck the
deck design stage that there was a
rocket barrage in the main and that
rocket barrage could serve as an answer
to that beta hook. Like at first we were
talking about like, oh, like you don't
even need beta hook. Look how many units
you have on here. And then all of a
sudden now that baited hook is starting
to look like a little bit more of a
valuable commodity considering the
amount of damage that traumatiz has been
able to do to the board state from flex.
Yep. And to note here, getting that six
point is very helpful because Kai'Sa has
to end this game soon or else they will
get outvalued. Absolutely. For sure. So,
they need to figure out a way to push
these next couple points. Even a double
hold doesn't do it here as we are going
to nine. I'm, you know, a little bit
concerned about the uh mech here.
Obviously, this is kind of tipping the
hand of like no third Thousand Tail
Watcher is what this is showing. On top
of that, if we were to play Thousand
Tail Watcher accelerated, we would have
to have two more blue runes as our
trigger or as our channel as well.
>> That's a good shout out. Actually, the
amount of thousand tails that have
already been played have completely
blown up the blue runes available here.
And mirror image of Thousand Tailed
Watcher is being played here. A good
option.
>> And then I will
>> Yep. And it is ready.
>> So, we're going for you know advantage
here on a trade. Yep. Uh, I'll score a
seven. Y discard a watchful sentry. Make
a copy.
>> Also, on top of this, I love the make
the copy here and the uh the baited
hook. We'll be able to find seven or or
eight or less here.
>> And oo, that is a bit of a whiff. We
have glass mixologist, which isn't bad.
So, that will have to be, you know, that
pretty much has to be it here because
the other ones just aren't really good
enough for it. glass mixologist will be
able to make sure that we can get
Leblancs back and have more card draw.
So essentially we won't run out of cards
in this which is very helpful as well.
But there isn't too much gas left in the
tank for the Kai'Sa deck.
>> So we do have the Raven Bloom
Conservatory proc there. It was a
>> Yortal. So no spell for Kaisa. It would
have been a little I mean he is tapped
out but
>> would have been nice to get a spell.
>> It's always nice to draw cards.
Now, Flex is threatening to close out
the game on the the hold of the next
turret here. We're going to need some
accelerate. We're going to need some uh
>> some removal here. So, we'll have to see
what Traumatize can do. I mean, I don't
want to count them out because every
single time I've been like, well, it
looks like Traumatize is in trouble. He
found a way.
>> Yes. And we'll have All right, there it
is. And then I just
>> Flex on Leblanc does take victory here.
And I got to tell you, I got to give
full credit to Traumatiz. That was like
one of those games where Alo could have
been counted out at any time and then he
just kept finding a way to claw back
into the match and unfortunately Leblanc
had such an amazing mid game that it was
very hard to catch up.
>> Yeah, really once Leblanc gets online
there's no stopping her. I mean big
thing in that game is once we saw that
glass mixologist we saw that instant
pick of the excitement and then moving
very quickly because the glass
mixologist is what mattered the most
there to really make sure that engine
kept on going. Yeah, and that those
thousand tailed watchers honestly were
absolutely incredible. And you're right
to call out too that like you're
utilizing all those blue runes so
rapidly that even if he top deck the
third, he didn't really have an answer,
but honestly those board states were so
aggressively pitted against traumatized,
but the thousand tailed Watcher allowed
him to once again push in, take control
of the game, and fight back. I mean, the
game looked like it was so far gone and
he found ways to consistently compete,
which honestly, I think that's a great
lesson for for riftbound players
watching cuz it's one of those things
like you might be want like, "Oh, well,
I'm going to scoop. Look at this.
Leblanc's popping off." But it's like at
the end of the day, like there are ways
to claw yourself back into a game.
>> And I just want to note the amount of
value that Leblanc can generate. We saw
unchecked power, thousand tail watcher
with a lot of value and 20,000 tail
watcher with a lot of value multiple
times. And Leblanc was like, "Do I
actually really care about these? I get
some runes. I get some draw. This game
looks pretty good for me still. It just
generates so much value. And that's what
we said. These control list uh they have
a really tough time into it unless you
are able to get them from the get-go and
never let them establish themselves on
the board.
>> And now let's take it to the desk where
they're going to be interviewing Adulan
who won on Leblanc.
I'm joined here by our other feature
match winner that we had the pleasure of
watching and of course the great
commentating as well. I've got Dulon
here from team Flex Slot as we want to,
you know, of course, showcase some more
of these teams. And you're playing a
wonderful deck that we've already seen
and have been talking about, Leblanc,
specifically on that baited hook
variant. And the best thing that we
really want to talk about and what I
want to ask you is there are other
versions of this deck that are running
around.
>> Why this one? As we saw baited Hook be
the most successful version of Leblanc,
at least in Sydney regional qualifier a
couple weeks ago, but there are other
versions. And do you think this deck is
strong enough to maybe take down the
whole tournament? Uh, I'll answer that
last question first. Absolutely. This
deck is unbelievably good. Um, I may be
on team flex slot, but I do want to give
a shout out to Challenger TCG, uh, Dan
and Colin who put into work to the
Leblanc guide. Uh, I learned a lot from
that guide as well. You know, I got to
got to respect the other the other
teams. Um, as for why the hook variant
um has kind of ended up being the
default version. Early on, people were
very excited uh about Leblanc, but as a
result, a lot of people built their
decks to hate it. A lot of the purple
decks have access to a lot of early
disruption, you know, to prevent you
from copying your your birds and your
watchful centuries with Gust.
>> Yeah.
>> Um the Leblanc Hook version is a lot
more resilient to those hate pieces. Um
and the the endgame of that deck is nigh
unbeatable, whereas the other versions
have like a more mid-rangey lower cur
like lower top end. Um, so as long as
those decks are not able to rush you
with aggro or something like that, they
are simply never going to beat you. I
think the only deck in the format that
really can go over the top of it is
Aurora and even then. So I yes, I do
believe uh it is the best version and I
actually would say it is the best deck.
>> Wow. I mean that that is a bold
statement and of course you're doing so
well currently in the tournament so
you're on your way to kind of do that
here in Vancouver. But you say it not
only like helps you like maybe bring up
some of the weaknesses of the other
version of Leblanc by implementing the
sort of extra level of the deck, but it
also maybe makes it a little more
susceptible do you think? Because people
are playing gear hate. They are afraid
of things like Aurora. Is baited hook.
The real question here is is baited hook
that important of the deck for it to
function in case you run into something
like other people's salvages. Do you
think the deck maybe can stabilize a
little bit better even if you don't find
it or it gets removed? Uh, so the answer
to that is that baited hook is is what
makes you you makes your engine work at
a,000% capacity, but no, you do not you
do not need that. You have extremely
powerful tools in your legend. Even just
copying a a uh I always want to say
riptide rex, the origins unit, but if
you copy a ruined Rex, you don't even
need baited hook. You can just let it
die and destroy all of your opponent's
creatures. Um, and I, you know, you can
time your baited hook to where you can
play it and get an activation before
they salvage it or something like that.
Um, absolutely not. And that's really
what makes this deck so hard to beat
because you cannot attack this deck
solely with gear hate. Um, you cannot
attack it solely with trash hate or
death nail hate, which doesn't even
really exist. So
>> smite, that's like the big one.
>> Smite. My opponent was on Kai'Sa and
they cighted in smite. They did not see
any copies. But those are the the deck
is too multifaceted. It is too hard to
attack it on one angle.
>> And like you said, believe it to be
strong enough to take down the entire
tournament. So my last question here
kind of almost bring it back with your
team. So I mean you already think it's
the strongest deck in the room. Do you
have more people here that are kind of
representing that deck or when you guys
are kind of play testing, is this where
you settle on, you know, with the sort
of collaboration with Daniel or is it
you know playing other decks and
challenger getting some extra context?
Are you all kind of like sporting and
piloting this deck or are some of you
also maybe looking for some bests?
>> Um, I wouldn't say that we are here for
best ofves. We are we are here to win
the tournament. I personally am hunting
my qualifications still. I came off a
931 in Atlanta. I was one match off. So
I I like to play the best deck. I I was
I was like this throughout all three
sets so far. I think LeBlanc Hook is the
best deck and it'll give me the best
chance to potentially win the
tournament.
>> And you are well on your way to do that.
Zulan, thank you so much for this
interview. very insightful as we always
want to kind of get into the minds of
the players who pilot such an incredible
time on the feature matches. So, I wish
you luck. Don't go anywhere though. We
got some more action. So, we're going to
send it back.
Yeah, that game was absolutely amazing.
I'm glad to hear that, you know, he is
committed to try to win the tour. It's
not just about best, which I mean, I
love best. If I was in here, I'd be
playing some best of Teemo, I think, or
at least going for it. But yeah, that
match was absolutely incredible. Good
luck in the future rounds. And on that
note, we got more Riftbound coming,
including round four after this break.
I'm joined here with the wonderful
Randy. You know, Randy, I'll be honest.
I've seen you at all these events
recently, but I have yet to sit here and
talk to you in quite a long time. So,
first of all, Randy, how are you feeling
right now as you have now just won and
you're now moving on still undefeated in
the current tournament. How are you
feeling?
>> Uh I'm feeling pretty good. Pretty good.
Very tired from the jet lag, but uh
yeah, feeling very good about this
weekend. Much better than uh the last
three weekends. So I
>> I'm kind of the same. The the coming
back from Sydney was a lot. So uh but
I'm glad you're doing well in the
tournament. And speaking of the
tournament, you are one of the players
I've seen jump between quite a lot of
debts decks in general. You were on
Fiora just two weeks ago in Sydney, and
now you're on Ireelia, the deck that has
just one. I'm interested to hear your
take on why the sudden change and in
general how does your sort of like
testing go on what makes you make a
decision on what to bring to the event.
>> Um I kind of played what I whatever I
feel like I want to play. Uh I only play
strong decks. I try to only pick like
actual decks that could win the event
because that's kind of what I'm looking
for. So I will not go for like purely
best of decks. Um I was on Leblanc at
the start of the set. I just feel like
it's not strong enough. So I decided to
to move off Leblanc. I think it's very
good, but I don't think it's like at the
very top top. Uh, so I was interested in
a few decks. I was interested set Diana
Aurelia and then my friend were prepping
uh Fiora as well and uh we kind of
decided to wing Fiora for Sydney. We got
we thought it had a good match up into a
good match up into Aelia. Turns out none
of us play into any of those decks. We
just play into completely random stuff
and we just got crushed. Um got very
close to best of the three of us. So
that was kind of the idea for Sydney.
Then I played the Chinese regional last
week and I brought Diana. I thought
Diana was a lot of fun. I hadn't played
Diana yet. And um Alan is on Diana
friend teammate. So uh it it does feel
kind of wrong to like contest each other
for the best stuff. So that's kind of
how I pick. I decided between a few good
decks and uh I just take whatever I
think is much stronger if there is
something uh I feel like taking if I
really feel strong about the deck or
whatever doesn't contest my friends so
we can all have a shot at the best of
and all do well at the same time. Um
yeah so I like I like changing I like
change because I play so much of this
game all day every day that uh two weeks
before the release I'm already like 300
game on Tulong. So, at some point, like
>> I I I am I I am not one of those guys
who can play a full set on one deck.
>> And I think that's such a good skill to
have for a lot of players because, you
know, I think playing multiple different
decks and being able to swap on the fly
doesn't just make you better in general
as a player, but makes you really good
and prepared about the mentality of the
players when you play against those
decks as well. So, I think that's a
great skill to have. We've seen you be
proficient at it. Now, of course, now
you're playing Ireelia. I heard though
that you are still trying to kind of
avoid the Aurora decks in the room. I
know you don't really want to run into
them. I know you were even mainboarding
the rake, you know, to like kind of
prepare for that stuff, but speak to
that a little bit. I know you don't
really want to run into those decks
right now.
>> Um, yeah, I think Aura is pretty good
into it's not lost by any means. Like
you can still win. You're just
unfavored. Um, it's just that there is
not a lot of play against Aura. It's
just like if they have it, they just
have it and you can't do anything about
it. So, I'd rather face matchup where I
have some play. Uh like the Darius is
clearly unfavored for me, but um I still
have a lot of room for play. So it's it
feels much better losing to a Darius
than an aura, even though it never feels
good losing obviously, but um that's why
I prefer avoiding Zoras as much as I
can.
>> Well, and we'll kind of speak to that
cuz you just played that match against
that Darius deck and I was a little
worried there for him as he was, you
know, game two was, you know, we missed
the trigger. We chose to go second. I
want to ask you about that soon. But we
on Arena's greatest, chose to go second
and he had he had this, you know, the
salvage being very strong. You didn't
have an answer to it. Your hand was a
little rough in that game. But then in
game three, he kind of did still hit you
with a pretty difficult puzzle where he
killed off the scuttle crab shows you
he's got two call the weeks plays them
both and you've now lost your Ireelia
that you have. Luckily, you had another
one which kind of solidified you that
game because he was so far behind in
runes. But like you did luckily have an
answer in that game whereas game two,
you didn't. But you know, it's okay to
drop a game or two as you kind of know.
But my question is, I hear you do
believe that going first is kind of
overrated. Can you kind of speak to that
a little?
>> Um, yeah. I I don't feel like so about
about him choosing to go second. It's
just Darius. I think he wanted to kind
of go for like two units or accelerate
something
>> to try and go go for more points. So
that's probably why with a uh was it
Tons? No, it wasn't Targon, but yeah. So
I think that's why he choose to as going
second in general. I think right now a
lot of champions are like three cost for
Diana for example, five cost for
Aurelia. So you can kind of curve into
those anyway when you're going second.
So I don't think going first matters as
much in a lot of matchups. In some cases
it does against a much more aggressive
deck. Um but I think going first is not
as important that people think. I think
if you lose a dice it's not that big of
a deal. Um that's that's kind of where I
come from and where the stakes come
from.
>> That makes a ton of sense. But Randy,
you're off to a great start here at the
Vancouver regional qualifier. You play
so much Riftbound. you changed so many
decks and we're excited to hopefully see
you in the future rounds of this
tournament. But for now, good luck and
thank you so much. We're going to send
it back. See,
>> all right, we are back and we're trying
to keep these rounds quick. We're
already in round four, almost halfway
through the day. How you doing, Ersa
Day?
>> I am having so much fun. I mean, all
these matches has been awesome. Even
watching the Darius versus the Ireelia
last round in the back, I watched the
Darius choose to go second one game and
I was mind blown.
>> Yeah, and I know you're jealous that we
saw some Leon gameplay, right?
Definitely one of your uh legends of
choice was able to squeak it out, too.
So, in a good running so far.
>> Yeah, I mean, it seems to be I mean,
it's 1 and0 on stream so far. I think
that's a good start to maybe beating all
of you guys to having the correct
champion, the correct uh legend to win
the entire tournament.
>> Yeah, and we're just going to sneak into
our first game. Uh we're going to see a
new legend I don't think we've seen on
stream yet. Let's look at the deck list.
>> All right, we've got Poppy here. One of
the new legends has a when hold ability,
you gain one XP and when you spend
three, you can get a draw one. So, draw
cards have been pretty popular. And uh
we are seeing Aurora. I think this is
the first Aurora deck we've seen on
stream today. Am I wrong?
>> I think so, actually, which is very
surprising, but I think this is an
awesome one to start with. Uh, Poppy is
such I mean, I think she's really
interesting. And also, the player is
such a good pilot. He's done really well
in multiple different tournaments, many
like grassroots Nove has won. Uh, and he
also has a best of Civer, I believe,
back from set 2
>> for sure. And we haven't seen as much of
order for it, but I think it's a good
choice. Uh we do have stuff like the
Rift Herald which is really good. Also
the harness dragon there being able to
uh just get a kill on play is super
strong. So uh it just means that you
know obviously Elder Dragon is a very
good pick but we've got some good
backups which I think sometimes the
chaos version doesn't have as often.
>> Yeah, I think there's a lot of great
backups with this. I was actually
talking to Veggie about this list before
the uh tournament. He was telling me
this Elder Dragon is the card to watch
for when it comes to his Aurora. He said
that he really likes playing it and
watching things go boom basically.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Uh but you can see really here even on
this list with the Aurora.
>> I mean, it's six dragons. So, I
definitely think that he is excited
hopefully to hit and planning to hit the
dragons with this dazzling aurora for
sure.
>> All right, so that's our first side. On
the other side, we've got him with their
build of Diana. We've seen Diana already
today. So, obviously one of the uh you
know, the deck I think actually I'm I'm
hoping to win this event. Uh, but you
know, we've seen so many variances with
it. I think that Diana has a lot of
cards in its pool that you can really
pick and choose the ones that make
sense.
>> Yeah, I mean, between these two uh
domains, I think there's fantastic cards
that you can pick from. Obviously, a
little bit different from the one that
we watched earlier. I'm looking at both
Vex's in this list, which is really
interesting to me. And I mean, VEX
cheerlist we saw a lot of in set two.
We've seen less of it today, but still
super important and super strong that
when it is in combat, she affects how
the costs of spells go versus Apathetic,
who is just the stun if she's at a
battlefield.
>> Yeah, for sure. And I think another
decision point card for us is the Frigid
Jewel. It's a new card here uh from uh
Unleashed. And so it's a gear as well.
So when you draw your second card each
turn, you get a friendly unit, a plus
two, which is pretty easy for us to get
an extra draw. and works really well
with Hoe. Hoe has three different
abilities and you know having a flex
into the gear one being able to ready up
to two more runes if you need it. Uh
just having that in your wheelhouse of
options I think is really strong.
>> Yeah, that makes a lot of sense and that
seems like such a strong thing. We love
resources. We love more having more
runes and opening up that option just
seems really smart.
>> Definitely. So, we're ready to go. Let's
get into it. It's going to be Poppy
versus Diana round four and let's see
what happens. This is going to be so
exciting.
>> All right, there we go. We do have uh
two matches as well. We're going to see
if we're going to be able to get to our
second one as well. But again, we are
going to be looking at Nove running
Poppy uh versus himy who's going to be
on Diana.
>> Yeah, Nove is a part of team TSS, which
is a new team that's been popping up in
Riftbound about the last month. So
really exciting to see how Noveil
of the Storm really helpful for, you
know, trying to slow down your opponent,
right? As the Aurora deck, you get more
and more value the later the game goes.
And then on the right side for him,
we've got the Raven Bloom Conservatory
again.
>> Yeah, and we saw it play so well earlier
as with Diana. Um, so I'm really excited
to see how these two do because
obviously Aurora does have a lot of
spells in it. Um, a little bit different
type of spells obviously, but you get to
have a lot fewer units in this deck
because of Aurora, for sure.
>> All right, is gonna start off with the
uh tide turner there. Uh, just a very
good turn uh one play and moving back to
no veggies has the three runes and again
this is I think our at least our first
Aurora deck for us today, right? And uh
you know it does play a little bit
different than I'd say most typical uh
lists in uh Riftbound here.
>> Yeah, Aurora is really interesting. I
mean you the main game plan is to get
your Aurora out and running. So a lot of
this early game is going to probably be
trying to get more runes, more cards,
make sure that we have Aurora when we
hit that number of runes that we need.
>> Uh and so we're going to see them start
going through these and build up these
resources, getting that gold and
hopefully putting him making them slow
enough at least to be able to get to
that turn where Aurora comes into play.
>> Yeah. And we use the blood money there.
So, not only is it able to prevent the
point there, but does get us the the
gold as mentioned, you know, analog to
like Gust on the Chaos side. Something
that you really get to use and take
advantage of for order, including Cole
the week here to get rid of the Diana
just stopping any kind of momentum might
have in these first couple turns.
>> Yeah, I think this is where Poppy's
extra domain really comes into play.
Cold the week is so nice, especially
when you don't have any units yourself,
so you don't have to pay that cost. Uh
but making sure that Timothy's units
stay off the board while we hopefully
get set up for the Zora.
>> Yeah. And it's nice because again that
blood money did generate gold gear so we
don't even have to lose any runes for
it. So I'd say a pretty solid start for
Nove
trying to do.
>> Yeah. I mean it's such an interesting
take on Aurora because obviously it's a
lot of times I feel like it's order.
>> Yes.
>> Uh order is what you like don't want to
see as Aurora. Mhm.
>> So, it's very interesting as it being a
part of this Poppy list.
>> Yeah. And another thing too that uh I
I've noticed for Poppy as a Aurora deck
compared to others is that our champion
unit does not recycle anything, right?
Doesn't have a power cost associated
with it. So, in a turn like this, you
don't mind just playing it out. You get
some interaction with it later on. And
uh yeah, again, when you care about
getting to nine runes as fast as
possible, having all these ways to, you
know, prevent or mitigate power cost is
really nice. Yeah, it's almost needed,
especially when we're already on these
odd runes because we went second that
you really have to stay away from paying
power if you can.
>> All right, so we're going to use the
blood money once again trying to get out
of another battle here, but we're going
to respond with the star cross. So, uh
you do have the ability to return the
poppy to hand here. So, really nice.
>> Yeah, that'll be nice to get at least
something back ourselves and set maybe
no veggies back as well. just keep
>> Oh, I thought do it have to be the same
sleeves.
>> All right. And
>> no,
only when it goes
>> think Oh, we're just replacing the uh
the champion unit. Sure. Yeah.
>> Yeah, makes sense.
>> I for some reason thought No, it would.
>> So, we will see here. Tide Turner going
back to hand as well. We'll be able to
play it later, which is kind of nice
with Tide Turner, honestly, because Tide
Turner does have an ability that allows
you to swap positions with another unit.
Uh so, we can still rehness that ability
later. I didn't bring a finish.
>> All right, so we do have the Raven
Bloom. We're moving it there. Uh and
yeah, this will be this will be the
first point of the game, which you know,
we've had uh some pretty fast games, I
think, already today, but you know, 5
minutes in only getting her first point
already is a bit of an of an anomaly.
>> Yeah, definitely different from some of
the quicker games we saw earlier. Um
though, I will say obviously Raven Bloom
student taking the first point at Raven
Bloom Conservatory, it speaks for
itself. It's a great moment. Yeah,
>> I will just quickly note I actually love
the plushy on Nove.
>> Oh, yeah. It's a poy.
>> Yeah, I did see that during our uh our
intro there. That's very fun. So, uh you
know, obviously wrapping the deck, you
want to make sure that you are fully in
there and yeah, making sure that we've
got those same sheets of paper just to
confir. I mean, again, we just scored
our first point, so not not a regular to
notice until now that we didn't have it,
but Raven Bloom's going to get that
point there. We've got five runes left
for Diana. To me, that means that
there's potential for her. Like, I think
most cards cost five or less for Diana.
So, so many options for us right now.
>> Yeah, so many options. Diana has a lot
she could do, but definitely I think
Diana's game plan of hopefully getting
in early here is not working the best.
No veggies, their whole game plan till
they hit nine is to slow this match
down. And you can even see that as you
said in that battlefield. So, it seems
like we are definitely more on Nove
timeline that he wants than him right
now.
>> Yeah. And we play out the Vex here. Uh I
I think this is a perfect time to play
it. Uh because we are very good for when
we have to force a combat, we get this
ability. Uh and it's nice to have it on
the board.
>> Yeah, that is for sure. It does look
like we are coming up onto those nine
runes. So, it's going to be an important
moment to find out if we actually do
have Aurora. It does look like Diana is
at zero runes untapped here, but she
does in a showdown still have the
legend ability.
>> Yes. Yeah. And so, uh, we are not seeing
the Aurora. And I think that's the only
like, you know, one of the things you
have to choose between like order and
chaos. Chaos is a little bit better at
finding the, uh, the Aurora. But, you
know, order has a lot of ways to be
interactive without losing, you know,
your ramp to it. But, uh, that is going
to be the Poppy replayed right there.
And then we are also going to play Forge
of the Future to be able to get out a
uh, unit. Again, having a non-unit that
plays unit is really good because it
does get around kind of Aurora's
finding, you know, the smaller body.
Yeah, that's a great point. You really
don't want to hit some of those smaller
bodies off of Aurora just because it
already costs so much. You really want
to hit big uh big units that do a lot of
damage or really can affect the field in
some way. So, really nice to have some
of these units that do make them just
like you're saying
>> for sure. So, uh we're passing back to
him. We're at two points thanks to the
uh Raven Bloom hold there. And we've got
uh some pretty strong choices again uh
with the battlefield there. Uh if we do
end up uh conquering it, we will have to
recycle a rune. So, we've gone to I
think late into the game that it's not
as uh debilitating, but you know, you
love your runes, right? You want to keep
them when you can.
>> Yeah, I definitely don't want to lose
any runes if I don't have to. Does look
like we are going to be seeing last
rights come down on the Diana side. This
is a gear from the spirit forge set and
honestly, I think it did so much for a
lot of different decks. In this case,
when you equip it, you also recycle two
cards from your trash back to your deck,
which can be really interesting and does
give plus two, which is really nice.
>> Yeah. And uh with it, you know, when I
conquer hold, you can play a unit from
your trash. So, uh we still have that
Diana there. So, we could put the last
rights on the Vex. We can attack into uh
the battlefield there. And now that
we've conquered it, we can not only one
recycle it, but we will be able to
potentially get there. And on the uh
reaction to that, we will be sacrificing
uh our Poppy to get a draw to and
hopefully try to get a little bit deeper
into our Aurora.
>> Yeah, it seems like we're definitely
lacking in an Aurora right now, which
Dazzling Aurora is the card that this
entire deck is built around. If you
have, you know, if you wait too late in
game, you can draw some of those big
units that you really don't want to be
playing for full cost from hand. Uh so
we need to find it as quickly as
possible and obviously to get things
running as well.
>> Yeah. And well the biggest thing is yeah
the elder dragon here. So normally
you're stuck at nine runes. It's hard to
get to 12 to play it but because we used
that sacrifice we went from 9 to 10 and
then going to 12 the start of the turn.
We've got three units in three spaces.
And uh looks like we're going to try to
gus the student back to hand but the Vex
and the Diana are going back into the
trash.
>> Wow. That was a huge elder dragon coming
down there. as you said, not um killing
all of those different units. We kind of
did save the one. Uh but we still are
going to have to play runes next turn to
be able to play it again.
>> Yeah. And also something to notice, you
know, no veggies could have used that
sacrifice at any o moment, but waited
until him if he has kind of overextended
a little bit, made sure that there's a a
unit on each location.
>> Going from 9 to 10 means that, you know,
the again the Elder Dragon is a play on
this next turn. Yeah, it was a really
great move by Noveggies. Really getting
to I mean use every part of the Elder
Dragons ability. We'll have to see how
Diana can come back from this because I
mean we're just starting to build mine
up now on Nove side and it's just going
to continue.
>> Yeah, but it looks like we're going to
play out the Fizz. Uh which uh looks
like I think they thought they had the
star cross in their trash, but
unfortunately uh you know that was
recycled with the last right. So, uh,
Gust still is a great play here and it
might have been the play that they were
hoping for. Uh, but we've seen so much
Fizz Star crossed already. Would have
been a great way to answer the Elder
Dragon if we had it available to us.
>> Yeah. And sadly, Gus does get capped
out, I believe, at three, Mike.
>> Yes, Elder Dragon is just a little bit
more uh powerful than that.
>> Just a little bit. So, it was not able
to deal with that Elder Dragon, but at
least we do get to take that token off
of the Raven Bloom Conservatory. Yeah,
because uh it's it's a minor thing, but
also, you know, poppies gains that XP
from holding, right? So, uh you know,
offering less chances for XP is fine. I
don't think this build particularly
cares about the XP, but it is a a little
minor ad.
>> Yeah, very true. Very true. Uh it does
look like Dana though was able to really
start building out that base again. We
have three units and we're kind of being
safe here by holding them all in our
base. we aren't allowing it to be spread
out to different battlefields where if
another Elder Dragon somehow appeared
either through Aurora or something else,
I really wouldn't get to use it in the
same way.
>> Yeah. So, we're using the catalyst of
Aons to go from 10 to 12, which
generally wouldn't matter if you're
going to 12 again next turn, but we are
going to use the mobilize to then get
the draw one since we were at full runes
and we're going to use the sabotage. So,
uh choice there between our frigid jewel
and uh yeah, we're not going to get that
one out of hand.
>> Yeah, sabotage is so nice to take out.
some of these nonunit cards from your
opponent's hand. Also giving you so much
information about what they have. In
this case, obviously Timothy only had
two cards, but you're able to really
find out like is there something that
could happen next turn? What is there?
And then also like as they draw, you
know, you kind of have an idea what they
could have drawn
>> and what they will need to draw to do
that play that you think they might
have.
>> Yeah. But getting the uh the Eclipse out
of hand like that could be a great way
for you to try to get rid of the elder
dragon. Uh you know last rides can still
be used cuz we kind of have a free
conquer on the other side right now. A
little bit freer at least. So there
could be a way for us to play something
but we are going to recycle one uh with
the last rights and try to equip it to
uh one of our looks like it's going to
be the student.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. All right. And as you said, if you
do conquer a battlefield with a unit
that has last rights attached to it, you
then are able to bring back a unit. So,
it looks like we are potentially looking
at what unit we may want to bring back.
But first, we do have to decide that
recycling.
>> Yeah. And uh we might have to uh update
our champion sleeve again to put it back
into uh our deck there.
>> So,
>> both of our players have had to update
their sleeves now.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's funny. Yeah. We
you're used to just, you know, champion
zone, uh, battlefield, and trash, but
when there's so much interaction right
now, uh, you know, they can end up in so
many different situations.
>> Yeah, for sure. Though, I do actually
love having like a different lead color
for my uh for my legend or my chosen
champion.
>> I've been uh I've I've been so close to
uh getting game losses and warnings due
to uh
>> with with having the same sleep. So, I I
completely understand. Yeah. Especially,
you know, when when legends have been
uh, you know, when you get different
champions that you can use for the same
deck, too, you need to make sure that
you choose the right one. So, we
>> we do get the last rights on the student
there. Uh, currently has five might or
sorry, four might, but can have a fifth
if we play a spell.
>> We set up and it does look like we are
going to be moving up into that sigil of
the storm with last right. We'll try to
play this, but I'm going to take note of
score first.
>> And looks like, yeah, we're going to go
to four points here. So, halfway there.
Uh, and then, yeah, we do have to
recycle a rune. We also do have to uh
pay for this. We I do believe we have
one floating already from the attach for
the last right. So,
>> yeah, I believe that is remembered.
>> And then, uh, yeah, recycling one
>> for that. And I think we need to recycle
one from the sigil with the storm as
well.
>> I'll trigger Poppy's ability to gain XP.
>> So it does seem like we are explicitly
generating the XP though coming into
Nove's uh side. So I wonder if there's
some use for it,
>> but we will have to see. And we do have
that XP card come down.
>> Yeah. So yeah, three three is quite a
bit. Uh I do know that uh I think body
does have a lot of ways to generate XP
though. So, I don't recall anything
particularly in the deck, but you know,
maybe in the side deck as well, we could
see in the future, but you know, being
able to have access to a draw one when
clearly we need to see the Aurora more
often, uh, ends up being pretty huge.
>> Yeah, for sure.
And I mean, hopefully we will find that
Aurora. It is, I still believe, on
Diana's side here, so we'll see what
they
do.
>> Yeah, so they do have the three points.
Well, another Elder Dragon. Uh ouch
>> offers a lot of answers here. So
choosing the Vex and the student there.
Last rights does fall off.
>> Um
>> yeah, what a yeah strong strong card
here. I mean it's the same as playing
Aurora with just a couple extra steps I
think. Right.
>> Yeah, just a couple extra future
>> or a little fewer as well.
>> Fewer fewer. Yeah, you know what? You're
right. Yeah, fewer steps. So just a
little bit more recycling. But uh we
also do get to use the uh forge of the
future effect. So, we will be able to
recycle cards into uh their deck here as
well. So, that means that it's going to
be really tough to put two cards in the
trash to equip last rights again.
>> Yeah, that's a great point. Uh
>> okay,
>> so few cards left in that trash pile.
>> It is so surprising we still have not
found Aurora. Obviously, the decks built
around it. Playing these Elder Dragons
does not feel the best from hand, but it
seems like we're doing pretty well even
without Aurora. Even though a lot of
times when we talk about Aurora, we say
without it, these decks seem to pull
apart.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And I will say that Diana
hasn't really seen a Hawaii yet.
>> That's something where if you let that
get value, it just continually, you
know, runs away with the game. But, uh,
you're still like, yeah, both both
players are like keeping each other
honest, I feel like.
>> Yeah, that's very true. We haven't seen
Ho yet, but I think Noveis has done a
great job at trying to keep some of
these different units that Himathy is
playing
>> like under wraps like the the Vex that
keeps getting played keeps getting
killed. Now does it second time dying.
>> So we are trying to use these other
dragons to make sure that him can't get
some of these units out. That may really
affect the battle.
>> Yeah. And uh we're going to be playing
four for the Vax Seir and then an extra
two to play out the Frigid Jewel which
has been in hand for a good amount of
this game. But it will offer uh a plus
two might as long as we get a second
draw cuz draw will count towards the
first draw.
>> Nice.
>> Yeah. And I think we only have one card
left in hand here, but we have seen that
frigid drill in hand since the salvage
earlier.
>> Mhm.
>> Not salvage, sabotage.
>> Sabotage. Yes. Yeah. Yeah. And uh we are
at 10 runes currently. Uh we're going to
uh you know
>> make sure that we get the energy for it
and also recycle it off of the uh
conquer there. We are going to pay one
for a Gust to put the Fizz back in hand.
Uh could play the uh you know the Gust
again next turn. Not that it's going to
be readily activating these or you know
interacting with these elder dragons,
but this is an intimidating board that
Nove's been able to make.
>> Yeah, this is very intimidating. I'm not
sure what I would do facing off two
different of these elder dragons on both
battlefields as him, but I do like the
idea of Gust bringing that Fizz back in
hand where you can use the Fizz's
ability when you play it again later.
That being said, as you mentioned, the
Gus is the only thing in in the discard
pile right now. So, do we want to use
Gus? I'm not fully sure.
>> Yeah, and we're playing out the Vanguard
Armory. So, uh I I've seen some like
Victor decks play this, right? Uh since
there are some ways to get this out a
little bit earlier, too. Uh but just
being able to have a gear that lets you
play se three one-1 recruits uh ends up
being like really important here. Uh
especially because you know generally
speaking cold of the week is a good card
against us. So uh this lets us kind of
change uh how we're using it right.
We're able to you know one have some
protection against cold of the week
because we have these other cards that
we can choose for it and then also it's
good if we're using cold the week
against our opponents too. Yeah, that's
a great point. And even earlier, you
really hit on it where Aurora, you don't
want to have too many units in your deck
such that you might hit something else.
And because it's a gear, you're not
going to have a unit to hit with Aurora.
Yeah.
>> So, you can safely then generate these
recruit tokens, still have these smaller
units on your board without being at the
risk that Aurora is going to hit a one
might unit instead of your 12 might
elder dragon.
>> Yeah. And uh himy's at two cards. It's
open knowledge that one of them is Fizz.
Uh we do find the Hawaii maybe a little
bit late here, but uh we'll see if it's
enough to get something going. Uh no
movement currently available to it, I
believe. But it is going to be nice and
just a way to activate our frigid jewels
moving forward.
>> Uh trigger poppy.
>> Let's see here what they're able to do
with it, though. I would love to see I
mean obviously Nove has really started
out this game like he wants, but him is
still at four points, right? still
I mean Hawai
I believe seven points going into this
turn. Uh we also get 2 XP so Poppy can
actually use it uh 3 XP ability to get a
draw one which uh is really appreciated
right uh and yeah it's going to be
difficult to I think interact with
>> either not to mention both of these
battlefields.
>> Yeah, very true. Hopefully this draw
does help us find Aurora, but it does
seem like we don't need it this game.
>> Yeah, we have, I think, gotten to a good
point. Uh I will not look away at a draw
right here. We'll definitely take it.
And I think we've got 11 runes currently
since we recycled one for the armory.
So, uh no third elder dragon, but maybe
a roar, but the ruin nation
>> kills all units.
>> Okay,
>> that's going to be an exciting card to
see here.
>> Respond to my ruination.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I mean when you look
at it like man, you're already so far
ahead. Why would you kill all units, but
you have the ability to create three
more here. Uh you know that your
opponent only has one card in hand
again. I believe it's Fizz as well. Uh
looks like we also are going to react
with sacrifice here too. So it does
offer us a way to get some uh runes back
as well. Uh and a draw two.
And there goes there goes the board. But
again, we still do have our armory to
set up three more. Um, and yeah, I think
I think we're okay with this trade
because it really really slows down a
lot of what they're trying to do.
>> Yeah, I think that's a good point. And I
have to wonder if
>> cuz you mentioned Hawaii finally coming
out to play. Obviously, Timothy is also
getting a pretty wide base set up as
well, but we took them all out with that
ruination. It did risk some of our own
units, but
>> it kind of shows like we are
prioritizing making sure that him can't
get set up at all. And we do have those
three units. Like you said, we got those
two points this turn and we only need
one more point to win.
>> Yeah, but like right here, uh, you know,
we're playing another Hoy. I mean, we we
got lucky. Uh, I think we just drew that
off the top as well. I think it's still
Fizz in hand, right? It could maybe get
like a Gust to get rid of one of these
tokens, but you got no cards in hand for
him, and there's just going to be two
recruits to take both these
battlefields. This might be our entrance
to game number two.
>> All right.
>> Interesting to see what they choose to
do, but yeah, it seems like a difficult
spot. Looks Oh,
>> yeah. Which which crew do you like the
least? Yeah. Yeah. Making sure. Yeah,
sure. We'll play the Fizz, but uh yeah,
not going to be enough. And we're going
to game number two. Veggie taking that
first one.
>> Yeah. Fantastic job by Nove. I mean,
again, we were able to win the whole
match. Noah Aurora to be seen. I mean,
and him did a really great job though
trying to get in, trying to get some
early points if they could, but kind of
stalled out. Wasn't able to get in.
>> Yeah. And you know the the ruin nation
felt you know you lost more might from
the ruin nation right you lost two elder
dragons for it but I think it's when you
know that your opponent's like on top
deck mode you will clearly take away all
their resources.
>> I mean I know a lot of people want to
try to get rid of the Hawaii that's
probably the most expensive Hawaii
removal I've seen today but it it ends
up I think being still worth it.
>> Yeah I think that is a great point and
it definitely seems like it worked out.
So great for them. All right, going into
game two real quickly here. Uh, looks
like both are considering a double uh,
put back here.
>> Yeah, making sure. Yeah, where Yeah, we
put two cards back into deck here. And
our two battlefields, we've got
Forgotten Monument on the left for
Novear's Peak on the right for him.
>> You're good. It happens to literally.
>> All right, so we're going to go our
start here. We'll see if there's a
playable card. uh stack deck off the
top. Not the worst, but again, you do
want to try to put units out when you
can.
>> Yeah, especially getting these early
units I feel like versus Aurora is just
going to be so important for him. So, it
doesn't feel great to be seeing that
stack deck coming down right now. That
being said, though, we did have a bit of
a difficulty last game, even getting
into some of these early battlefields.
So, while Targon's Peak I definitely
think is a fantastic battlefield for
Diana, if we can't get it into the first
place, it's going to be difficult to use
the battlefield for its ability.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And we're going to go at
three runes here for no veggies. Again,
both players got a double put back. So,
uh that usually means to me not not our
best hands either, but we do get the
forge of the future. Make our first
recruit of the turn and pass it back to
him. Yeah, and it is nice just going and
get that token. We also have the unit
now as well. So, it definitely feels at
least feels better for no veggies here,
but we do finally find a unit here with
that Raven Bloom student or two
>> and two. All right,
>> a little study session over there.
>> We're back. We don't have D Bloom
Conservatory, but
>> yeah, a little field trip to Targon's
Peak or the Forgotten Mountain, but or
monument, but we've got five energy here
again.
It's It's always funny when the Aurora
deck can get the first point, but uh if
we want to try to get the Monument or
the Targon's Peak, um but I also
wouldn't be too surprised if they kept
the recruit in the uh the base.
>> Yeah, I don't think it would be that bad
of an idea either just taking one
battlefield here. uh
fast.
>> Yeah, it's it's just going to be tough
because you know that it's just going to
uh you know, one of the students is
going to interact with it. And yeah, no
veggies is like you know what, this
might be useful later in the game uh to
kind of force some interactions,
especially like if I have Elder Dragon
out uh the one damage from this recruits
enough to remove something. So, I'm not
going to get I don't need the point that
bad. I don't need the, you know, runes
back at the next turn. So, we're just
going to pass it back with the five uh
full open.
>> Yeah. And it's not like really either
player can score two points here. They
do have the units, but for those who
don't know, Forgotten Monument does stop
players from scoring at it till the
third turn. So, the max you can get here
is one point and sometimes being at odd
points can be a bit difficult.
>> Uh, it's third turn overall. So, we have
we have passed. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But
that but it is a good point though that
the monument is good for preventing
starts especially saw we saw those Lilia
players earlier if they have like the
double sprite start. So, uh, but I I
believe that they would be able to with
the interaction, but, uh, we try to use
a blood money here to do two damage,
which we still do. Uh, but the stupify
will let us get that additional, uh,
point of might due to the student
effect. Both of them are at three might
right now. And, uh, the extra draw one
might have given an additional plus two
might from the frrigid jewel. Uh, no,
sorry, second time for the turn. So, it
hasn't happened yet. So, both are at
three might right now.
>> Let's see.
>> All right. Okay, so we're passing it
back to uh no veggies. No runes played
last turn, but at the seven right now.
So without any runes recycled, we would
be able to get to uh to nine to
potentially play an Aurora for the first
time. And you know, you you'll have to
trust us so far. This is an Aurora deck.
There's been no real proof yet. But uh
you know, this this could be a tough
spot if uh you know, both these students
can get a lot of points.
>> Yeah, this could be really nice. It does
look like it is not going to be the
Aurora though. We are going to go and
play that confront. It does let us draw
a card. So, we're getting a little bit
deeper into our deck, but we're gonna
have to keep looking. And by drawing, we
are hopefully getting closer to some of
those cards we're gonna want in this
follow-up turn.
>> Yeah. So, uh we end up using the
confront. And then we were, you know,
there's this choice of using either the
Poppy or, uh using the blood money. So,
we are going to use uh the blood money
to get a uh try to get two damage on the
student, which we do get.
>> Is currently at one uh you know, we
could trade with the token. Uh, but
saying, you know what, I I don't feel
safe that there's nothing left in that
hand, so we're just going to pass it
right back to him again.
>> Let's see here. Timothy is up to so many
runes now. He has Diana has so many
options here on how to hopefully keep
these battlefields and we're trying to
get points to kind of win the game
before Aurora comes into play, which is
just potentially a turn away.
>> Yeah. So, we've got it looks like eight
runes for for Diana here. um you know
could be uh a vex. Okay, that's a nice
ad there. Uh so since it's out of
battlefield makes the uh you know
effects cards that are played next turn
uh so they're going to be stunned and
can't move are actually even going to
play out the Diana. So really trying to
hold this Targon's peak. Uh additionally
making sure that you have multiple units
on the same battlefield means that Elder
Dragon doesn't hit as hard.
>> Yeah, Elder Dragon can only I think
target one unit per battlefield. So, it
would mean we would potentially be able
to still hold this despite that and it
will come in stunned as well.
>> Yeah. So, uh but that's also why I think
we've been so patient with this recruit.
Um you know, there could have been some
situations. Yeah, we've got the uh
Aurora for the first time uh for this
game, for this match, for the for the
weekend, I think. But I'd be surprised
if it was the last. And looking off the
top, let's see what unit we find.
>> Yeah, we Oh, and it is going to be that
Elder Dragon. Yeah. So, definitely one
of the students and then deciding, yeah,
we're going to get the Diana. Um, it
does get stunned and as as the rules
processing, as I'm aware, it will
continue to be stunned until the uh your
next start of beginning phase, which has
already passed. So, as far as I know,
it's uh it's going to be stunned,
including uh next turn as well for no
veggies.
>> Let's see here. But, I mean, it's
>> it's true. It is a dazzling Aurora deck.
We were correct. We we found we've have
finally found it. Uh and yeah, we we
missed out I think on this uh pre this
game some potential ramp to get there,
but uh we were able to play it as soon
as we could.
>> Yeah. Which is going to be really nice.
Obviously is going to be difficult as
long as we leave that Vex alive though
as you mentioned with the stun and
having that interaction with Dazzin
Aurora's timing.
>> Yeah. So uh currently uh we did get uh
the plus one might on the student there
>> and we are going to play out the
>> the removal potential there.
>> Forgotten memories.
>> Yeah,
>> I believe is the name.
>> Yeah. So give a unit at a battlefield or
any gear temporary and it does get
killed at the start of the controller's
beginning phase. So that will get rid of
the Aurora before it's able to activate
again.
>> Yeah, that's going to be rough for Nove.
He finally found the one or found a
dazzling Aurora and it's already going
to be gone before next turn which is
going to be I mean difficult. Will he be
able to find another one?
>> Yeah. And uh you know it's tough to see
right like uh so many people are
respecting uh Aurora right now. Um you
know we've been seeing the removal in
the main board at this point too but uh
yeah there goes the temporary trigger
and there goes the dazzling Aurora.
>> Let's see.
All right, we are at I believe nine
runes again because I think we Yeah, we
have to recycle two from the Aurora
here. Uh, and we'll see. But we do have
the Elder Dragon on the board and that's
still going to be kind of tough for us
to interact with.
>> He's still stunned,
>> but
>> yeah, it definitely
>> uh Yes, this is
>> this is Vexpothetic.
>> Yeah, I think I think they are just
confirming Yeah. the interaction just to
put that I mean but it if there's no
combat this turn you being stunned is
not uh as terrible but with stuff like
ride the wind there definitely could be
some uh interaction points for it as
well.
>> Yeah, always something you have to be
concerned about that ride the wind on
these on the chaos decks and we do have
those three runes up that could use as
well as the one energy from the legend
ability during showdowns.
>> Sure. and you kind of need to uh ride
the wind here. Uh I I feel like just to
be able to uh you know get the go to six
points in your opponent's turn, then
potentially go to the eight on the next
one. But we do get the rebuke there
removed from the sabotage. And I did not
see a ride the wind there. So you can be
kind of cautious uh with the rest of the
cards uh in hand. So we'll start off
though with maybe Recruit moving up.
>> Yeah, I think that was really nice to be
able to get that Rebuke out of hand. And
Rebuke is one of those cards that would
be able to send that Elder Dragon back
to Nove's hand. And again, paying 12
energy and is it four power to be able
to play it from hand is a lot to do
>> for sure. And looks like we're thinking
about paying some uh some energy here at
least. Uh
>> timer, please.
>> Yeah, I think it's going to be a harness
dragon based on the amount used and
recycled, but Poppy's getting a little
anxious there. He wants to see the
action. She doesn't.
>> And I love it.
>> Yeah, there's the harness dragon. Going
to choose the student there to get rid
of it. And we're going to keep the elder
dragon safe in the base. Get two runes
back to the Targon's Peak and back to
him.
Yeah,
>> part of me has to always wonder like
that obviously you would want to get rid
of that Vex because she seems to be
dealing
>> really just like kind of upsetting your
game plan with the the stun. Obviously,
she's not on a battlefield right now, so
it's not the same exact thing, but she
always could retake a battlefield and
potentially again stun one of these
units that you might want to move up and
take a point with.
>> Yeah. And there's also like the deflect
cost you have to think about. So maybe
there is a play they're hoping for next
turn that they wouldn't be able to do if
they paid the deflect. Uh obviously
student has the potential to be above
four might at times too. So I think it
was a fair choice. Uh yeah.
>> Yeah. I always think it's a fair choice
and obviously these players know these
decks much better than I do uh or
anything like that. I do think we're
still around that rune count to kind of
just be hitting Aurora as well. Maybe
right above it. So this is where those
runes really really matter.
>> Yeah. Yeah. and you know being able to
uh oh there's the XP token. So back on
the board there got one XP have two
points to the six on the other side but
six is such an important number in this
game. A double conquer could be all him
needs to force a game three.
>> Yeah for it very well could be. We're
only at as you said uh one or two points
here. I think two from the hold and then
six. We're definitely on the cusp of
winning here for him.
>> Yeah and I think it looks like uh we
must be at eight runes right now. uh if
I'm looking at this correctly. So that
means that we can play Poppy and since
they are three away from winning, it
does mean we get the XP and we get to
enter active. So that is the potential
for a draw, which is nice. Uh we do get
the removal of the student, so that's
really nice. Uh so we're at three points
here. And again, um
>> draw ones are good. They're great,
actually.
>> I mean, they're very nice if you're
trying to find your second Dazzling
Aurora as well, for sure.
>> Yeah. So we'll see if that ends up being
the case, but it it's cool to see. Yeah.
the the fact that this Poppy is also in
like sacrifice range, I think, is really
important. Uh can be really helpful. Um
and it looks like we're paying two for
maybe uh okay, a mobilize there.
>> So, we're just going to keep generating
these runes. Uh
>> to see what they're going to be able to
do, but
>> I do think he just passed back to the
>> Yeah. Uh I'm curious if there is
something that I don't know about that
maybe the XP could be using, right? Uh I
would feel like maybe a draw one could
be warranted here, but looks like we've
finally found the Hawaii from Himthy.
Again, it's been a little bit shy this
match here, but can still do a lot of
damage and again with Frigid Jewel on
the board, uh can offer some, you know,
additional might from all the draw that
gets to do.
Yeah,
>> I feel like we're already I mean in a
pretty good position as Timothy.
Obviously, we do have to take the
battlefield builds. Uh which No has
control of both, but it does seem like
we're starting to build out our base
again. We have I think it was 12 runes
at the beginning of this turn down to 11
right now. And we're starting to get
some of these units that can do a lot.
>> Yeah. So, we go to six XP for no
veggies, which is verifiably the most XP
I've seen a Poppy player have. So fun to
see that there. And uh you know, double
fridge jewel can do a lot of damage next
turn. We got to be careful about that.
But uh you know, we're still uh quite
ahead. Uh himy does have what looks like
two cards in hand. Uh and we'll see what
Noveggy's response to this is.
>> Yeah,
let's see.
>> All right. Yeah, we're going to we're
going to get our draw one here. Use
three of our XP.
>> Draw. We still have three more.
>> Yeah, we and again next turn we can we
can do it again. So,
>> uh you know, sometimes, you know, it's
it's a compared to other draw effects, I
feel like this is a little bit expensive
at times, but you definitely still take
it and it can be really helpful,
especially when I think we don't have as
much of this uh
>> uh draw power in these domains, but we
do have a lot of harness dragons. We got
another one hitting the board. Uh
pairing both up at Toron's Peak and
getting rid of that Hawaii. Yeah, I mean
it seems like Quay is such an important
target to make sure that it doesn't stay
on the board in this matchup. And I
think Nove just seeming to be able to
like hold here. It is seeming very
difficult for him to kind of retake
these battlefields even though they had
such a lead at that that six points.
>> Yeah. And uh you know this could be it
for for him on either side, right? Uh
there is the potential for uh it'd have
to be a pretty spectacular but double
conquer here. Um, you know, we do have
the ability to go to uh eight might if
we draw one more card off of both these
frigid jewels, but um yeah, the the fact
that we are reducing their hand size so
often does make it tough for him to get
a lot of stellar plays.
>> Yeah, I think that's a really good
point.
But I mean, even though Nove had the
Aurora for one turn, it seems like he's
been able to stabilize now and kind of
like come back from where he was.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And that's the thing with
the Aurora decks a lot of the time, too.
You're like, I'm at six points. They
weren't able to do it. I get to go there
and then they stabilize. You're like,
this is unclimbable. They've given me
such a bad position here. But we're
going to play with the Fizz. Uh looks
like there's a couple options for us.
We've got uh some superify, some stack
decks. We've got the uh I think just
those two actually cuz the uh the other
one is at a four cost, right? We're a
little bit too expensive. But going to
use the stack deck or sorry the yeah
stack deck here. Look at the top three.
We can we can uh another fizz and
another stack deck if we really want.
>> Yeah, we could have stack deck again
potentially it looked like. But um it
does seem like we went on and picked
what we thought would be the best card
here. Uh, and hopefully we'll be able to
see it help us.
>> Does look like Fizz is going to come
down. Another Fizz here. Uh,
>> uh, you don't you didn't draw.
>> And I think I think we're making sure.
Yeah, Frigid Jewel only is for draws.
Uh, the stack deck puts the card into
your hand. Uh, I think we have a Stupify
or two in the trash though, so we could
use that and then that would offer a an
ability to uh, get a draw one. So, it
makes our Vex. Yeah. So, there's the
Supy. Now, we're going to use the plus
one might. So this is a think plus four
might be Vex right now.
>> That's going to be really nice if we
decide to go somewhere.
>> Think.
>> Yeah, we can we can conquer the top one.
But again with Elder Dragon uh it makes
it uh a little bit harder to get the
interaction. Oh, this is this is
actually going to be a really nice play
though. So we're going to use the star
cross on the Fizz and the Elder Dragon
here. So now that's no longer an option
for you. And with this Vex, this has
actually been a pretty strong play, I
think, from Timothy. We've gotten a lot
of interaction. Uh, and we do have the
potential to now be eight might to six.
We were able to conquer uh the top
battlefield. And then if we're able to
hold it, we're forcing the game three.
>> Yeah, this seems like a really nice spot
to be in. As you said, that Vex
potentially could go up in that top
battlefield. We are able to resave our
Fizz for a potential future turn. We
might want to grab another one of those
spells from the trash. And we're also
going to moonfall here.
>> Oh wow. So using the moonfall here, we
are able to move one of the dragons over
and with the numbers I have to redo
them, but I'm pretty sure we're going to
be able to get uh
>> yeah, what we need to. So uh we
essentially move a five over, but we
give a minus six to the board. So uh
that should be a full clear on this uh
forgotten monument. and then three. So
get six, I think.
>> And the other thing for the Moonfall,
too, is that it can give you minus uh
might here. So the recruit ends up being
minus one. And yeah, Vex gets the clear.
We're at seven points here. This could
be uh exactly what Timothy needs.
>> Seems like the exact turn that Timothy
needed to potentially uh try to struggle
their way to eight after stuck at six
for so long.
>> Yeah. And it's going to be pretty much
down to does no veggies have a way to
interact with this vex. If they can
clear this battlefield, you're going to
hold to eight. And again, we're going to
game three.
>> Yeah. And that would be super exciting.
I'm trying to think there like any cards
that would potentially be able uh to
upset this Vex. Um obviously there is a
Fizz in base to potentially protect it
against anything like gold weak.
>> Uh
>> could be another harness dragon. Maybe
>> a harness dragon.
>> Yeah. But it's it's kind of tricky
because again we don't have a lot of
movement in this deck if really any. So
uh I'd have to be like maybe like what a
confront into something. It's going to
be very tough.
>> Yes, it will be a difficult spot to be
in.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, I believe we've got 11 runes. If
we had 12, we'd be able to play out the
Elder Dragon and it' be a non-issue. But
>> Mhm.
>> with I think the only 11 that we have.
Uh I mean maybe we have a Dazzling
Aurora. It's a Dazzling Aurora. Hoping
to find either a harness dragon or a an
Elder Dragon to get the removal there.
Uh but just maybe making sure that there
wasn't an, you know, before we have to
spin the dice that there's not a better
play for us.
>> I I think I saw it as but maybe I am
clear off there.
>> All right. So it looks like we are going
to play Fors of the Future. We're going
to get rid of a couple spells. Uh, so
prevents Fizz from being played again
aggressively. Uh, yeah, really take away
the options. Yeah, Moonfall. Yeah, good
choice there, I think, cuz again, Fizz
can really get some interaction with
that. And
I love Forge of the Future. I think it's
a really good ad for Aurora deck. So,
it's it's really cool that Poppy gets to
use it.
>> Yeah, it's very nice. Especially you can
see here with uh what they just did cuz
definitely there is that fizz back in
hand. We know him if he has it
>> and we have to find a way to
let's see.
So we are going to be cycling three
runes here.
>> Oh could be a rune nation.
>> Runation.
>> Yeah, ruin nation. Okay. I mean, again,
it's an expensive way to interact with
it, but it's a valid way to do so. Um,
and that does prevent a, you know, easy
double conquer. Uh, there are a lot of
ways that that could happen still, but,
uh, you know, this likely will buy us
another turn.
>> We just saw the last game and I forgot
about it. I was thinking about what
could kill the backs.
>> Yeah, it's just like it's, you know, at
what cost, right? Like I don't lose next
turn likely, but uh, you know, it makes
it more difficult for me once again.
100%. Um,
let's see.
>> All right. Well, again, a kind of funny
hand for him because if I remember
correctly, I don't think there's any
spells in that trash right now. So, uh,
we can just play out Fizz as a no effect
unit, it seems.
>> Mhm.
>> Yeah. Three and the recycle.
>> And yeah, that's going to be the pass
there. So, no veggies. Very happy to see
that.
Yeah, and I mean it does not feel good
to be playing Fizz obviously when you
can't also then play one of those spells
in the trash. But at least we are
getting a unit down in base and it is
going to be a struggle from here. Himy
obviously next turn that Fizz will be
could be ready if it survives. But it
can't take the eighth point by itself.
Instead, you have to either hold to your
eighth point or to have had control of
both battlefields during the same turn.
And so you would then instead draw, but
it wouldn't be an immediate win if Fizz
moves into one of these battlefields
next turn.
>> Yeah. So, looks like we're going to pay
two for cold a week here. Uh again with
them only having one unit. You do get
kind of the uh removal there. And then
again, we're going to be playing out the
uh not the forge, but the Vanguard
Armory. Uh getting us three recruits
here. And again, we have, you know, we
just have to get a double conquer next
turn. We have that ability next turn for
No Veggies. And uh it's funny, it's
looking like the same game we just saw.
>> Yeah, it really is. This Vanguard Armory
may actually be for me the V uh the MVP.
Yes. Of the game,
>> but it definitely feels nice to be able
to make those three units. Obviously, I
think Gary, you could be able to do it
again. And I'm just like thinking back
to earlier when we were able to remove
the forgotten memories from the trash
and recycle it back into the deck as
well. Just making sure there's not any
of that gear that can take out things
like the uh vanguard armory.
>> And recruit goes to the peak, takes it,
goes to the monument.
>> Uh looks like there might be a Yeah, a
confirmation. Yeah, that they are at
eight points and that's going to be it.
Yeah, no veggies gets it. And yeah, what
a crazy game. What a fun game to watch.
>> Yeah, fantastic job by No Veggies. I
think at the end he actually showed he
did have the other Aurora which is I
mean really cool to see that he was able
to win without having to play it.
>> Yeah. Like again those ruin nations they
I I feel like they almost hurt him more
immediately but when you know that your
opponent's running out of resources and
there's less and less units to play. I
think that's really good. But honestly
uh Timothy did a really good job putting
him on that pressure right? Uh getting
that vex getting that board clear. What
a great game. A great game to end. Yeah,
I think it was so fantastic and kind of
interesting to see. I hate killing my
own units if I'm being honest. Uh maybe
that's why I don't do great with yellow
decks. Uh but like
>> so many units of Nove died when he was
playing ruination and it was still able
to come back because that Aurora has
such a great late game.
>> Yeah, for sure. I mean, you can tell
your opponents. Yeah. Oh, I uh ruination
two elder dragons today. They are my own
valer dragons, but I still did it,
right? So, uh, I think that's, you know,
a non-intuitive play, but definitely
worked out. And, you know, Nove,
uh, I think we're going to our, you
know, other game right now. We've got
some also unique, uh, legends as well.
And we're going to look at Volibir here.
Uh, another Aurora deck. And, uh, yeah,
but plays very differently.
>> Yeah, it does play very differently. I'm
really excited to see this one. Uh,
Billionaire actually does have a best of
Volibear just from Sydney as well as a
best of Ye I believe as well. So, he is
a fantastic player. He really knows how
to play Volibear and it is a dazzling
Aurora, but he actually when I was
talking to him earlier about his Dazzing
Aurora list mentioned that even if I
don't hit Dazzing Aurora, you should
watch the curve we play because with how
this deck is set up, I don't always have
to hit Dazzing Aurora.
>> Yeah. And you know, I'm a sucker for
dragons and so having that kind of sub
archetype is really cool. And you know,
uh, Volar and Dazzar are supposed to go
together and they do, but it's cool to
see all these different other builds
that do have these like really congruent
backup plans for when it doesn't happen.
>> Yeah, cuz I feel like we really like
talk about how like if especially in
this set sometimes it feels like it's
hit the dazzling aurora or lose the
game. And in this round it seems to be
the opposite. It almost seemed to work
well for no veggies not to hit dazzing
Aurora and I would love to see
billionaire do well as well here
>> for sure. So that's on one side. On the
other side believe we've got a Master Yi
if I remember correctly. Yes, we do. Uh
and again there has been a discussion.
Do we like this mid-range build? Do we
like the Aurora build more? Uh is there
Aurora hiding in the sideboard as well?
There's so many different options for
it. But you know Yi's been one of the
most consistent legends in this game for
a really good reason. Yeah, I absolutely
love uh the Yi deck back at Houston. I
actually played Yi when I went Houston.
I'm just going to state it. It was not
the Aurora list and this one is not. Uh
but I really think it's just a such a
consistent deck. It's a lot of fun. Uh
and the leader ability to have plus two
might when you're defending by yourself
just feels so strong.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The legend's fantastic. And
we do have a new champion, right? A
mastery that we can just play out on
tempo is great. Uh we're also using one
of the new battlefields amateur recital
which is really exciting as well. Um so
yeah looking forward to seeing what uh
Mastery does with it. But yeah, when you
hold here you may move a unit at a
battlefield to its base. So it's good
for you getting the point moving a you
know one of your units back and then use
it to conquer the other base as well or
battlefield as well.
>> That seems so nice especially with this
list I feel like. Uh and I think it's
going be really interesting to see how
they do play that master y like you
mentioned and it's also kind of using
that expos.
So yeah,
>> definitely I think we're good to go into
this one. We're going to be starting in
game three. So one a piece and we're
going to see who's able to close out
this match.
>> All right, as mentioned, we got
Millionaire on the left with Volibar
using the paper tree and we've have I
missed my Q on the right using the
mastery and we're playing the arena's
greatest, which means I think they're
going to be going first for I missed my
Q.
>> That's very exciting. um you're going to
win. Okay.
>> And we are into that game three like you
mentioned here. I'm interested to see
that. Obviously these two players,
they've played the two games before.
They've started to get an idea about how
each other plays their deck, how they
kind of are looking into this matchup.
So, it'll be interesting to see in this
last game. Hopefully, they have
sideboarded in exactly what they need
and we're going to see a great match for
me.
>> And and honestly, like uh kind of a
skill uh for these players, too. Like,
you know, really good pace of play,
right? We've got 18 minutes left for
game three, so should be enough to to
really conclude it out. We've got the
scuttle crab hitting the board there and
pass it back to Billionaire.
>> Let's see. I think obviously Villionaire
is going to be kind of shooting for that
Aurora is my guess. Obviously, we talked
about a lot of these decks trying to
just like build up and we do see that
pass back quickly to the Y. We are going
to go and take that first or I guess
>> second point. I think both are at two.
Yeah. Yeah, second point at the arena's
greatest and playing Ye from our chosen
champion spot.
>> Yeah, and sorry, two, two for I Miss My
Q, one for Villionaire. We got the one,
but uh quickly trying to prove me right.
We've got the Rengar there. Uh paying it
and being able to uh get that additional
point going to two there and also being
able to use the Volibar legend ability.
And since we did get the scuttle crab uh
death kneel, right, we are able to get
all of the knowledge in their opponent's
hand and not seeing the uh dowsing is,
you know, a good first step, right?
>> Yeah, it is a very good first step. I
will say I feel like I may be a little
concerned seeing some of these different
cards. You know, Kadricken is very scary
when you're going into some of these uh
dragon decks. Uh, obviously we saw that
Elders Dragon, but I guess to some
extent if you're actually going against
Dazzling Aurora and it's in your
opponent's hand,
>> maybe that's a blessing in disguise
because it can't come down from the
Dazzling Aurora.
>> Yeah, for sure. So, we've got six runes
here for I missed my Q. Uh, could be
their chance for their own Rengar here
if they so desire. Uh, you know, only
five runes on the other side for
Villionaire. So, not and all of them
have been used. So, uh, a little bit of
free reign right now.
>> I'm sorry. uh see what he's able to do
>> uh and it reduces based on the might of
the creature.
>> Let's see. Also, we do have one XP from
the uh scuttle crab, right? Uh I think
Mastery is a deck that can take
advantage of XP a little bit more,
especially with our champion unit here.
I believe you have to be level six to be
able to get uh the additional bonus from
it, but uh we're we're getting our way
there. Yeah, I do love this new mechanic
with experience, especially with the new
master Y with getting different uh
keywords and abilities that you get at
these different levels. Really
interesting to see.
>> Yeah, so it looks like we're just going
to preemptively play the discipline here
to get the plus two and then the
unguard. So, uh could have just been a
situation where maybe if I drew
something, I would have changed what I
did, but going to three, getting rid of
the Rengar. Uh and again once he is on a
battlefield being able to uh defensively
have that extra might is going to be
really really nice.
>> Yeah, it is. And it looks like we are
going to play sabotage as well. Uh which
is always really nice when you're going
up against Aurora again. This does just
like Skittlecraft lets you see the hand,
but in this case actually gets to remove
one of those non unit cards from your
hand if that could be an Aurora. like if
it was there, you could then get it
recycled back into your opponent's deck.
>> Yeah. And with the scuttle crab, I mean,
sometimes there are times where I'm
like, "Oh, there's nothing I can remove
or I know that there's nothing super
great." So, meaning, you know, the
scuttle crab saying, "Oh, yeah, there is
something I want out of that hand."
Really sets up that sabotage.
>> Yeah, it's really nice to be able to
know exactly what you're shooting for to
some extent. Um, and so we are going to
be going back to Villionaire. But yeah,
I think it is interesting that he's got
a lot of these units that he is playing
even though we don't see the dazzling
roar just yet. And he does seem okay
these power costs even though they could
set him back on that dazzing Aurora.
>> Yeah. Well, so luckily with the Volibar
when you play a mighty unit mean you may
exhaust me to channel one. So uh it
really just again mitigates the
recycling from Rengar. So you just get
to play out a unit which is really nice.
>> Yeah, that is really nice getting to
offset that there. Uh which kind of
makes it good for Volibear to be playing
a lot of these units as we curve up into
that dazzling aurora. just my
>> and we are playing up the guardian angel
here and then we are attaching it and
equipping it to the master here. So
which is going to not only give it some
defense. We're also at 5 XP which uh so
we're only one XP away from getting our
bonus effect here from the but I think
we're thinking about
>> passing with what five runes open right
now.
>> Yeah. And that's I mean that's a lot of
scary things in a in a Y list for
Billionaire then to have to account for
if he decides to come up into that
arena's greatest as well.
>> Yeah. And uh you know obviously we've
seen Rengar already just be a force uh
in this meta. We currently have I
believe nine runes from Villionaire. So
if we have been able to draw into the
Aurora in the last couple turns it could
be a play for us right now. Um we're
currently at four points I believe for I
missed my Q. So that will be the halfway
mark. But we are going to go to the
paper tree
>> three
>> billionaires at three right now.
>> Um
>> and think about the rest of them. Think
about the the uh the units I know in
hand. Uh we do have the play here. Yeah,
not too shabby.
>> Yeah, Kadan is really nice to see come
down here. I mean and just kind of
fortifying that paper tree. Uh, so let's
see. Again, we also do have uh, you
know, we get to channel one off the
Volibar. We get to draw two. When you
play me, draw one for each of your
mighty units, which we have two. So, uh,
obviously works really well with this
deck to get an additional draw.
>> Yeah, it feels like Kadricken really
just synergizes so well with Volibear.
Kind of just mighty cards in general do
with I mean both Bear and Kadricken. Um,
so really nice here. Obviously that
Rengar, obviously that the draw, but
everything's just working well together.
So nicely.
>> Yeah, and we do have seven XP. Uh, so
our mastery uh does get its level six
effect, which is nice. We do play out a
scuttle crab again once again to get a
draw and the potential to look at their
hand again. And looking what we want to
do for the rest of these runes here, but
you know, we're at five points right
now. It's still a long journey if we're
trying to just hold to eight here. Uh,
and we'll see what I miss my decided to
do.
It seems like we are at least slightly
holding I mean being able to keep up on
points on billionaire's side
>> but let's see I miss my Q is able to
play that lonely porro. It is a very
cute porro. Um and kind of goes well
with that defending by yourself but
right now it is going to obviously not
kind of be able to deal with the might
that is in paper tree. So we're going to
have to find more here on I missed my Q
side if we do want to break your tree.
to some extent we kind of don't have to
right now since we are in the lead with
points.
>> Yeah, we do. And uh you know I think the
movement for Voli Bear is not super
high. So having them both on this paper
tree uh we do also get like the extra
channel
>> for both players which
>> uh you know I think means more for
Volibear than Master Y right now.
Volibear will definitely you know allow
both of them to to get that extra
channel here. But
>> looks like we're we're spending nine if
I'm counting correctly. Ooh. Is it going
to be that Aurora coming down here?
>> Oh, this one is tapped from the the
paper.
>> Oh, yeah. Sorry. Sorry. Yep. Let's see.
>> Could be another Cater, too. But Oh, no.
It's not
>> actually. Yeah, it's going to be another
of those dragon cards.
>> Uh
>> I believe that was the gentle Yeah, the
gentle gem dragon. when you play me or
another dragon, you can ready up to two
runes, which can be nice when all these
units are costing a lot to then
potentially be able to do something else
with the runes that get ready.
>> Yeah. And then it works obviously really
well with Volibar because you do also
get to channel one too cuz you play the
mighty unit. We're going to play out the
mobilize here. Uh so it gets us another
draw since we're at full runes too. So
uh obviously maybe missing out on
something, but we've got, you know, a
pretty bulky uh paper tree right now.
So, I don't think we should be too
worried or pressed about, you know, them
getting these extra points and XP off
the master.
>> Yeah, I don't think we're pressed about
the about that too much. We do need to
break into that arena's greatest at some
point. Uh, I missed my Q is at six
leading uh the match here. So, we do
need to get into Arena's greatest and
hopefully offset those points at some
point.
>> Yeah. So, we're just going to move the
scuttle crab into Paper Tree just to get
the uh, you know, knowledge of cards in
hand. And we see two elder dragons. Uh
we see a ferris 4runner. We see
catalyst. We see Rengar. So uh
definitely something to be scared about
next turn. Uh but currently nothing
really uh interacting with us this turn.
>> Yeah, that yeah, nothing for this turn
for sure. But I'm definitely worried
about some of these Elder Dragons.
Obviously Billionaire, I think it's all
12 runes in play right now. So Elder
Dragon is definitely an option. Um, and
it's not like it would be alone because
you would get those two runes back from
the
>> J. Yeah, you're right. You're right. So,
uh, yeah, it's going to be a little bit
scary here. Um, yeah, Mastery has like
deflect and ganking now cuz it's level
six. So, you know, we could move over to
the other side. Uh, but and what
interact with the Rengar, maybe get like
a five for five trade, but you know, not
really nothing super great right now.
>> Yeah. And we're not really pushed to as
I miss my Q, right? like this is kind of
our game. Obviously, we do know that
billionaire could outscale us with just
the amount of might he is amassing on
his side of the board. But until he does
something, I missed my Q is kind of
sitting pretty here. He has everything
he needs and in a couple turns if
Billionaire can't find a way in then
we are happy. That being said, obviously
OD Dragon in hand could be a problem
when that would free up that arena's
greatest.
>> Yeah. Uh there's a decision here uh to
maybe you know again have the lonely
porro head to the paper tree to offer a
draw one. Uh there are also some ways to
buff up uh and make this lonely porro
lonely and mighty. So uh can maybe get
some uh interactions with uh the Rengar
potentially. But yeah, some some
decision- making from I miss my Q for
sure.
Well, looks like we also have a charm in
hand, which yeah, that could be a really
good interaction uh for making sure that
you do uh get to defend with the Y and
get those extra two points of might.
>> Yeah, we could potentially see like like
a charm maybe like over like bringing
maybe something like Ringar over while
there is only two runes up. Uh we also
do have a pretty good idea like what is
in hand. I do. I'm trying to remember if
I actually saw Skysplitter that time
that Skittle Crab did or if it was the
time before, but
>> Sure.
>> Oh, okay.
>> Okay.
>> So, we're just going to put a lot on the
arena's greatest here. And this is the I
think to play around the Elder Dragon,
right? When you can uh you know, just
>> with everything at one location, you can
only get rid of one of these. I've also
if you get rid of the Master Yi, you do
have the uh the uh angel guardian angel
there. So, uh, this is going to be, I
think, kind of tough for Villionaire to
interact with because, uh, you know, you
can hold up here.
>> Yeah, I think this is really smart by
Miss Q starting to put more units into
Arena's greatest.
I wonder what Villain will decide to do.
Um,
>> I feel like sometimes you do want to
like keep gym dragon in the back just
because it can help continue to ready
those runes. But is there some world you
try to break in with her, start killing
some of those units, but elder dragon is
going to get played straight to paper
tree and we are going to kill the go
back and I get
>> and we do play a mighty unit and we get
to ready too due to playing a dragon. So
that ends up being pretty nice. We're
going to be at five uh you know still
five points for Villionaire here.
But it's, you know, not a lot of
interaction this battlefield. We're
going to try to use the gem dragon to
get a double removal here.
>> And I will pass.
>> I wonder what the hidden card's going to
be.
>> Yes. Yeah. I I think
>> back off.
>> Uh yeah, I'm actually not. It's going to
be back off though on this one. So,
we're going to use back off here. Uh
play it from hand cuz it is eight might
to seven. And if the stun does happen,
then you know, you just get to uh just
stay on the arena's greatest.
>> We have eight.
>> Yeah, it stun would mean that Jim Dragon
couldn't deal damage to either the E or
the Lonely Porro. They can always still
deal damage back. Uh but
>> oh, I'm sorry.
>> Yeah, cuz I think it's it's eight might
to seven. We're going to use the Unguard
here uh to make it 8 to eight. And so
with it being uh stunned uh you will be
able to you know just get the removal
there.
>> Yeah, that would be really nice. And Ye
does I mean that's one part about E
that's really nice. Obviously that plus
two from if you are uh defending by
yourself but it does have a lot of these
like might adding cards from like
discipline on guard obviously those
stuns with back off. There was like last
last uh set. So it does have a lot of
options of how to deal with some of
these battles. Uh so
>> yeah, and we do have the skysplitter uh
using that to uh deal five to a unit at
a battlefield. So that does get uh I
believe the removal there. So
>> Oh yeah, the E is deflect.
>> We do have the uh guardian angel there
that did get to survive with the master
in the back on the B battlefield, but
you know, we can maybe hold to this
point here. It looks like Villainer's uh
thinking about something.
>> Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, Master Yi does survive in base
from Guardian Angel just like you
mentioned. And because it does die, uh
well, and gets revived though, it's not
enough damage to kill the Gem Dragon.
Instead, it just gets sent back to base
because it's stunned.
>> Correct. Yeah.
>> Oh, sure, sure, sure, sure.
>> Yeah. And just Yeah, I think just
clarifying. Yeah, the Volibar is not at
the spot there. Oh, we do have the rune
runner, though. Ooh,
>> very scary card.
>> Yeah, people love talking about Ruin
Runner. I feel like during set two, uh I
think it was set two that Run.
>> Oh, and we're charming over to the paper
tree. Love this play here because it
means it's, you know, you don't have
anything to move over to the arena's
greatest. We're at seven points for I
miss my Q. And with three units at this
battlefield, uh, you know, unless they
have a spell to deal the damage here,
they might have a hard time just getting
over to this arena's greatest here.
>> Okay.
>> Um,
>> all right. Going back to Villionaire has
to be able to interact with this. And
again, yeah, this is this is the first
time I've seen a charm used this way.
Uh, but I love it. I love to see that
gameplay.
>> Yeah, it is so smart. kind of really
putting I miss my Q in a really smart
spot. As we said earlier, all they had
to do is keep holding that battlefield.
They're only one turn away from
potentially being at eight points. And
there's not a lot of, as you were
mentioning earlier, mobility in these
Volibear decks to kind of get over,
especially when you're already in one
battlefield.
>> Yeah, cuz like you're just so used to
doing that. We do have a Rengar uh from
hand.
>> We do have another back off to stun it
here and that's going to be enough. I
missed my Q holding the arena's greatest
taking that game 2-1 ending the round
40.
>> What a fantastic job by that Yi though.
I mean
>> it is so I mean nice to see Ye being
able to play without Aurora. I do think
it is the popular choice this tournament
with Ye to be doing mid-range. Uh but
really cool to see some of those awesome
decisions including that charm that you
highlighted.
>> Yeah, that that charm. Uh what a high IQ
play for that one. So, uh, yeah, really
great game. I'm happy we were able to
find, you know, watch that final game
for sure.
>> Yeah, it was I I loved watching it. And
the Volibear was also really cool to
see. You don't see too much Volibear,
but
>> I don't know. There's just so many
options with Ye. Obviously, you have
cards that I mean, there's like the
thigh that stops spells. We didn't see
that too much. Might increasing spells
like that on guard, disciplines, and
then even these stuns that are just
doing so much in this game. Yeah. Yeah.
And I think that was like a thin needle
uh that you had to thread through that
game. I missed my Q. Was able to find it
and loved watching it.
>> I did too. I would say this time he did
not miss his Q.
>> No, he did not. The Q hit for sure. So,
uh that is uh the end of of this round.
I'm not sure if we have any interviews
or or such coming up, but honestly,
yeah, some really really good gameplay.
>> Yeah. I I just think there's so many
cool options that you have with Ye.
Obviously, it does seem like there is
with Volibear as well, but Ye just
really pulled it off so well. Yeah.
Yeah. And it's it's funny because, you
know, uh you have to bunk her up. You
like at the end of the game, you have to
really disregard your legend ability,
right? It's like I need to have as many
units as I can at this battlefield,
especially with the elder dragon on the
board. Uh being able to interact with
just single uh location units. So, uh
you know, being able to play around
that, you know, pivot to that I thought
was good.
>> Yeah, I feel like it was a it would mean
a really smart choice. I feel like
sometimes, especially with those like uh
the legend abilities that you can almost
like get baited into just doing whatever
the legend says. I know I have that
problem sometimes with Ye where I just
went like, "No, I want my plus two." But
instead, he knew exactly what his lose
con was, right, where he would lose if
he lost that battlefield. So, he did so
many I mean really smart choices between
what you're saying with holding with
multiple units and obviously the charm
uh and having one back off a hidden back
off that just did so well in protecting
it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. And so if you're just
joining us we did have two matches we
looked at. We saw no veggies and
himothy. It was a Poppy versus Diana
where the Aurora deck, the the body
deck, was able to win with that. And
then on the other side, we did have
Volibar uh just narrowly lose to Master
Yi. But, you know, really showing that,
you know, there's been a lot of good
body decks, I think, in this format
right now. Yeah, I think that they
there's definitely some fantastic ones
and we saw some great gameplay from both
of those decks that even though they
played Aurora, they seem to still
function without Aurora as well, which
is nice to see.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Cuz there there is just like
a lot of choices. I think it also shows
like cards like Rengar uh from Unleash
has been a really really, you know,
flexible good card. Uh we've been seeing
it being played a lot, not just in the
Rengar decks, right? And uh yeah, that
mobility that that card offers is huge.
Yeah, it seemed to be like one piece
that he like definitely relied on for
situations like that where he maybe
couldn't get around. So, I mean, I
wonder if there's any other pieces that
you can add though in in body that might
still give that access.
>> Yeah, for sure. For sure. And we also
were able to kind of show off the XP
mechanic uh for this one, right, Poppy?
Uh, I think it was able to draw three
additional cards uh through the games
there uh with all the XP it was able to
get and obviously having deflect and
ganking I think was helpful for our
mastery champion unit there. Uh even
though it's mostly just it and scuttle
crabs uh offering the uh the XP there
but uh you know that is just really
important deflect also the potential of
ganking to get to the other battlefield.
Both just strong abilities.
>> Strong abilities especially come into
play when the Volibear is having to
decide like where will my Elder Dragon
damage land? he still had to play that
extra deflect when he then uh targets
the Yi. So, I think that like it can
definitely come into some of these
decisions where especially like you saw
in the Poppy game where those deflect
keywords really came into account when
trying to figure out who they were going
to kill.
>> Yeah. And also, you know, as we're
getting a little bit later in the day,
right, uh being 40 is quite a feat in
its own. Uh but we're seeing like, you
know, why these players are, you know,
earning the records that they have,
right? Uh even for him, right? you know,
it ended up being 2, but that that last
game was so close, right? The being able
to find the way with the Vex really put
uh, you know, no veggies on it to say,
"Hey, you have to have an answer to this
or I'm going to make you go to game
three."
>> Yeah, it was definitely so close. It was
crazy to watch. I I mean, the hype
moment around the charm was absolutely
fantastic trying to figure still having
that back off for the Rengar. So, really
cool. And again, like no veggies has has
to have a lot of experience with it. But
both those times playing the ruinations
like I feel like you got hit immediately
for it, but knowing that you have more
card draw, you have more uh you know
cards in hand on the late game, you can
really take up uh that tempo loss for
it. But man, it it does feel bad when
you again hit two of your own elder
dragons with it.
>> Yeah, I think we also killed like two
harness dragons, so we killed like four
dragons in total. I would have been
afraid to throw down that ruination just
like you're you have you're holding so
strong
>> but he knew right that he had control of
the board taking out who was the only
way. Yes.
>> Uh and so it was really cool to see that
like he knew that his game plan was late
game. So
>> definitely definitely so uh I think
that's going to be actually it for us
for round four. Uh we are going to take
a tiny break before we get to round
five, the second half of the day here,
but we've got a lot of games still
going. a lot of people grinding to get
to that day two and no one's guaranteed
quite yet. So, we're going to take that
break and we'll see you guys in round
number five.
Welcome to a deep dive where Civil Fuse
and I are going to break down one of the
more popular decks of the format. I
mean, we might as well at this point
call it the big bad. We're going to talk
about Dazzling Aurora and I you're my
expert here as I'm going to ask a bunch
of questions to kind of really unlock
and dive deep into why this deck is
having so much success right now and
what can we do as players necessarily to
combat a deck like this. So, of course,
the first one we've got here, Civer
specifically and what we'll talk about
soon, Chaos and Body taking advantage of
Dazzling Aurora. And that's I think one
of the biggest things I want to
highlight here is why are so many
players right now focusing on the chaos
domain to pair with the sort of powerful
strategy within body.
>> Well the big thing is that it allows for
a lot of consistency. We have stack deck
for instance that allows you to filter
through your deck and find those
auroras. We have the lunar boon as well
that allows you to discard a card and
then go through more cards as well. So
the chaos really just allows you to get
that consistency because without aurora
this deck really struggles. Yeah, I
can't I can't disagree with that. That's
really the hardest part and what we've
seen a lot of times maybe even on stream
or watching this deck perform is a lot
of the times if you just like draw the
units instead of drawing the Auroras,
yes, you can still play them, but you've
then like given up more points in the
earlier parts of the game than you
normally would have if you can at least
drop the dazzling on nine runes, of
course. But moving away from the Civer
one specifically, Misfortune brings a
little bit of a different dynamic,
right? We of course we now are focusing
a lot more with Elder Dragon being added
into this deck. And so having an
additional tool in the deck with like
bullet time being able to be paired with
things like Flurry of Blades makes the
removal of this deck specifically very
very powerful because you only need to
spend that one power cost to get the
bullet time really going here to pair
with this and as well as what's just as
good as having these large units giving
them ganking. The mobility of this deck
is huge. Wouldn't you agree?
>> Oh yeah. the fact that you can just
dance around battlefields without having
to really think about it too much and
you're able to establish yourself on one
battlefield, play a unit there, and then
gank the other one over. So, you're able
to build up a ton of might very quickly
and have control of both battlefields
whe rather than just pulling one back
and then having to send it back in
instead.
>> So, I'm playing Chaos Body Dazzling
Aurora. What are the weaknesses that you
would say are probably of this deck?
because we are going to dive in a little
bit further into some of the other
Aurora archetypes that exist out there.
But chaos is so powerful silverfuse. So
like what do I have to use and what do I
do to kind of combat against all of
these you know counter spells that exist
within and then not only just that but
the units are just so strong. Of course
we have things like mind spplitter that
can look at your opponent's hand. Baron
Asher exists on you know chaos. What is
the weakness of this deck?
>> Well a big thing a lot of players are
doing right now is running a bunch of
gear hate. a lot of gear removal,
whether it be in the main board even,
but the sideboard. Almost every player
you'll see is going to be having the
turn to dust and the acceptable losses,
funny enough, also in our chaos domain.
And we see we'll see a lot of gear hate
overall. And the other thing you can do
is be very aggressive against these
lists. We see decks such as Leblanc do
extremely well into Aurora because it's
able to just take control and maintain
those battlefields before Aurora is
really able to get online.
>> That's really the name of the game,
right? you need a very aggressive deck
to kind of take advantage, get those
early points that the deck is already
going to concede to you. But this is
just with Chaos in mind. So, we have a
couple extra variants that we want to
talk about. Maybe some more fun ones as
I'd like to say. So, I believe we've got
Master Yi that is now maybe coming into
the format at this moment because
>> Calm is a very powerful domain. Some
would even say probably even the second
strongest one right now in the format.
And this deck is so interesting because
it also gets to play powerful counter
spells, but cards like Defy are so much
easier to play with because it's only
one energy and a power, whereas the rest
of the things like not so fast, being
able to protect your other units as
well. And Mastery getting that little
bit of extra might and that legend
ability. I think this deck is going to
come in in full force with the weak or
the strength that it brings to the
table.
>> Yes. Uh a big thing that a lot of Aurora
decks have had a hard time into is
yellow decks. We've seen Victor do very
well for instance, but Master Yi with
the Defy and the not so fast as
mentioned is able to say, you know what,
I don't really care about your yellow
removal stuff. I have all this great
stuff that I can play and then protect
very easily. And because we've seen a
lot of mid-range E, we are seeing
players say, you know what, this Aurora
card pretty good. We saw it in set one.
We're going to see it even more in this
tournament.
>> You said protection. Protection really
is the name of the game, especially with
a highlight here for Sonia's Hourglass.
You can even play cards, of course, like
Guardian Angel, which do the similar
effect. But Zonia's Hourglass being able
to keep cards like your Elder Dragons
alive after they've been removed by just
having this nice little hidden or two
drop essentially of this gear that keeps
that unit. You're already playing so few
of these units. Making sure that they
get recalled and back to your base
instead of actually getting killed is
such an important part of this deck. But
I've got one more fun one for you here,
Silverfuse. This is another one that's
kind of up and coming recently. And I
would say when I was in Sydney, a lot of
people were not necessarily on top of
this one, but Poppy Aurora is really
coming into the front here. and you
talked about all the tools that are good
against all the Aurora decks,